WE'RE GOOD MORNING SENATOR. OKAY
JUDICIARY LABOR AND
TRANSPORTATION WILL BEGIN IN
SIXTY. FOUR EIGHT BANK THE.
WE'RE GOOD MORNING SENATOR. OKAY
NOW NOW I CAN BANG YEAH THE
COMMITTEE WILL COME TO ORDER
GOOD MORNING ON TO MY COLLEAGUES
ON TO EVERYONE IN RESPONSE TO
COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS THE
SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
WITH SOME MEMBERS ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE REMOTELY. TODAY THE
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE ARE
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM. THOSE
PROVIDING TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TODAY ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FOR OUR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN THE LEMONADE
IN ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. I ASK
THAT EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT YOU USE THE
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO ON MUTE PLEASE. WE
BEGIN BEGIN. RIGHT WILL PUT YOU
. ON ME WHEN YOU ARE DONE WAS
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN
YOUR DATE TO. THE COMMITTEE TO.
OKAY WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TO THE HEARING ROOM
TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING. DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER. AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED OUR COMMITTEE
SITE AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER. IS
TODAY'S. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR. AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS THREE FIVE
THREE ONE TWO. THREE FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TEAM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
OR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL
BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO
DIAL ONE THEN ZERO. PRESS THIS
ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY
. THAT'S A GOOD WORD- FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT.
ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN THE QUEUE
FOR THE MODERATE TO CALL YOUR
LINE NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU
WILL BE ON MUTE IT AND YOU'RE
NOW READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE KNOW THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY
AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK
YOU MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO
GIVING. OVER THE- IT A- THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY. AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE. OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. UP BEGIN THE
HEARING. BEFORE WE BEGIN LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. SENATOR ALSO
HERE SENATOR GROVE. THE NEW
YORKER TO SENATOR CORTEZ IN YOUR
SENATOR NEWMAN HERE. DO WE HAVE
A QUORUM. THANK YOU- C. THE CORN
HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED THIS IS OUR
FIRST SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE HEARING
THIS WILL BE THE FIRST IT WILL
BE THE FIRST OF TWO HEARINGS
COVERING THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION OR CD C. R. AND
WE WILL COVER JUVENILE JUSTICE
REALIGNMENT- THE- WE GET IN-
SINCE IT'S OUR- HEARING- I JUST
WANT TO- SAY I'M VERY. PROUD AND
EXCITED TO BE CHAIRING THE
SUBCOMMITTEE WE HAVE AN ENORMOUS
OPPORTUNITY THIS SUBCOMMITTEE
COVERS A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT.
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS- AND
THE THERE'S A LOT THAT WE CAN
DO- UP A LOT THAT WE WILL DO- I
ALSO COVERS LABOR AGENCIES AND
TRANSPORTATION OF WEEK I HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO REIMAGINE AND
CONTINUE WITH REFORMING OUR
JUSTICE SYSTEM. AND ADDRESS
RACIAL DISPARITIES BUT WE ALSO
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE
HISTORIC INVESTMENTS IN OUR
WORKFORCE AND CREATE TRUE MIDDLE
CLASS JOB- JUST AS AN EXAMPLE
THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET
PROPOSES APPROXIMATELY FOURTEEN
BILL THE IN THE- ASSIST. FEELING
IN. NONC THROUGH VARIOUS PER AND
THAT'S NOT COUNTING THE FEDERAL
FUNDING COMING TO CALIFORNIA
FROM THE INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT AND JOBS ACT SO-
THOSE ARE THINGS THAT- I WILL
KEEP IN MIND VEHICLE WAS WILL BE
KEEPING IN MIND IS. HOW WE
CREATE THESE CAREER PATHWAYS NEW
AND MORE OF THEM AND THEY ALSO
SERVICE SUPPORTER PROGRAMS FOR
INDIVIDUALS RE ENTERING MARC- SO
WE'VE GOT A CHEAP SHORT TERM AND
LONG TERM- SAVINGS THANK YOU. TO
EVERYONE AS WE MOVE FORWARD I
THINK MY COLLEAGUES IT'S GREAT
IT'S OUR SECOND YEAR TOGETHER.
AND THANK THE STAFF. THANK THIS
. OVER AND OVER THE AGAIN ALL
THAT YOU DO SO HERE WE GO- THE
FIRST ISSUE IS- SEE ISSUE ONE IS
OUR JUVENILE JUSTICE
REALIGNMENT- WE WILL BEGIN OUR
WITH AN UPDATE ON THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUVENILE JUSTICE FROM CDC
ARE. THEY WILL ASK THE OFFICE OF
YOUTH AND COMMUNITY RESTORATION
AND THEN WE WILL HEAR FROM THE
BOARD OF STATE AND COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS- AND- I. OUR FINANCE
TO MAKE ANY COMMENTS ARE ELLIE-
AND THEN OUR COLLEAGUES WILL
HAVE DISCUSSIONS SO. WITH THAT-
TOOLS MAKING THE PRESENTATION
FROM CDC ARE. MORNING MY NAME IS
DR HEATHER BOWLS I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF THE DIVISION OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE. I'LL BE MAKING
COMMENTS TODAY REGARDING THE
UPDATE ON WHERE DJS AT.
CURRENTLY DJS PREPARING FOR THE
END OF A LITTLE CLOSURE IN
RESPONSE TO SB EIGHT TWENTY
THREE BUT I WANT TO MAKE IT
CLEAR THAT OUR FOCUS WILL
CONTINUE. TO BE THE CONTINUITY
OF ALL SERVICE DESK AND
PROVISIONS OF PROGRAMMING. IN A
SAFE. VALIDATOR BIOMETRIC EVERY
YEAR CENTER CARE. CURRENTLY WE
HAVE A POPULATION OF SIX HUNDRED
AND THIRTY THREE YEARS. AND WE
EXPECT THIS POPULATION TO BEGIN
TO REDUCE THE FUTURE MUCH. AS
NOTED DJS TO THE A PLAN FOR THE
USER CARE WHO ARE UNABLE TO
DISCHARGE OR OTHERWISE
TRANSFERRED FROM DJJ BY JUNE
THIRTY OF TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
THIS PLAN IS IN THE FINAL STAGES
OF REVIEW AND WILL BE
FORTHCOMING. FOR THE YOUTH HAVE
AN OP. TO JUST CHARGE PRIOR TO
CLOSURE OUR PROCESSES WILL
REMAIN THE SAME. THEY WILL BE
SEEN BY A JUVENILE PAROLE BOARD
AND GRANTED JUST CHARGE WILL
RETURN TO THE COUNTY OF
COMMITMENT OR RE ENTRY HEARING.
THE MAJORITY OF ARGUES WILL HAVE
THAT OPPORTUNITY PRIOR TO JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
THEREFORE TREATMENT GOALS AND
PROGRAM CONTINUE TO FOR ON.
USING REST. INCREASED ONSTAR-
PAYER AND INITIALLY A SUCCESSFUL
TRANSITION BACK INTO THE
COMMUNITY FOR THIS YEAR. YOU WHO
ARE ABLE TO DISCHARGE BY JUNE
THIRTIETH OF TWENTY TWENTY THREE
WILL BE SHOT FULLY
COLLABORATIVELY TRANSITIONED TO
THE COUNTY JURISDICTION. DJJ IS
FOCUSED ON MAPPING OUT THE NEXT
SEVENTEEN MONTHS AND TERMS OF
SERVICE DELIVERY BASED ON THE
INDIVIDUAL CASE PLAN OF EACH
YEAR. THE NEEDS OF DANGER YEAR
SICKENING AND COMPLEX. WHICH IS
WHY A MEASURE APPROACH ISN'T.
WHEN MAKING DECISIONS REGARDING
HOW TO RETURN YOU. TO COUNTY.
AFFECTED BY DOWN. BASED ON. THE
MANNER IN WHICH THE TRANS OF
CARE IS COORDINATED IS CRITICAL.
THAT ANSWER CARE RECALL- SIDE
FITS. APPROACH AS WE KNOW EACH
YEAR JIMMY. AND EACH CAR IS.
ESSENTIAL OF A TRANSIT PLANNING
ADDRESSING NEEDS HIGHER NEEDS.
HEALTH NEEDS MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS
CONTINUE BECAUSE DEVELOPMENT AND
THAT. EMPLOYMENT AND OTHER
OUTCOMES RELATED TO AVOIDING
RECIDIVISM THAT IS WHY WE HAVE
BEEN AND WILL CONTINUE TO BE
ENGAGED WITH OUR COUNTY PARTNERS
. LEARN INCLUDING YOUR FAMILY IN
ORDER TO DEVELOP INDIVIDUAL
TRANSITION PLANS. THE CHALLENGES
FACING DJJ ISRAEL AND THE PAST
TWO YEARS HAVE BEEN HARD ON THE
USE AND THE STAFF FOR MULTIPLE
REASONS WE'VE HAD ASK FOR TENS.
HE IS A LOT TO OF ANY ONE IT'S
VERY A LOT- ARE STILL HOW TO
COPE WITH DIFFERENT EMOTIONS.
SENSOR AND SHE- WHICH IS WHY WE
ARE FOR. DOES CONTINUE TO
REHABILITATE OF MEASURES. ONE OF
OUR CHALLENGER HAS BEEN
RETENTION STAFF WHO
UNDERSTANDABLY BEEN SEEKING OF
UP. TO HAVE. FOR THE- FAMILIES.
THERE THE ADMINISTRATOR AND
GAZING AGING ELEMENTS
STAKEHOLDERS TO IDENTIFY. TO
ADDRESS THE CHALLENGES AND ALL
HAVE A MORE STAND. AS NO IN THE. AFTER THE- THANK YOU FOR MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU- WE
COULD NOT HAVE THE OFF OF YOU
AND COME REST. THE MORNING MY
NAY IS KATHY LEASE. AND I AM- HE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE
OF YOUTH AND COMMUNITY
RESTORATION AND I CAME ON BOARD
IM EIGHTEENTH. AS AS A REMINDER-
THE- YC OUR GOALS ARE TO
IDENTIFY AND PROMOTE EVIDENCE
BASED PRACTICES FOR
DEVELOPMENTALLY APPROPRIATE
YOUTH REHABILITATION. SUPPORT
COUNTIES IN THEIR REHABILITATION
AND CARE OF YEAR'S AND TO ENSURE
THAT THE VOICES OF USED FAMILIES
VICTIMS ADVOCATES AND OTHER
COMMUNITY MEMBERS. EARNED DURING
THREE. AN UPDATE ON- BECAUSE I
KNOW THAT THAT THAT SPEND A
PENDING IS THAT WE CURRENTLY HAD
HOSTED THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
POSITION AND THE ASSISTANT TO
THE DIRECTOR POSITIONS WHICH-
DUE TODAY- AND THAT WE ALSO HAVE
GOTTEN A STARTED THEY COUNTY
COORDINATION EATEN UP POSITIONS.
THE SAYS SOME SPECIALIST THE SSM
. AND WE- ROLL CAGE HE
REPOSITIONS M. ARE- HOPE TO- I
TRY. AT A POTENTIAL- WORK THAT
IS HAS LIFE EXPERIENCE AND- WE
AT THE S. SOMEONE SPECIALIST AND
THE AS A SOME TO. ARGUE TODAY
AND HELD OPEN THE HEPA POSITIONS
UNTIL THE FIFTEENTH. WE ARE
CURRENTLY AND PARTICIPATION IN
CROSS AGENCY INITIATIVES- FOR
EXAMPLE THE G. THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL SECURE USE TRACK OFFENSE
BASED CLASSIFICATION WORKGROUP I
AM A MEMBER OF THAT WORK GROUP
APPOINTED BY THE CHIEF JUSTICE.
FOR ALL THE WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
COURT AND PROBATION STATISTICAL
SYSTEMS REPLACEMENT AND SYSTEM
WORK GROUP. AND THAT- COUNCIL
FOR THAT WORK GROUP A LISA HART.
WHO WAS HIRED ABOUT A MONTH
BEFORE ME- IS CURRENTLY THE O.
Y. C. R. REPRESENTATIVE ON THAT
COMMITTEE. WE'RE ALSO OF WORKING
AND LOOKING AT B. O. Y. C. R.
SUB COMMITTEE OF THE CHILD
WELFARE COUNCIL. THEY HAVE NOT
MET FOR SOME TIME BUT WE ARE
HOPING TO MEET AND MARCH AGAIN
AND BECOME A ROBUST PART OF FEET
DISCUSSIONS IN THE CHILD WELFARE
ACCOUNT. SO AT HAVE MET WITH THE
CENTER FOR DATA IN AND IN OF.
ABOUT HOW WE CAN- USE ME- NEW
THAT NEW DEPARTMENT AND HOW WE
CAN COLLABORATE. SO THAT WE CAN
ULTIMATELY- HAVE AT BEST
PRACTICES BEST OUTCOMES
EVERYTHING DOCUMENTED AND LOOK
AT OTHER DATA POINTS THAT WE
NEED. AND THEN OF CHILDREN AND
YOUTH. INITIATIVE IS SOMETHING
THAT WE ARE IN- ALREADY
BEGINNING TO HAVE SOME CROSS
DISCUSSION ABOUT. OR A VERY MUCH
ENGAGED WITH STATE PARTNERS SUCH
AS THE JUVENILE COURT JUDGES OF
CALIFORNIA WE SEE- IT'S THAT
IT'S CRITICAL FOR US TO- A LINE
SOME OF THESE- PARTNERSHIPS JUST
LIKE WE'RE DOING THE
REALIGNMENT. I WHERE- VALUE AND-
ARE VERY MUCH- ENGAGED WITH THE
DJJ. OUR PARTNER. DSS DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES. AND HE
COUNCIL I'M CRIMINALAND
BEHAVIORAL. WITH REGARD TO OUR
PARTNERSHIP AND ENGAGEMENT WITH
B. S. C. ST WE'VE ALREADY MET A
COUPLE OF TIMES TO DISCUSS AREAS
OF JOINT RESPONSIBILITY. WILL BE
ON THE REGULATE. FOR SECURING
INSTRUCTORS CELANESE EXECUTIVE
STEERING COMMITTEE AND WE HAVE
ALREADY BEGUN TO OUR DISCUSSIONS
ON THE CONCURRENCE ON THE
GROUNDS. AND WHAT THAT MEANS FOR
OUR- I HAVE ALL ATTENDED THE
STATE ADVISORY. ON JJ-
DELINQUENCY PER ANIMAL WE WILL
BE PRESENTING FORMALLY IN APRIL. ARE ALSO VERY MUCH OF THE END.
OF BUILDING COUNTY. A PARTNER%
AND RELATIONSHIPS AS AND OUR
GOAL IS TO HAVE- ONGOING AND
ROBUST RELATIONSHIPS WITH SYSTEM
PARTNERS COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. ADVOCATES AND
WHERE POSSIBLE- AT FAMILIES. I
IN THAT REGARD WE AND HAVE
ALREADY BEEN IN DISCUSSIONS WITH
C. **** THE CHIEF PROBATION
OFFICERS OF CALIFORNIA. IT IS
IMPORTANT FOR US TO HAVE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS PUBLIC DEFENDERS
VICTIM SERVICES AND ADVOCATES
SUCH AS HUMAN RIGHTS WATCH
CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE USING
COMMUNITY JUSTICE. THE USUAL
CENTER AT. JUST A FEW- PARTNER.
WITH THREE TO THE COUNTY. ALL
FIFTY EIGHT PLANS WERE SUBMITTED
TIMELY AND WE HAVE DEVELOPED A
PLAN REVIEW PROCESS AND ARE
CURRENTLY ENGAGED IN THAT REVIEW
PROCESS. WHERE ARE CHARGES TO
ENSURE FAITHFUL COMPLIANCE WITH
THE STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS TO
IDENTIFY PRIORITY AREAS FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND SUPPORT
WITH BEST PRACTICES TRAINING
GRANT PROGRAMS AND OTHER STATE.
PORT TWO COUNTIES OUR DESIRE IS
TO BUILD RELATIONSHIPS TO
FACILITATE THE EXCHANGE OF
INFORMATION AND RELIANCE ON THE
OFFICE OF YOUTH AND COMMUNITY
RESTORATION AS AN EXPERT IN THE
FIELD. A FEW OF OUR NEXT STEP IS
TO COMPLETE THE PLAN RADIO. TO
GET STAFFED UP ANY AHMED'S
PERSON IS A TOP PRIORITY AND
WE'RE HOPING IN THE NEAR FUTURE
WE WILL HAVE THIS POSITION
FILLED. WE- AS MENTIONED WERE
EVERY LAUNCH THE OFFICE OF YOUTH
CAN BE REST SUCH COMMITTEE OF
THE CHILD COUNCIL. PURSUANT TO
S. B. TWO THREE AND OF COURSE WE
WILL CONTINUE TO BUILD
PARTNERSHIPS WITH IMPLEMENTERS
AND ADVOCATES. AND THOSE ARE AND
THE CONCRETE NEXT STEPS. THANK
YOU FOR LETTING ME PRESENT AND
THAT WILL- AND MY COMMENTS.
THANK YOU MISS LOU SEVERAL- NEXT
WE HAVE THE BOARD OF STATE AND
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS. AND
MORNING SENATOR ALL I'M KATHLEEN
HOWARD KATIE HOWARD THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE PSEC
IS THE AUDIO OKAY YES GREAT-
HELLO SENATORS AND HAPPY NEW
YEAR I'M HAPPY TO BE HERE TO
PROVIDE SOME ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION ABOUT THE NEED FOR
THE FUNDING THAT IS PROPOSED IN
THE BUDGET. MILLION DOLLARS.
TWENTY MILLION FOR IMPROVEMENTS
AND TO GIVE YOU SOME SENSE WHERE
WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
DEVELOPING A PLAN FOR HOW THAT
FUNDING WILL GO OUT AND IN
GENERAL TERMS THIS PROPOSAL
RESPONDS TO VERY PRESSING AND
CURRENT AND TIME SENSITIVE NEEDS
FOR THE COUNTIES TO MODERNIZE
AND UPDATE TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN
MEETING THESE IMPORTANT GOALS
DJJ REALIGNMENT AS YOU'VE
ALREADY HEARD ABOUT FROM DOCTOR
BULLS AND FROM DIRECTOR THE
CERRO- THE SERVICES. ARE NOW
GOING TO BE THAT RESPONSIBILITY
. YOU HAD THE REMINDER FROM DJJ
ABOUT THE NUMBERS OF USERS WHO
ARE STILL IN DJJ AND- WHO ARE
ANTICIPATED TO BE IN COUNTY CARE
WITHIN THE NEXT FEW MONTHS- ON
THE- NEED TO REMAIN ON THAT
POLICY CALLS AT THIS.
SIGNIFICANT PROGRAMMATIC CHANGE
AT THE STATE LEVEL- TO INCLUDE
THAT THE PROGRAMMING AND
TREATMENT SUPPORTS ARE THERE
POSITIVE YOUTH DEVELOPMENT-
SERVICES NEED TO BE
DEVELOPMENTALLY APPROPRIATE
TRAUMA INFORMED AND- THE CHEAP
THE GOAL OF KEEPING YOUNG PEOPLE
CLOSER TO HOME- ON. COUNTIES
NEED TO A TO PROVIDE YOU WITH
THAT BEST OPPORTUNE POSSIBLE AND
THERE IS A CONCERN I THINK SURE
BY ALL THAT IF THE COUNTY
DOESN'T FEEL THEY'RE PREPARED TO
MEET THOSE NEEDS THAT THERE
COULD BE AN INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF YOUNG PEOPLE TRANSFER
TO ADULT CRIMINAL COURT. WITH
DJJ IS NO LONGER AN OPTION THE
COUNTIES ARE MOVING REALLY
QUICKLY AND THEY NEED TO BE
READY AS SOON AS POSSIBLE- AND
THAT LENDS TO THE URGENCY OF
GETTING THIS FINDING OUT
UNDERSTANDING THE QUESTIONS THAT
HAVE COME UP FROM THE L. A. O.
AND- IN THE COMMITTEE AGENDA
ABOUT SOME OF THE DETAILS THAT
NEED TO BE PRESENT. FOR THAT-
YOU KNOW TO ALL COME TOGETHER SO
AS DIRECTOR OF THE SEVERAL
MENTIONED THAT FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTY PLANS HAVE BEEN.
SUBMITTED I'M AND PROPOSAL- IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR A
HUNDRED. NOT TO BE IN THE NUMBER
OF BEDS COUNTY I KNOW THERE BEEN
SOME IF UP IN A COUPLE OF CON
ABOUT FINDING THAT THE STATE HAS
HAD PROVIDED OVER THE PAST TEN
YEARS SO YOUR EIGHTY ONE THAT
WAS TO MEET A VERY POLICY NEED
TO ABOUT TWO YEARS- WHEN JOURNAL
REALIGNMENT FIRST BEGAN- ON THE
COUNTY'S WERE GOING TO BE
RECEIVING MORE- USE IN THEIR
CARE AND AT THAT TIME MORE VETS
WERE NEEDED THIS IS A DIFFERENT
TIME AND A DIFFERENT NEED AND
THE KINDS OF THINGS THAT ARE TO
BE FUNDED WITH THIS ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. OKAY THE SPACE
AND MAKING LOCAL FACILITY.
CONDUCIVE FOR THE KIND OF
BANNING AND TREATMENT-
RESIDENTIAL NEEDS AND RE ENTRY
NEEDS FOR ALL OF YOU SAID THE
SYSTEM NOW INCLUDING THE USER
WOULD HAVE WHO MIGHT HAVE BEEN
PLACED IN DJJ PRIOR TO
REALIGNMENT- DIRECTOR ZERO
TOUCHED ON THIS BUT THE PENDING
REGULATIONS FOR SECURE YOU
DROPPED. OUT SECURING TREATMENT
FACILITIES WILL BEGIN OUR BOARD
WILL LAUNCH THAT PROCESS NEXT
WEEK- AND AS DIRECTOR THE SIR
MENTION SHE'S AGREED TO
PARTICIPATE ON THE EXECUTIVE
STEERING COMMITTEE. TO DEVELOP
THOSE REGULATIONS WORK WE'RE
CONTINUING TO COLLABORATE ALL OF
THIS YEAR. BILITY IS WITHOUT Y.
C. R. TURNING TO THE NEED THAT-
COUNTIES HAVE THEY WERE ARE. YES
CONDUCTED A SURVEY ON IN THE
CONTEXT OF THE NINE POINT IX
MILLION DOLLARS THAT WAS
ALLOCATED OUT. UNDER SB EIGHT
TWENTY THREE AND THAT WAS USED
TO MEET SOME OF THE IMMEDIATE
NEEDS BUT THIS THIS FUNDING IS
INTENDED TO ADDRESS A BROADER
RANGE OF FACILITY IMPROVEMENTS
IN THE COUNTIES. AND THESE
INCLUDE THINGS LIKE IMPROVING
OUTDOOR RECREATIONAL AND OPEN
SPACE UPDATING AND UPGRADING
HOUSING UNITS FOR PURCHASING
FURNITURE THAT CAN CREATE A MORE
HOME LIKE ENVIRONMENT AND THIS
IS OFTEN REFERRED TO AS-
SOFTENING THE INSTITUTIONAL
STEEL- SOME COUNTIES YOU NEED
FUNDING TO UPDATE CAMERAS AND
OTHER KINDS OF TECHNOLOGICAL
SUPPORTS. AND THEY'RE COUNTIES
HAVE NEEDS FOR SPACE FOR
MODERNIZE CLASSROOMS OUR
CLASSROOMS FOR HIGH SCHOOL AND
COLLEGE LEVEL COURSES AS WELL AS
TRAINING ON THE JOB TRAINING
VOCATIONAL TRAINING. I'M RIGHT
HI. I'M ALSO PLEASE MIND THAT
THE COUNTY JAIL. THESE ARE QUITE
FOR. SO IMPROVEMENTS BY ADDING
PLUMBING FOR TOILETS ARE SO.
SINK IN THE USE LEADING ROOM-
WOULD BE AN EXAM OF AN- AND
REALLY QUITE COSTLY UPGRADE SO
THE BOTTOM LINE HERE IS THAT THE
COUNTIES HAVE SIGNIFICANT AND
TIME SENSITIVE NEEDS TO IMPROVE.
AND UPDATE THE FACILITIES- WE'RE
ACTIVE CONVERSATION WITH THE-
AND FIND ABOUT. LAST EXPEDITE
YOUR WORKING OF THESE IN WILL
CAN TO THAT I WE KNOW THAT MORE
AND FOR IS ME. AND CERTAINLY THE
THAT IN THE AT ABOUT- IN. THE
FUNDING. IS SPENT ON WHAT'S AND
TO DO WE WITH ALL SORTS OF AND
AND OTHER GET THOSE. NEED TO BE
OUT IN THE- AND I'M HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY. YOU HAVE. GREAT I
THANK YOU HOWARD. HOW WE MOVE
NOW TO SEE IF- FINANCE. HAVE A
OF. I DON'T THINK DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NOTE I SPECIFIC COMMENTS
AT THIS TIME. HAPPY AND
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU ISSUE IT- THE L. A. O. ANY
COMMENTS. HI THERE. I YEAH WE
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
AND STAFF MY NAME'S ORLANDO
SANCHEZ WITH THE L. A. L. AND WE
WANT WE JUST WANTED PRIVACY
COMMENTS WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE RECHECK THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED COUNTY
OPERATED JUVENILE FACILITY
GRANTS PROGRAM BECAUSE THE
ADMINISTRATION DID NOT PROVIDE
SUFFICIENT INFORMATION ON HOW IT
ARRIVED AT THE A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR ESTIMATE AND IT IS NOT
CLEAR BY THE ADDITIONAL. THIS
NASA. THANK YOU. THAT LED TO OUR
RIGHT AND THAT ARE ALL IN THE-
PRIMARILY THE UPPER IS NOT BASED
ON ASSESSMENT OF FACILITY NEED.
SO WHAT THE ADMINISTRATOR
CONDUCTED A SURVEY TO DETERMINE
WHETHER COUNTIES WOULD BE
INTERESTED IN THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDS. ASSESSMENT BEEN CARRIED
OUT TO IDENTIFY THE SPECIFIC
DEFICIENCIES OR SHOW THE EXTENT
TO WHICH COUNTY FACILITY NEEDS
ARE IN NEED OF REPAIR. OR NOT
ADEQUATE TO PROVIDE THE REHAB
SERVICES TO THE REAL LINE USE.
THIS MAKES IT DIFFICULT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO EVALUATE THE
APPROPRIATENESS OF THE PROPOSED
A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS. IN
ADDITION WHEN CONSIDERING
WHETHER COUNTIES ARE IN NEED OF
THIS FUNDING. THE LEGISLATURE
MAY WANT TO CONSIDER TWO THINGS
. THE FIRST IS THAT IN RECENT
YEARS THE LEGISLATURE HAS
PROVIDED THREE HUNDRED MILLION
FOR DRIVEN OUT COUNTY FACILITIES
. AND THIS HAS LED TO NEWLY
CONSTRUCTED BED SPACE SOME
REPAIRS THAT- ARE ONLY RECENTLY
COMING ON LINE. IS NEWLY
CONSTRUCTED SPACES MAY BE BETTER
CONDITION AND MORE CONDUCIVE FOR
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMMING. THE
SECOND ONE IS THAT COUNTIES HAVE
THE ABILITY TO CONTRACT WITH
EACH OTHER FOR ADDITIONAL SPACE
FOR NEEDS. IT IS POSSIBLE THAT
SOME COUNTIES MAN FACILITY NEEDS
. HOWEVER THEY MAY BE ABLE TO
PARTNER WITH A DIFFERENT COUNTY
IN A SURVEY CONDUCTED BY THE
PSEC. AFTER REALIGNMENT SHOWED
THAT SOME COUNTIES WOULD BE
INTERESTED IN TAKING REALIGNED
YEARS. FOR THESE REASONS WE
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
REJECT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
IN THE CASE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS ABLE TO
PROVIDE A DETAILED ASSESSMENT OF
THOSE COUNTY FACILITY NEEDS THAT
pCONSTRUCTED BATES. AND THE
INABILITY TO PARTNER WITH OTHER
COUNTIES IN THE FUTURE THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER THE
GRANTS AT THAT TIME. AND THE
LAST TIME WE PLAY TO MAKE ABOUT
THIS PROPOSAL A- IT IS
EXCLUDABLE UNDER THE STATE
APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT AND AS A
REMINDER TO THE LEGISLATURE THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION IMPOSES
A LIMIT. ON THE AMOUNT OF
REVENUE THE STATE CONCRETE EACH
YEAR ALSO CALLED THE CELL. STATE
CANNING EXCLUDES CERTAIN
APPROPRIATIONS FROM THIS
CALCULATION. AS SUCH IF THE
LEGISLATURE. DECIDES TO REJECT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IT WOULD
NEED TO REPURPOSE THE SALUTE
ASSOCIATED FUNDING FOR OTHER SAU
RELATED PURPOSES. HAPPY TO
ADDITIONAL. THANK YOU MISTER
SANCHEZ- WE NOW- I TURNED TO MY
COLLEAGUES HERE IN THE IN THE
COMMITTEE- FOR YOUR COMMENTS ARE
QUESTIONS FROM FROM THE PANEL- I
JUST WANT TO START IF I CAN WITH
. A COUPLE OF QUICK- I'M
PROBABLY FOR THE- ADMINISTRATION
BUT ARE RELATED TO THE DJ JAKE
UP CLOSURE COULD YOU SUM UP WHAT
YOU BELIEVE ARE THE MAIN
CHALLENGES. THAT WOULD YOU KNOW
OF RELATED TO THE CLOSURE- YOU
KNOW HOW HOW DO YOU SEE HANDLING
THOSE- ON MAJOR CHALLENGES. YES
SO- I DO YOU SEE AS AS I
MENTIONED ONE OF THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGE WE HAVE RESTARTING
STOPPING WHICH IS ONE. OF THE
ADMINISTRATION AND DJ ARE VERY
FOCUSED ON FINDING SOLUTIONS TO
THAT- IT WAS DISGUSTING THAT
WITH THE- THAT WE WOULD MAKE
SURE TO ENGAGE AGGRESSIVELY-
EARLY IN THE YEAR WHICH WE HAVE
DONE- I THINK BECAUSE IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT WE ARE ABLE TO
CONTINUE OUR REHABILITATIVE
PASSAGE. RESULTED A FASHION WITH
THE YOUTH IN OUR CARE THROUGH
CLOSURE THAT IS WHY. RESULTING
THAT ISSUE AND WE'RE THROUGH IS
CRITICAL. THANK YOU FROM. GIVE
THAT THE DEPARTMENT AT THIS
POINT IS PROJECTING OVER FOUR
HUNDRED YOUTH REMAINING AT DJJ
ON THE CLOSURE DATE- WHAT ARE
YOUR THOUGHTS OR PLANS FOR
TRANSFERRING THE USED TO THE
COUNTIES. AND I WILL CHRISTIAN
FIRST CAN ADDRESS. HOT REJECTION
- WHAT I WILL SAY IN TERMS OF
THE NUMBERS IS- AS I MENTIONED
THAT YOU KNOW WE HAVE THE SIX
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE YEARS
AND THE MAJORITY OF THEM YOU
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY. TO THAT
DISCHARGED PRIOR TO JUNE. OF
TWENTY TWENTY THREE SO PART OF
WHAT WE'RE FOCUSED ON IS
BUSINESS GOES BACK TO THE
IMPORTANCE OF A REHABILITATIVE.
MISSION IS TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
YOU THOSE SERVICES IN THE HOPES
THAT THEY ARE THEY'RE WORKING
TOWARDS THOSE TREATMENT GOALS
AND WHEN THEY GO IN FRONT OF THE
PAROLE BOARD HAVE A GOOD
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCHARGE AND GO
BACK TO THE COUNTIES. WHICH
WOULD BE OUR CURRENT PROCESSES
THEY WOULD GO INTO A RE ENTRY.
GO TO RE ENTRY HERE. AND THEN-
AFTER INJURY AS WE DO NOW
THERE'S. MAKING SURE THERE'S AT
DEPENDING UPON WHAT THE USERNAME
FOR PLACE AND SUPER. FOR THOSE
YOU CAN'T JUST- AND ALSO THAT
THOSE. WE FOLK ON AGAIN THOSE.
PAROLE AND SO IT IS FLUENT IN
TERMS OF THOSE NUMBERS FOR YOU
HAVE THAT POSSIBILITY AND SO FOR
THOSE USE THAT DOWN ON OUR END
WE'RE PRIMARILY FOCUSED ON AGAIN
. THAT IT PROVIDING TREATMENT
THROUGH CLOSURE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THOSE GOALS AND THEN IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION AROUND THAT
INDIVIDUAL TRANSFER PLAN. THAT
ONE FITS ONE MILE AND I. ONE
KEEP EMPHASIZING BECAUSE I THINK
THAT. BECOME AN IMPORT CHALLENGE
AND ONE THAT I KNOW MY AND OUR
ARE VERY FOLK ON IS AGAIN
RACKING EACH YEAR THIS GONNA TO
PRO JEFF SUPERVISION DIFFERENCE-
SUPPORT SYSTEMS BASED ON THEIR
INDIVIDUAL NEEDS AND SO WE WILL
NEED TO HAVE INDIVIDUAL
CONVERSATIONS FOR EACH OF THOSE
YEARS AS TRANSFER BACK TO THE
COUNTIES. MMHM THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SO IT SEEMS LIKE. WE HAVE
ARE YOU THAT ARE GOING TO BE
TRANSFERRED TO THE COUNTY THE
COUNTY NEED TO BE READY WITH ALL
THE SERVICES AND- OFF FOR THOSE
YOUTH WE HAVE YOUTH THAT ARE.
NOT YET READY NOT GOING TO BE
TRANSFERRED HOPEFULLY BEFORE.
THE TWENTY FIVE TWENTY BAKLOH.
AND THEN THEY'LL STILL BE A NEED
FOR SOME NUMBER OF YOUTH ARM
THAT WILL CONTINUE TO BE OUR
SUPPORTED BY STATE IS THAT. THAT
MAKES SENSE THAT SORT OF ORDER
AND THEN- BASIC NEEDS. REALLY AT
DIFFERENT GROUPS IS THAT GROUP
THAT CAN'T CONTINUE WITH OUR
REGULAR PROCESSES BEACH CHARGE
PRIOR TO THAT JUNE THIRTIETH
DATE AND THOSE YOU'RE HERE.
AREN'T ON TO DISCHARGE BY THAT
JUNE THIRTIETH SEPT TWENTY
TWENTY THREE DATE AND WILL NEED
TO CONTINUED SUPPORT AND
TREATMENT AS THEY RETURNED. TO
THE COUNTY. OKAY THANK YOU- WITH
REGARDS TO THE FACILITIES-
THAT'S- EARNED HOWARD FILE WITH
REGARD TO THE FACILITIES CAN YOU
JUST DESCRIBE A BIT ABOUT HOW
YOU UP APPROACH GO TO SO THAT WE
DON'T END UP WITH OF CONTINUED
LIKE ENVIRONMENT FOR THOSE YOUTH
. MANAGER THANK YOU JUST GAVE ME
AN UPGRADE IN MY AGE I'M NOT A
DOCTOR. HE. ANY HOW. THE- THE
PLAN AND I THINK THE THIS WOULD
BE ONE OF THE THAT THE BUDGET
MAKERS PROCESS YOU KNOW COULD
YOU I THINK THAT THAT THE PLAN
THAT THEY CAN HAVE SUBMITTED AND
THAT AWAITS YOU IS IN THE OF
REVIEWING- YOU KNOW WHAT WE WILL
FIND IN THERE ARE ALL RIGHTY-
APPROACHES TO IMPLEMENTATION
THAT THE COUNTIES HAVE- PUT
TOGETHER TO COVER THE CONTINUUM
NEED. YOUNG IN. COLLUDING THE
USER FORM ON MY HAVE BEEN HOUSED
DJ JAY SO THE NEEDS- ACROSS THE
COUNTRY WELCOME FROM THE PLANS-
I IMAGINE THAT SOME CONVERSATION
HERE ABOUT HOW TO ENSURE WHAT
THE PRIORITY- APPROACHES SHOULD
BE WOULD BE SOMETHING THAT THAT
WE COULD ALL WORK OUT. AT THE-
CHANCE THAT WE ARE HEARING ABOUT
FROM THE COUNTY IS ABOUT-
NEEDING THE PROGRAMMING IT
TREATMENT MEANS HAVING A SPACE
THAT'S CONDUCIVE TO
REHABILITATION AND TRAUMA
INFORMED CARE AND BETTER
CLASSROOM SPACES REALLY ONE OF
THE KEY DIFFERENCES IN BRINGING
- YOU STILL MIGHT HAVE GONE TO
DJJ UNDER THE OLD MODEL IS THAT
THAT THAT THE YOUNG PEOPLE.
MIGHT BE UNDER COUNTY
SUPERVISION FOR A LARGER NUMBER
OF YEARS YOU KNOW DEPENDING ON
ON WHAT THE ISSUE IS WITH NEEDS
QUITE- TREATMENT IN PROGRAMMING
TO ADDRESS PERHAPS MORE SEVERE
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES FOR. THIS
PROGRAMMING FOR A SEX OFFENDERS
AND THOSE SORTS OF THINGS SO-
WHEN I HEAR YOU SAY MADAM CHAIR
WE DON'T WANT MORE PRISON LIKE
ENVIRONMENTS THAT THEY CAN LEVEL
THOSE ARE THE SAME CONVERSATIONS
THAT THE COUNTIES ARE HAVING TO.
SO HOW CAN YOU ENSURE THAT THE
RIGHT KIND OF HOUSING IS
AVAILABLE AS WELL AS TREATMENT
AND SERVICES AND EHABILITATION
ACROSS THE CONTINUUM OF MEATS.
OKAY THANK YOU NOT NOT DOCTORS
NOT DR HOWARD. ONLY A MASTER'S
DEGREE OKAY MASTER POWER- OKAY
JUST TURNED TO MY COLLEAGUES AND
FOUND FOR ANY OR COMMENTS. YES
SENATE. YOU OKAY COMMITTEE AND
THANK YOU FOR THE GREAT QUESTION
A U. S. HIM- I'VE FIRST WAS WHEN
ASSEMBLY EXCITED ABOUT WORLD
THIS IS GOING AND- EVEN MORE
EXCITED TO SEE. WHAT A
TREMENDOUS TEAM. WE HAVE FOR YOU
HAVE- IN TERMS OF THOSE WHO JUST
PRESENTED- DIRECTOR WAS ZERO I'M
GONNA HAVE A HARD TIME NOT
REFERRING TO THE JUDGE WAS ZERO-
BASED ON YOUR BACKGROUND. I HAVE
A QUESTION IS ACTUALLY TURNED
OUT TO BE A- I HAVE TWO
QUESTIONS BUT DON'T WANT ONE OF
THEM HAS IS A- IS KIND OF A
NATURAL. SEGUE IF YOU WILL. TO
THE LAST QUESTION RICHARD JUST
PASSED IN THE RESPONSE. WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE FACILITIES DOLLARS-
YOU KNOW THERE WERE DELIBERATING
OVER TO SOME DEGREE. THE
QUESTION IN MY MIND AND BELIEVE
ME I FULLY UNDERSTAND THE
DIFFERENTIAL BETWEEN. BONNIES IN
PENN WHAT. THEY NEED- IN HIS
WORDS SOME OF THEM ARE ARE MUCH
BETTER OFF THAN OTHERS AS MORE
COMPANIES ARE GOING TO HAVE A
DIFFERENT CHALLENGE YOU KNOW
BASED ON MY OWN BACKGROUND OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENT- THE PARTY UP
TO THE LAST QUESTION OF THE LAST
TWO QUESTIONS WAS ABOUT- YOU
KNOW THIS WONDERFUL INSIGHT THAT
ALL YOU HAVE BEEN TO INDIVIDUAL
ASSESSMENT. IN IN THE NEED FOR
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT. IN
OTHER RESOURCES AND I'M JUST
WONDERING IF I DON'T KNOW IF
THIS IS A QUESTION FOR. DIRECTOR
SIR OR- MISS HOWARD- WHICH OF
YOU. BY AT WHAT POINT DO WE
START LOOKING AT FURTHER
DIRECTING. THE FACILITIES
DOLLARS WITH REFERENCE TO THE
POLICY AROUND. THOSE THINGS
INDIVIDUAL ASSESSMENT AND MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT I MEAN THERE'S
IN A- JUST. WHO THAT'S THE
QUESTION I WILL TELEGRAPH MY
OPINION WHICH IS THAT MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT FACILITY SHOULD
BE MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT
FACILITIES AND JAIL SHOULD BE
JAILS- AND IN THE TWO SHOULD NOT
BE- CONFLATED EVEN THOUGH WE'VE
DONE THAT FOR. A COUPLE THOUSAND
YEARS- IN WESTERN CIVILIZATION
AND SO I'M I'M VERY MUCH
INTERESTED IN SEPARATING THOSE
TWO- BUT I'M JUST WONDERING WHAT
YOUR THOUGHTS ARE GOING FORWARD. FOR YOU TO ASSUME THAT THE
SENATOR. BUT DIRECTOR ZERO I
GUESS I CAN START WITH HER AND-
LET HER REFER TO SOMEBODY ELSE
SO SHE WANTS TO. THANKYOU
SENATOR CORTESE FOR- YEAH KIND
OF ELEVATING THAT ISSUE- YOU'RE
YOU'RE EXACTLY RIGHT- I THINK
THAT THE PROGRAM BEING THE
MENTAL HEALTH APPROACHES THE
GENDER RESPONSIVE CULTURAL
CHARLIE RESPONSIVE APPROACHES
ARE CRITICAL- BUT I THINK WHAT
WHAT IS ALSO HISTORICALLY BEEN
TRUE IS THAT THE LOCAL JUVENILE
DETENTION FACILITIES ARE NOT-
MORE CONCEIVED AS THERAPEUTIC
LOCATIONS. AND WHAT WE KNOW
ABOUT- ARE YOU- IS THAT MANY OF
THEM WILL BE SPENDING.
UNFORTUNATELY YEARS- DEPENDING
ON WHAT WE ULTIMATELY AFTER AS
FAR AS THAT THAT COMMITMENT
MATRIX BUT THERE IT IS POSSIBLE
THAT SOME OF THE DEEPER AND
HIGHER AND- PUBLIC SAFETY YOU
WILL NEED TO BE IN A FACILITY
FOR. AND UNDER AND- THESE
DETENTION FACILITIES OR
DEVELOPED. IN THAT REGARD AND
BECAUSE WE'RE GOING INTO THIS
LOCAL APPROACH WE WANT WE WANT
FACILITIES THAT HAVE FAMILY
ENGAGEMENT. PLACED PLACES WE
WANT ARE YOU PARENTING USE TO
HAVE MEANINGFUL RELATIONSHIPS
WITH THEIR CHILDREN BECAUSE OUR
YOUTH WILL BE RE ENTERING AND RE
ENTRY WILL BE PLANNED FOR FROM
DAY ONE IN OUR PAST DISABILITY.
AND I THINK WHAT WHAT WE CAN
LOOK TOWARDS ALSO ULTIMATELY IS
WHAT KIND OF STEP DOWN
PROGRAMMING THERE WILL BE
BECAUSE I'M THINKING THAT. THE
NEED FOR THAT WHOLE OPERATION
FROM SOCIETY AND- I'M HOPING
THAT BECAUSE WE'LL HAVE GOOD
PROGRAMMING THAT THAT WON'T BE
LIKE THE- THAT- FOR EXAMPLE AS
YOU KNOW IN OUR OWN COUNTY
SENATOR CORTESE WE HAD. BOTH
TENSION HAS BEEN AROUND
VISIBILITY BUT EVEN THAT EVEN
THE STEP DOWN FACILITIES ARE
GOING TO NEED- MORE THEY'RE
GONNA AT ARCHITECTURAL IN OUR
OWN COUNTY THE WINDOWS NEED TO
BE CHANGED BECAUSE OF HIGH RISK
. YOU PLAY SPENT DEFINITIONS
VERSUS MEDIUM REST- FENCING AND
SOME OF THE COUNTIES WILL HAVE
TO BE CHANGED OR UPGRADED SO I
THINK IT'S BOTH. I THINK I THINK
WE WANT OUR DEEPEST HAVE
CONFIDENCE THAT THEY DON'T NEED
TO FILE TRANSFER MOTIONS FOR
EVERY SIXTEEN AND SEVENTEEN YEAR
OLD. AND THAT CONFIDENCE IS
BUILT WHEN WE HAVE MEANINGFUL
PLACES FOR YOU TO BE. NOT AND
NOT IN THE CASE WHILE THEY
UNDERGO REALLY IMPORTANT TRAIN
MISSION WORK SO I THINK IT'S
BOTH AND I DIDN'T. THE ANSWER
YOUR QUESTIONS. BUT I THINK
THERE'S A LOT WORK TO DO IN THE-
THAT WE'RE HAVE ARE USED AND
THAT'S A LOT OF WORK TO DO IN
THE PROGRAMMING. THANK THANK YOU
. THROUGH TOUR DIRECTOR. A US
READ YOU ADD TO THE QUESTION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BUT I DON'T
THINK. I GUESS MORE SPECIFICALLY
THAT I PROBABLY DIDN'T
ARTICULATE WELL THE QUESTION IS
ARE THERE SHOULD HOW MUCH OF IT
IS LOCAL CONTROL IN TERMS OF
THOSE DESIGN ELEMENTS THAT YOU
WERE JUST DESCRIBING- YOU KNOW
THINGS. DON'T AND HOW MUCH OF
IT. IT YOU KNOW HOW MUCH THAT
WILL WILL BE REQUIRED TO BE
SIGNED OFF IN TERMS OF THE GRANT
APPLICATIONS. VERSUS DEFERENCE
LOCAL CONTROL- IF THAT'S NOT IT
IN EASY ANSWER I COULD CERTAINLY
TALK OFF LINE AND JUST ONE BEING
. IF THIS SORT OF EIGHT. FROM
THE STATE LEVEL A BLANK CHECK
TYPE OF THE GRANT HERE WE KNOW
YOU'RE ALL DIFFERENT WE NOTIFIED
COUNTIES HAVE BOARDS OF
SUPERVISORS IN COUNTY EXECUTIVES
IN ADMINISTRATION AND PROBATION
AND YOU KNOW WHAT TO DO SO
HERE'S THE MONEY AND GO TO WHAT
YOU THINK YOU SHOULD DO OR
ARTISTRY. GROWTH TO THOSE WHO
JUST. AND KATIE CAN YOU CAN YOU
HANDLE THAT QUESTION SURE IT
DIRECTLY SERRA I WILL TRY ON I
FEEL LIKE WELL FIRST OF ALL I
JUST WANNA GIVE A SHOUT OUT TO
DIRECTORS THEREFORE. I THINK THE
PROCESS COMING FROM SOMEONE WHO
HAS BEEN A GENERAL JUDGE FOR
MANY YEARS AS STRICKEN THE SERRA
HAS- REALLY HELPS TO KIM'S THAT
ACTION PRAGMATIC EXPERIENCE OF
WHAT IS NEEDED WHEN- A YOUNG
PERCENT COMES IN CONTACT WITH
THE JUVENILE SYSTEM BOB SO JUST
TO QUICK THOUGHTS I THINK I
REALLY WANT TO- UNDERSCORE THE
POINT THE DIRECTOR THE CERRO
MADE ABOUT THIS FUNDING IS
INTENDED TO. BETTER SUPPORT THE
WHOLE CAN YOU ONE OF CARE THE
COUNTIES NEED TO HAVE AVAILABLE
SO SOME OF THE FINDING MAY
INDEED BE GOING TO SUPPORT ON
SECURE USE TREATMENT FACILITIES
AND IN THAT REGARD CENTER
CORTESE CERTAINLY THE
LEGISLATURE MATE WITH AND THEY
MINISTRATION MAY WISH TO PUT
MORE THE CITY ABOUT YOU KNOW HOW
HOW THE FUNDING CAN BE WORLD OUT
SHOULD SOME BE GOING TO SECURE
YOUR TREATMENT FACILITIES SOME
OF THE DOLLARS GO TO THOSE AND-
OTHER KINDS OF THINGS LIKE.
GRANNY THESE NEXT MONTH AS WE
LOOK AT THIS PURPOSE WHICH IS
TIMES AND I THINK MIGHT BOTTOM
LINE IS COUNTY NEED TO BE REALLY
READY TO PROVIDE THAT RANGE
PROGRAM AND TREATMENT- AND DOWN
SIR AND ALL. YOU KNOW I I'M PART
OF THE ADMIN SO THE EXTENT TO
WHICH THERE CAN THE RIGHT
BALANCE- FOUND IN TERMS OF SHORT
DEGREE OF. CONTROL BUT ALSO. A
CLEAR STATEMENT OF WHAT THE
STATE. IS THAT THAT LIKE A GOOD
LANDING PLACE FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE. THANK YOU THAT'S
THANK YOU IT'S WONDERFUL TO HEAR
AND- BUT BE VERY ENTHUSIASTIC
ABOUT. THE GETTING INVOLVED IN
THOSE THOSE DISCUSSIONS SOME IN
OVER THE NEXT COUPLE MONTHS- ARE
THIS IS PART OF THE COMMITTEE
BUT- INDIVIDUALLY AS WELL THE
ONLY OTHER QUESTION I HAD IT IS.
AGAIN PROBABLY GOING TO BE
TAKEN. THAT THE SORT OF SIMILAR
HIGH LEVEL- BUT THEY WERE SO
MUCH REFERENCE. YOU KNOW TO
YOUTH VERSUS ADULTS- THE CARD
SHIN- THE COURT SYSTEM IN PENCIL
FOURTH. I CAN'T HELP BUT ASK YOU
KNOW WITH- YOU KNOW WHAT I THINK
IN MOST COUNTIES HAS BEEN OF A
VERY SUCCESSFUL AB ONE OH NINE
ROLLOUT- REENTRY- KIND OF
PROTECTIVENESS- HE IN IN WITH
THIS REALIGNMENT. HERO PICKING
UP STEAM THERE'S CERTAINLY BEEN
SOME DISCUSSION SOME PAST RECENT
LEGISLATION THAT THAT ALLOWS
SOME DISCRETION IN TERMS OF. H.
AND IN TERMS OF WHO IS A YOUTH
WHAT WHAT CONSTITUTES A YOUTH IT
SHOULD BE TO YOU FACILITY A
PERSON THAT SHOULD BE TO YOU
FACILITY VERSUS- AN OFFENDER WHO
. WHO REALLY NEEDS TO BE IN AN
ADULT FACILITY IN- AGAIN IS A
SHORT ANSWER I'M GOING TO GUESS
BASED ON THAT LAST RESPONSES
THAT. IT IS TO BE DETERMINED-
DID. YOU KNOW AGAIN I GET IT
TODAY'S A BUDGET HEARING IT'S
NOT. THIS IS A POLICY COMMITTEE
PER SE- BUT BUT OBVIOUSLY
EVERYTHING POLICY AND BUDGETS
VERY MUCH INTERTWINED HERE SO
I'M JUST TRYING TO GET A FEEL
FOR YOUR THOUGHTS. ON HOW
FLEXIBLE. THE HE SORT OF THE
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY ONE OR.
TWENTY ONE TO TWENTY FIVE
CATEGORY SHOULD BE IN TERMS OF
THE REENTRY APPROACH AND WHO
SHOULD GO INTO WHICH FACILITIES
. THE GENERAL START WITH YOU
AGAIN JUST BECAUSE- THANK YOU
YEAH I'M I THINK THE LAW ALLOWS
AND ACTUALLY REQUIRES THAT A
YOUTHFUL OFFENDER. D. N. A. U.
FACILITY I THINK THAT DOES.
THERE THERE IS THERE ARE SOME
DISCUSSIONS AROUND WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN THE USES TWENTY FIVE.
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW THE LAW SEEMS
TO. ALLOW FOR A USED UP TO THE
AGE OF TWENTY FIVE TO REMAIN IN
THAT YOU'VE DISABILITY. THERE IS
THAT OTHER AUTHORITIES THAT HAVE
TO BE DEALT WITH AROUND SIGHT
AND SOUND SEPARATION- IF THE
YOUTH IS OVER THAT AGE BUT
CURRENTLY- USE UP TO THE AGE OF
TWENTY FIVE WILL IT IS. EXPECTED
AND REQUIRED THAT THEY ARE IN
THE U. FACILITY AS LONG AS THAT
- EVENTS THE UNDERLYING AND THAT
AT CURRENT WHEN THEY WERE- UNDER
EIGHTEEN- SO WE HAVEN'T REALLY
LOOKED AT WHAT HAPPENS BETWEEN-
YOUTHFUL OFFENDER BETWEEN THE
AGES OF EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY
FIVE. BUT IF HE- UNDER EIGHTEEN
THERE THERE IS AN EXPECTATION
THAT THEY WILL BE. HAVE THAT
REHABILITATIVE EXPERIENCE IN OUR
SECURE AT TRACK YOU FACILITIES.
DOES THAT ANSWER THAT QUESTION
SENATOR CORTESE YES YES IT DOES
FOR NO I THAT THAT GETS ME REAL
CLEAR ON WHAT THE BASELINE IS
RIGHT NOW AND I SUPPOSE FOR
FUTURE CONVERSATIONS POLICY
CONVERSATIONS- WHETHER OR NOT
ANYTHING MORE NEEDS TO BE DONE.
WHERE IS THIS MISS HOWARD HOWARD
WAS KIND OF ALLUDING TO WHETHER
OR NOT. AT SOME POINT THERE'S
MORE LEGISLATIVE DIRECTION ON- A
LOT MORE TO DO IN THAT REGARD SO
I'LL STOP THERE THANK YOU ALL
AGAIN I'M PRODUCES EXTREMELY
IMPRESSED WITH YOUR TEAM AND
WITH THE HELP- IN. ORDER TO LOOK
AT THINGS TO COME THANK YOU
MANAGER THANK YOU I HAVE JUST A
COUPLE MORE QUESTIONS PROBABLY
FOR DOCTOR BULLS- IF YOU COULD
CLARIFY THE OUR POPULATION
PROJECTION FOR THE NEXT YEAR. I
GUESS THERE'S BEEN A DIFFERENT
NUMBER SO I JUST WANNA IF YOU
COULD GIVE US AS MUCH CLARITY TO
THAT AS POSSIBLE. YES YES AND
ACTUALLY- CHRIS CHAMBERS IS ALSO
ON THE LINE AND HE CAN SPEAK TO
THOSE POP PRODUCTION STUFF I SEE
HAS HIS HANDS HAVE BEEN RIGHT SO
I'M GOING TO TRY HM AND THAT
TIME CAN ADD ANY. TIME THANK YOU
. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS COMMITTEE CHRIS CHAMBERS
DEPUTY DIRECTOR CCAR'S OFFICE OF
RESEARCH. AS A BACKGROUND FOR-
DJS POPULATION PROJECTIONS
CITIES ARE PROJECTS THAT TOTAL-
JUVENILE AVERAGE DAILY
POPULATION WILL EXHIBIT.
EIGHTEEN POINT 7% DECREASE FROM
JUNE TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO JUNE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO REACH SIX
HUNDRED EIGHTEEN USE BY JUNE OF
TWENTY TWENTY TO. GET ENOUGH
FURTHER DECREASE OF TWENTY TWO
POINT TWENTY POINT 2% TO REACH.
APPROXIMATELY FOUR HUNDRED
NINETY THREE USE- BY JUNE.
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. SO THAT
LAST NUMBER IS EXPECTED BY
TWENTY THREE TO BE 410093% FOUR
HUNDRED NINETY THREE YES WHAT
KIND OKAY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAMBERS- THE OTHER OUR QUESTION
DOCTOR BOLD IS- ON THE ISSUE
THAT YOU MENTIONED HICH IS A-
THE BIG CHALLENGE IS THE-
STAFFING. OF AS YOU ADDRESS
THAT- I'VE HEARD REPORTS CALL-
BUT ADVOCATES- TALKING ABOUT THE
DIFFERENT ARE A RANGE OF ISSUES
THAT IS BECAUSE BECAUSE AS I
UNDERSTAND THE LACK OF OUR THE
SHORTAGE OF STAFF- THE OF COURSE
THE CULPRIT OUTBREAKS WHICH IF
YOU COULD DEAL WITH SEPARATELY.
OUR YOUTH ARE GETTING THEIR FOOD
ON TIME- MAYBE STAFF WAS NOT
TRAINED TO WORK WITH YOU BEING
USED OSTAP ON YOUTH VIOLENCE
COULD YOU. RESPOND TO THOSE
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN BROUGHT TO
MY ATTENTION. OF COURSE SO- AND
I WILL I DO KNOW THAT THE CODE
IS ON A SEPARATE AGENDA ITEM BUT
YOU WANT TO SET THAT UP
OBVIOUSLY THAT HAS AT. INCREASED
OUR CHALLENGE AROUND SHOPPING
AND SO- I THINK I'LL I'LL TACKLE
THOSE ISSUES UNDER UNDER COVER
THEY DIDN'T WANT TO SAY THAT
THAT IS A REACHED. IT HAS
INCREASED THOSE CHALLENGES FOR
THAT IN TERMS OF YOUR QUESTION
SO- WE ARE MONITORING ALL OF
THOSE THINGS CLOSELY AND
ALTHOUGH WE HAVE HAD STAFFING
CHALLENGES FOR EXAMPLE OUR
INTERVENTIONS THERE ARE
CONDUCTED BY OUR YOUTH
CORRECTIONAL COUNSELORS THEIR
SCHEDULES FOR THOSE WHERE
MONITORING ANY OF THOSE GROUPS.
HAVE BEEN RESCHEDULED- HIRED
SOME OF THE WITH MOST RECENTLY
AROUND THE COPING POSITIVE STAFF
- WE HAD SEEN AN INCREASE OF
INTERVENTIONS BEING RESCHEDULED
BUT THEY WERE NOT BEING MESSED-
BUT IN ORDER TO REALLY IN
BECAUSE AGAIN THE FOCUS ON THE-
PUBLICATION. UTILIZING OUR
CONTRACTORS OUR COMMUNITY
PROVIDERS TO HELP SUPPLEMENT
THAT AS WE MOVE FORWARD AS WELL-
SO THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE THOSE ESPECIALLY VERY
IMPORTANT INTERVENTIONS THAT
REDUCE WASTE- IN TERMS OF OUR
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES THOSE
HAVE CONTINUED. AS IS OUR
PSYCHOLOGISTS HAVE CONTINUED TO
STEP BACK AND PROVIDING.
RESOURCES WE HAVE THE
AVAILABILITY TO DO THAT. WE HAD
EDUCATION THE NEW YORKER EVEN
THROUGH SOME OF THE CHALLENGES
WITH CO IT AND IN FACT- BRAD YOU
WAITED AT QUITE A FEW YOU AND-
MORE SO THAN EVER I DON'T. I
HAVE I TAKE ALL CONCERNS THAT
ARE BROUGHT TO ME VERY SERIOUSLY
AND SO I HAVE FOLLOWED UP ON ANY
CONCERNS AROUND CHEATING AND-
THAT WHEN WE- TURN IT DOWN. NOT
SEE ANY SIX ISSUES AROUND THAT
WE ARE PREPARED- SHOULD WE
CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE AND
STAFFING WHAT OTHER ALTERNATIVES
CAN USE OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE
ADOLESCENT USE SO- NOT ONLY IS
THAT IMPORTANT FOR JUST THAT THE
DAY TO DAY FUNCTIONING BUT- AT
YOU KNOW IT. BUT AGAIN IT'S JUST
IMPORTANT PART OF MAKING SURE WE
CAN- PROVIDE THE HEALTH IN TERMS
OF- CONCERNS AROUND VIOLENCE- WE
HAVE SEEN DECREASES OVER THIS
LAST YEAR BUT AGAIN THAT'S
SOMETHING. WE MONITOR. I GOING
BACK TO KIND OF SOME OF MY EARLY
CALL IT HAS BEEN A TOUGH CALL OF
YEAR FOR I THINK EVERYONE IN
TERMS WE HAD TO CHANGE THINGS-
BECAUSE OF CODE THAT MAKES IT
JEFF FOR YEARS- THEY'RE
FRUSTRATED WITH SOME OF THE
PRODUCTS THAT WE NEED TO KEEP IN
PLACE FOR HEALTH HEALTH AND
SAFETY- THAT ALWAYS MAKES IT
DIFFICULT FOR EVERYONE AROUND
AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE- USING OUR
RESOURCES ARE MENTAL HEALTH
STAFF TO HELP ADDRESS THOSE. IF
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS ARE BROUGHT
TO ME AGAIN ABOUT SPECIFIC
INCIDENTS WE ARE FOLLOWING UP WE
HAVE PROTOCOLS IN PLACE.
REVEALING INCIDENTS TO MAKE SURE
THAT IF THEY ARE OUTSIDE OF ALL
THIS YEAR THERE IS A CONCERN
WHICH AT ANY PARTICULAR INCIDENT
THAT IT IS REVIEWED AND FOLLOWED
UP ON AS SOON AS POSSIBLE. IF
OKAY- SECRETARY ANY SIGNALS OKAY
THANK YOU I THINK THAT'S IT A
DOCTOR BOWLS SOME DIRECTOR LU
SETTLE AND DIRECTOR- HOWARD- ON
EVERYONE THE L. A. ILL FINANCE
ARE PRE SHAPED VIA YOUR
INFORMATION APPRECIATE THE HARD
WORK THAT YOU'RE PUTTING INTO IT
AND THE- LET'S MOVE FORWARD IT'S
A REALLY HUGE CHANGE THAT WE'RE
TAKING ON IN THE STATE AND- WE
SHOULD ALL BE VERY PROUD OF
WHERE WE WANT TO BE. IT'S
ALWAYS- THE BUMPY ROAD IS
GETTING. THERE SO THANK YOU ALL
VERY MUCH. FROM GO ON NOW TO.
ISSUE TO. THIS MORNING OUT OF
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CHRIS CHAMBERS AGAIN
CCR DEPUTY DIRECTOR OFFICE OF
RESEARCH. ANNOUNCED TODAY TO
PROVIDE A THE COMMITTEE A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF CDCR SPALL TWENTY
TWENTY ONE POPULATION
PROJECTIONS. CTC ARTS FALL
POPULATION PROJECTIONS UTILIZE
HISTORICAL TREND DATA INCLUDING
DATA ON COURT COMMITMENTS. IN
AND TAKE THE STATE- PRESENT TO
PROTECT FUTURE POPULATIONS. RCBC
HAS FALTERED STATE OR CUT OFF
FASTER JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE IN ORDER TO PREPARE
THE SYSTEM THAT'S- HEY CANNOT IS
PROVIDED ARE PREPARED AND
HOPEFULLY PROVIDED YOU WHICH
INCLUDES CARP POPULATION
PROJECTIONS. COMPARED TO THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT
FOR. PROJECTIONS FOR REFERENCE.
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT ITS USUAL
POPULATION BE FALL TWENTY ONE
POPULATION PROJECTIONS
ANTICIPATE THAT THE AVERAGE
DAILY COP INSTITUTIONAL
POPULATION WOULD BE
APPROXIMATELY HUNDRED FOUR
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED. IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND A
HUNDRED AND TWELVE THOUSAND NINE
HUNDRED AND FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE OUR CURRENT
INMATE POPULATION IS JUST UNDER
NINETY SEVEN THOUSAND AS OF. ALL
TWENTY TWENTY ONE POPULATION
PROJECTIONS INCLUDE ESTIMATED
IMPACTS FOR EXPANDED ELIGIBILITY
CRITERIA FOR ELDERLY PAROLE
PROGRAM. AND THE NINE VIOLENT
PEARL THAT WERE NOT PREVIOUSLY.
IN PREVIOUS PROJECTIONS. YOU
KNOW THAT JUNE THIRTIETH HOFFERT
EIGHTY UTILIZED TO CALCULATE THE
FALL PROJECTION SEVERAL
ADJUSTMENTS WILL BE INCORPORATED
INTO SPRING TWENTY TWO
PROJECTIONS. MAY REVISION ALL
CORPORATE DATA AND TRENDS
THROUGH DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST OF
THE YEAR AS WELL AS THE
FOLLOWING ADJUSTMENTS. BASED
UPON THE LEVEL OF ACTUAL INTAKE
FOR JULY THROUGH DECEMBER OF
LAST YEAR SHE STARTED NOT
RECEIVED AS MANY QUESTIONS AS WE
HAD PREVIOUSLY ANTICIPATED. AS
SUCH THERE WILL BE A DOWNWARD
ADJUSTMENT SHRINK PROJECTIONS.
WE WILL ALSO ADJUST ASSUMPTIONS
ABOUT WHEN WE WILL REACH NORMAL
LEVELS OF PANCAKES- TO RECEPTION
CENTERS STOOD ON THE GROUND. THE
FALL TWENTY ONE PROJECTIONS
ASSEMBLY. AT RECEPTION CENTERS
WITH STABILIZER AND THEN THE
CLUB CLOSE BY THE END OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE IN OUR MAIN GAP THOSE
LEVELS THROUGHOUT THE PROJECTION
CYCLE. IN ADDITION. WE WILL BE
MAKING ADJUSTMENTS FOR THE
ESTIMATED IMPACT SB FORTY THREE
I SENATOR ALAN- THE DOW WAS
APPROVED BACK IN OCTOBER. WHEN
WE LOOK AT OUR POPULATION ARE
PRO POPULATION CITIES ARE
EXPECTS ACTIVE ROLE POPULATION
WILL DECREASE IN THE AVERAGE
DAILY PROPERLY XIN IS EXPECTED.
TO BE APPROXIMATELY FORTY SEVEN
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND.
FORTY TWO THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED
AND FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. AND DISSIPATED
DECREASING THE PRO PROPOSITION
IS RELATED TO CHANGES TO OUR
DISCHARGE AS WELL AS LIKE
SEVERAL TERMS FOR MOST PAROLEES
THAT WENT INTO EFFECT. BACK IN
JULY OF TWENTY TWENTY. THIS CALL
LENGTH CHANGE ALLOWS THE MOST.
ALLOWS MOST NON SEX REGISTRANT.
DETERMINEDLY SENTENCE PROBABLY
IS RELEASED FROM PRISON AFTER
JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY THE
SURVEY TO YOUR PAROLE PERIOD. IT
IS THREE YEARS FOR MOST POLICE
WITH AN INDETERMINATE SETS. I
THINK WE COVERED JUVENILE
POPULATION ALTHOUGH PROTEST
PEACE AGAIN. CDCR PREDICTS THE
TOTAL GENERAL AVERAGE DAILY
POPULATION WILL EXHIBIT A TEN
POINT 7% DECREASE FROM JUNE
TWENTY ONE. TO REACH SIX HUNDRED
EIGHTEEN YEARS BY JUNE TWENTY
TWO AND THE FURTHER DECREASE OF
TWENTY POINT TWO PERCENT. TO
FINALIZE FOUR HUNDRED NINETY
THREE BY JUNE OF TWENTY TWENTY
THREE THE PROJECTED DECLINE
REFLECTS ANTICIPATED CHANGES AS
A DIVISION OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
IS REALIZED TO ALSO STOPS. ALSO
DUE TO THIS CHANGE THE
PROJECTIONS ASSUMED NO
ADDITIONAL USE WOULD BE RECEIVED
AFTER- THE END OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. THAT CONCLUDES MY OVERVIEW
THANK YOU- THE ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU WAS CHAMBER I WE NOW TURN TO
OUR FINANCE ANY COMMON OR
QUESTIONS. FORTY MANAGER JUSTIN
EDELMAN DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I
JUST WANTED TO REITERATE MISTER
CHAMBERS STATEMENT ABOUT THE
FLUIDITY OF THESE POPULATION
PROJECTIONS- AT THE TIME CITIES
ARE INITIALLY PRODUCED THEM WE
HAD PROJECTED THAT THE BACKLOG
FROM COUNTIES. SORRY I'M FROM
COUNTIES WILL BE AYE ZEROED OUT
BY THE END OF JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AND WITH THE LATEST
ON THE CONCERT FOR YOU SEEN VIA
INCREASED TO ABOUT TWENTY FOUR
HUNDRED- SO AGAIN WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE THROUGH THE MAY
REVISION AND REVISING THE
POPULATION PROJECTIONS. THANK
YOU ADAM. ANY OTHER COMMENTS ARE
FROM OUR OKAY. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS CAITLIN
O'NEILL AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WE WENT HOLD
RECOMMENDATION ON THE POPULATION
RELATED BUDGET ADJUSTMENTS- AS
MISTER CHAMBERS NOTED THE
ADMINISTRATION PLANS TO SUBMIT
REVISED PROJECTIONS AND
ADJUSTMENTS AT THE- END WHICH-
THE ADMINISTRATION AND INTENDS
TO REFLECT VARIOUS ADJUSTMENTS
THAT ARE CURRENTLY NOT REFLECTED
IN THAT PROJECTIONS BEFORE THAT
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU MS O'NEILL
- COLLEAGUE. FOR QUARTERS THE
QUESTION- I JUST HAVE ONE PLEASE
- PROBABLY MISSED CHAMBER- MY
UNDERSTANDING- CDC STAFF IS GROW
. 13% SINCE PRE PANDEMIC OF SO-
GIVEN THE LONG TERM DECREASES IN
THE PRISON POPULATION AND THE
REALIGNMENT OF R. J. J. WHAT DO
YOU SAY IS DRIVING THE CONTINUED
GROWTH OF CDCR. NUMBER YOU ARE
YOU REFERRING TO THE EIGHTY. TO
THE STAFFING ARE YOU REFERRING
I'M SORRY FOR STAFFING YES I
WOULD I WOULD HAVE TO DEFER THAT
TO OUR BUDGET BUDGET MANAGEMENT
BRANCH FOLKS. WARNING THIS IS
MADELEINE CLEAN DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OFFICE OF PERSONAL SERVICES- SO
THERE ARE WHAT WE DO KNOW THAT
THERE HAVE BEEN CHANGES IN
STAFFING LEVELS THEY'RE NOT
PROPORTIONATE TO. POPULATION
CHANGES THAT STUDENT INVESTMENTS
AND DIFFERENT TYPES OF PROGRAMS
SPECIFICALLY REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS- AND OTHER INVESTMENTS
SUCH AS- STAFF. MISCONDUCT AND
GRIEVANCE PROCESS THAT HAVE
INCREASED OUR OVERALL UP
STOPPING TOTALS SO IT'S THE
POPULATION REDUCTIONS WE ARE
TAKING THE APPROPRIATE-
REDUCTIONS IN STAFFING IN
COMMENSURATE STOPPING IS RELATED
TO THAT YES THAT OTHER INCREASES
THAT YOU'RE SEEING ARE RELATED
TO SPECIFIC INVESTMENTS AND
PROPOSALS THAT HAVE BEEN
INCLUDED IN PREVIOUS. CALLS OKAY
SO THE ARM INVESTMENT IN THE
REHABILITATION THAT YOU'RE
REFERRING. TO THESE ARE NEW
PROGRAMS. THE EXPANSION TO.
EXPANSION OF A PROGRAMS AND YOU
PROGRAM SO WE CAN PROVIDE YOU A
LIST OF THOSE ITEMS OKAY THAT
WOULD BE GREAT OKAY- THAT'S ALL
I HAVE IN TERMS OF QUESTIONS
NONE FROM MY COLLEAGUE- THANK
YOU ALL VERY MUCH APPRECIATE.
ALL OF YOUR WORK. THANK YOU- WE
KNEW NUMBER ONE TWO ISSUE THREE
WITCHES ARE A COVERT NINETEEN
DIRECT RESPONSE. EXPENDITURE. SO
WILL HAVE A CDC ARE PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING AGAIN MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS AGAIN MADELINE MACLEAN
W. DIRECTOR OFFICE OF THE SCHOOL
SERVICES. ISSUE THREE YEARS AS
YOU COMPONENTS SPECIFICALLY
DIRECT RESPONSE AND EXPENDITURES
I WE'VE PROVIDED A HAND OUT TO
THE MEMBERS OF THE HOUSE- EIGHT
AFRICA NINETEEN I'M- AS OF
JANUARY TWENTY EIGHTH. AND
ALWAYS JUST WANT TO REMIND FOLKS
THAT OUR WEBSITE HAS ALL THE
INFORMATION RELATED TO CURRENT
CASES VACCINATION RATES AND
TESTING- CCAR'S EXPENDED
APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT ONE
BILLION IN THE NINETEEN TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY. TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO TO SUPPORT OPEN
NINETEEN AND WE ARE CURRENTLY
PROJECTING TO SPEND AN
ADDITIONAL SIX HUNDRED THIRTEEN
POINT FIVE MILLION IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. GIVING HOLDEN
NINETEEN WILL CONTINUE TO IMPACT
THE PRISON OPERATIONS FOR THE
FORESEEABLE FUTURE THE BUDGET
INCLUDES AN ADDITIONAL FOUR
HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR POINT SEVEN
MILLION A ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE.
THESE FUNDS WILL BE UTILIZED FOR
P. P. TESTING RESPONSE
ACTIVITIES. ADDITIONALLY AS YOU
KNOW ACKERMAN NINETEEN HAS
IMPACTED THE STATE FOR ALMOST
TWO YEARS AND THE MOST RECENT
SURGE IN CASES RELATED TO CRIME
VARIANTS I RESULT IN AN EASY ARE
WE IMPLEMENTING A VARIETY OF
MEASURES WHICH INCLUDE A CLOSING
INTAKE. SPENDING IN PERSON
FAMILY AND FAMILY VISITING
ELIMINATING UNNECESSARY MOVEMENT
YOU'RE A STATEWIDE MODEL I
PROGRAM- I DO HAVE SEVERAL
COLLEAGUES HERE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS ABOUT QUESTIONS
MEMBERS MAY HAVE. DOCTOR
PICTURES ARE DIRECTOR OF
DIVISION OF PROFESSIONAL HEALTH
SERVICES. CONNIE GIPSON RECTOR
DIVISION OF ADULT ADULT IN.
INSTITUTIONS ARE DOING READER
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR FISCAL MAN
OR HEALTH CARE SIR AND MY TO
ANSWERING. MY HOUSE. QUEST IS
BASED ON THE CURRENT PROJECTIONS
AND EXPANDED EXPENDITURE DATA
THAT'S BEEN COLLECTED TODAY. WE
COLLABORATED WITH STEVE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE TO
PROVIDE INFORMATION FOR HOUSE
CDCR ESTIMATED THE COST AS WELL
AS THE EXPENDITURE DATA FOR EACH
CATEGORY WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE L. A. O. TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION AS IT BECOMES
AVAILABLE BUT GIVEN THE CHANGING
CONDITIONS RESULTING FROM THE
PANDEMIC. THIS REPRESENTS THE
BEST INFORMATION THAT WE HAVE
AVAILABLE AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU- THE LA OFFICE PLEASE.
EVERYONE AT THIS AT THIS POINT
WHERE WE ARE WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT TO GET FURTHER
INFORMATION BUT WE'RE STILL
WAITING SOME KEY INFORMATION ON
THIS PROPOSAL AND WHILE WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THERE WILL BE
COSTS ASSOCIATED. AND CALL IT
NINETEEN DIRECT RESPONSE WE WANT
TO KNOW THAT KEY INFORMATION-
THAT IS MISSING FOR THIS REQUEST
MAKES IT DIFFICULT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE. TO DECIDE. ROBIN
SAID THE LEVEL OF FUNDING. BUT
AS MENTIONED WE WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THAT DEPARTMENT TO GET
SOME OF THESE MISINFORMATION
SOME OF THE EXAMPLES ARE. OF
MISSING INFORMATION I JUST WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT TO THE LEGISLATURE
CARD NUMBER OF INMATES AND
EMPLOYEES REQUIRING TESTING- I
THANK YOU AND HAPPY TO TAKE IT.
TO SONOMA WESTON'S. OKAY THANK
YOU MISTER SANTOS- SECRETARY. OF
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. NO THAT
WAS- PRETTY CLEAR EVEN THOUGH
WE'RE MISSING SOME INFORMATION
IT SOUNDS LIKE THANK YOU- I HAVE
A FEW QUESTIONS OF- WHAT TERM WE
DO HAVE THESE OUR EMERGENCE OF
THE OF THE NEW VARIANTS WE HAVE
SEARCHES AT BOTH THE YOUTH AND
THE ADULT FACILITIES SO IF WE
COULD- IF CDCR COULD RESPOND TO
WHAT ARE YOU DOING TO RESPOND
TO. THOSE ISSUES. HI THIS IS
THAT OUR TO GET SEND- KIND OF
GET SENT FROM CDCR DIVISION OF
ADULT INSTITUTIONS AND I'LL BE
HAPPY TO START WITH. SOME OF OUR
EFFORTS WE'VE INSTITUTED AS
WE'VE TRIED TO MITIGATE THE
SPREAD OF THE- CAR BURIED WITHIN
OUR SYSTEM. FIRST AND FOREMOST
WE IMMEDIATELY START GETTING OUR
EXECUTIVE LEADERSHIP TEAMS
TOGETHER AND ACTIVATE OUR
DEPARTMENT'S OPERATIONS CENTER
WHAT WE CAN HAVE CHRIS OUR
EFFORTS. OF CONSORTED AT
CONTROLLED ALBERS AS WE ARE. DO
OUR RESPONSES TO RESOURCE NEEDS
AB WORKING WITH THE PRESIDENT TO
MAKE SURE THEY HAVE AB. ARE ABLE
TO NAVIGATE AND HAVE THE NEEDS
THAT THEY HAVE THAT WE CAN WORK
TO ADDRESS ADDITIONALLY WE ALSO
AS WAS STATED BEFORE IMPLEMENTED
A STATEWIDE MODIFY PROGRAM. TO
HAVE THE POPULATION AND OURS AND
OF THEM AT THE MOMENT BUT THAT
OUR SYSTEM TO HELP MITIGATE THE
SPREAD OF COBIT. ALL WE'VE ALSO-
EDWARD TO COMPLY WITH IT AND
CONTINUE TO DO TESTING
OVERSTAFFED TESTING OF
POPULATION. THOSE STAFF WHO ARE
NOT VACCINATED ARE REQUIRED TO
TEST TWICE WEEKLY ALSO DOOR
SURVEILLANCE TESTING AND MORE
FREQUENT TESTING OF ALL STAFF
REGARDLESS OF VACCINATION
STATUS. WE HAVE OUTBREAKS IN OUR
SYSTEM AS WELL AS TESTING A
POPULATION WE CONTINUE TO
ENFORCE. MASS WEARING AN
APPROPRIATE PP. UP DEPENDING ON
THE LOOK BURKE LOCATION OF OUR
STAFF. WITH STAFF WORK IN
ISOLATION OR QUARANTINE AREAS TO
BE AND NINETY AND NINETY FIVE
AND FOR THE REST OF OUR STAFF.
TO BE AND K. AND NINETY FIVE.
AFTER PROTECTION AS ELL AS WE
COULD ISSUE MASS FOR OUR
POPULATION. AT THE INCARCERATED
POPULATION- IS YOU SURGICAL
MASKS TO WEAR AS WELL AS QUE IN
NINETY FIVE TO WHERE. OUT WE
CONTINUED SO FOREST MASK
COMPLIANCE WITH OUR STAFF
TESTING REQUIREMENTS FOR A
STAFF. AS WELL AS WE CONTINUE TO
PROMOTE VACCINATIONS AMONG OUR
POPULATION AND OUR STAFF. NOTING
THAT CURRENTLY WE SAID AT
ROUGHLY EIGHTY ONE PERCENT. OF
OUR POPULATION HAVE ACCEPTED THE
VACCINATION ARE VACCINATED. AND
WE HAVE APPROXIMATELY 71% OF OUR
STAFF WHO ARE VACCINATED
THROUGHOUT THE SYSTEM. THAT
WOULD CONTINUE NOW THAT BOOSTERS
ARE AVAILABLE TO OFFER BOOSTING
TO OUR. POPULATION AS WELL AS
OUR EMPLOYEES- WE SUSPENDED A
WILL STAY COUNTY AND TAKE. UP
AND WE ALSO MAKE SURE THAT ANY
LIMIT MOVEMENT THAT'S HAPPENING
WITHIN THE SYSTEM IS DATA
CONDUCIVE TO WHAT WE HAVE IS OUR
MOVEMENT MAKES AS WE TEST AND
QUARANTINE- OUR POPULATION
BEFORE THEY ARE MOVED. AND THEN
WE ALSO TESTED TRANSFERRED THE
POPULATION UPON RECEIPT TO THE
RECEIVING INSTITUTION TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE DOING
EVERYTHING IN OUR EFFORTS TO
MITIGATE THE SPREAD. THANK YOU
MISS SIGNED GIPSON PRECIADO
THAT- ARE THERE ANY OTHER
MEASURES THAT YOU'RE TAKING- YOU
KNOW. OUTSIDE OF THE- ONES THAT
YOU LISTED I CARE CIRCULATION
ARE ME ARE THERE ANY OTHER
THINGS THAT- YOU BELIEVE. WILL
HELP IN ADDITION TO THE YOU KNOW
THE PP AND FACING ON THE MASKS.
YES WE ARE ALSO LOOK AT OUR
VENTILATION AND I DEFINITELY
WANT TO INVITE DOCTOR BEGAN TO
SPEAK TO THE EFFORTS WHAT
COUNTERATTACKED. BUT WE ARE ALSO
MAKING SURE THAT FORMER CLASS
STAFF AT THE PRISONS THAT WE ARE
TRYING TO UTILIZE MARC THIRTEEN
FILTERS AND REPLACE THOSE THAT
ARE HELP US IN OUR- H. FAQ
UNITS. FOR THOSE SYSTEMS I CAN
TAKE A MERV THIRTEEN
ADDITIONALLY YOU KNOW WE ARE
EXCITED TO GET BACK TO OPEN IT
UP TO PROGRAM FOR OUR POPULATION
UNDERSTANDING THE IMPORTANCE OF.
THE REHABILITATION PROGRAM SO IN
PREPARATION FOR THAT WE HAD ALSO
ORDERED AND WE HAVE DISTRIBUTED
WITHIN OUR PRESENCE ARTICLE HELP
OR FILTER UNITS SO THAT WE ARE
ABLE TO HAVE THE POPULATION ONCE
WE GET PAST THIS. ALL ACROSS.
AND WE GET PAST THAT MIGHT
PROGRAM. TO GET FOLKS BACK INTO
PROGRAMMING THAT OUR PRESENCE
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO INVITE
DOCTOR BIGELOW. SPEAK ON THE
WORK WITH CAPITEC. THANK YOU. I
THINK DIRECTOR GIVES HIM COVERED
IT QUITE WELL- WE WE'VE HAD
OUTSIDE OF VALUATIONS COME INTO
MOST OF OUR PRISONS AND PROVIDE
FEEDBACK REGARDING YOUR HANDLING
AND HOW WE COULD OPTIMIZE
VENTILATION AND- AS DIRECTOR
GIPSON SAID MANY OF THOSE
CHANGES HAVE ALREADY BEEN MANY
TO THE EXTENT THAT IT'S POSSIBLE
WITH THE PHYSICAL PLANT THAT WE
HAVE SO WE'RE HOPING THAT THAT
PUT IN BETTER STICK. WHICH WAY
NOT JUST FOR KOBE BRYANT FOR ANY
FUTURE RESTORATION WE HAVE TO
ENCOUNTER. IT DOES- AS- DOES
SOME A USE OF OUTDOOR SPACES OF
SPACE IS THAT THE- BEING DONE AS
WELL. YOU KNOW IT'S A VERY GOOD
POINT ANY ANY ACTIVITY OUTSIDE
IS GOING TO HAVE LESS OF A
CHANCE FOR TRANSMISSION OF
RESPIRATORY ILLNESS ANSWER TO
THE EXTENT POSSIBLE WE ARE
MAXIMIZING USED ABOUT DOOR STATE
CERTAINLY. IMPORTANT TO GET
PEOPLE OUT TWO YARDS FOR A
VARIETY OF REASONS BUT THAT'S
ONE OF THEM. ANYWHERE ELSE THAT
WE CAN USE DOCTOR SPACE WE DO
ARM AS YOU CAN UNDERSTAND THAT
IS CHALLENGING. WITH THE
CORRECTIONAL POPULAR. AND ALSO
WITH THE WEATHER EXTREMES THAT
WE HAVE ACROSS THE STATE. ARMS
SEND UP I KNOW DARN THIRTY
GIPSON- THAT YOU MENTIONED
PROGRAMMING- HOW HOW ARE YOU
WHAT ARE YOU DOING WITH REGARDS
TO VISITATION DURING THESE
OUTBREAKS. AT BECAUSE BEFORE WE
HAD THE MODIFY PROGRAM WE WERE
BACK AT IN PERSON VISITING
UNFORTUNATE WITH THE ON THE
GROUND AREA AND THE MODIFY
PROGRAM WE'VE HAD TO SHUT DOWN
IN PERSON VISITING SO WHAT WE
ARE DOING IS. CAN YOU GUYS HEAR
ME YES GO AHEAD OKAY I'M SORRY
THAT I HAD- IT MYSELF- BUT WHAT
WE ARE DOING THIS AS ALLOW IT
AND WE HAVE SET UP OR ADD BE A
VISITING PROCESS AT OUR
INSTITUTIONS. WHERE WE ARE
FAMILIES ARE ABLE TO- SCHEDULE
APPOINTMENTS AND DO. A VISIT
WITH THEIR LOVED ONE EMPLACED AT
BERKELEY OVER VIDEO COURSES IN
PERSON. AND SO- WE KNOW WE HAVE
SOME CHALLENGES WITH THAT AND
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
STATEWIDE MHM THE COUNCIL AS
WELL AS THE LOCAL. MHM THE
COUNCIL THAT THE PRISONS. I WE
HAVE SOME SCHEDULING CHALLENGES
WITH THAT AND SO WE WERE ABLE TO
WORK WITH OUR PARTNERS AND OUR
INFORMATION SERVICES YOU AREA
WITHIN CDCR. AND WORKING WITH
THE CONTRACTOR WHO PROVIDES THE
SERVICE. TO BE ABLE TO BREAK THE
SCHEDULING TIMES UP INTO THREE
REGIONS THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND
TO STAGGER THOSE TIES BY THIRTY
MINUTES WHICH HAS REALLY BEEN
SUCCESSFUL. AND MITIGATE SOME OF
THE- TRAFFIC. THAT WAS CLOGGING
UP THE SYSTEM. BUT UNDERSTANDING
EVEN WITH VIDEO VISITING WE
STILL HAVE TO BECAUSE THAT'S
DONE IN A SPACE WHERE WE SET UP
THE EQUIPMENT. WE ARE STILL YOU
KNOW BOUND BY. PHYSICAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS. SO THE
CAPACITY IS STILL A BIT
RESTRICTED AT THIS TIME. BUT WE
ARE ALLOWING VIDEO VISITING AS
WELL AS- FOR CONNECTED YOU KNOW
TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE CAN TALK
TO THEIR LOVED ONES ON THE
STREETS THEIR SUPPORT SYSTEM.
YOU KNOW WE'RE ASSURED THAT IS
MODIFIED PROGRAM THAT EMBODIES.
THE INCARCERATED POPULATION ARE
ABLE TO. STILL ACCESS PHONE
CALLS AND- WHEN THE PROCESS OF
ROLLING OUT TABLETS TO OUR
POPULATION AND HAVE ALREADY GOT
SOME OF THOSE OUT AT SOME OF THE
PRISONS. WHERE THE INCARCERATED
POPULATION COULD DO VIDEO
CALLING WITH THEIR LOVED ONES
AND RECEIVE EMAILS WITH THEIR
LOT ONES SO. WE'RE STILL VERY
AWARE. OF THE IMPORTANCE AB. THE
END PERSON A BILL TO KIND WITH
THEIR SUPPORT TO ON THE- AND
WE'RE DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
FACILITATE THAT PROCESS. WELL I
APPRECIATE THAT SO MUCH BECAUSE-
YOU KNOW THIS MUCH BETTER THAN-
I DO HOW IMPORTANT THAT
CONNECTION TO FAMILY ESPECIALLY.
UP AND THOSE OF US WHO. ARE YOU
KNOW ABLE TO. MOVE AROUND WE'RE
STILL RESTRICTED AND- THE IMPACT
IT HAS ON OUR FAMILIES IS PRETTY
DEVASTATING SO. IT'S PROBABLY A
HUNDRED TIMES WORSE FOR OUR
INCARCERATED AND THEIR LOVED
ONES SO. APPRECIATE EVERYTHING
AND ANYTHING TO. KEEP THAT
CONNECTION. BETWEEN THEM AND
THEIR FAMILIES- OKAY WELL-
TERAGRID HASN'T NO NO MORE
COMMENTS- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK THAT YOU
DO AND- APPRECIATE YOU COMING
BEFORE THE IN THIS HEARING.
THANK YOU SENATOR THANK YOU GOOD
TO SEE YOU- WE MOVE ON NOW TO
ISSUE OF FOR WHICH IS SPEAKING
OF VISITATION AND REMOTE
COMMUNICATIONS OPTIONS. IS WHO'S
SPEAKING CDC ARE GOOD MORNING
THIS IS METAL MCLEAN AGAIN
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE SCHOOL
SERVICES I'M JUST GOING TO
PROVIDE A BRIEF OVERVIEW AND I
HAVE SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES HERE
AT THE ANSWER QUESTIONS AS NOTED
IN THE AGENDA DEPARTMENT DID
RECEIVE FUNDING IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT. OUT FOR A
VARIETY OF MEASURES AIMED AT
INCREASING OFFENDERS ACCESS TO
FRIENDS AND FAMILY ADD TO THAT
AND IN ADDITION TO THE FIFTEEN
MINUTES OF FREE CALLING ALREADY
PROVIDED EVERY TWO WEEKS FUNDING
WITH. AN ADDITIONAL. MINUTES OF
RECALLING EVERY TWO WEEKS AND
SIXTY ELECTRONIC MESSAGES FOR
MONTHS. AND THAT WAS MADE
AVAILABLE TO OFFENDERS BEGINNING
JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
THE BUDGET ALSO INCLUDED FUNDING
TO EXPAND VISITATION ON FRIDAY
IS WHICH WAS ACTIVATED ON AUGUST
THIRTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
AND ONCE THE ORDER WAS RECEIVED
IN THE BUDGET ACT DEPARTMENT
BEGAN UTILIZING THE STATE
STANDARD CONTRACTING PROCESS-
AND WILL RELEASE THE REQUEST FOR
BID ON JANUARY THIRD RELATED TO.
ORDER BOXES PROVIDE. ASIAN TWO
LOVED ONES. FRIENDS BECAUSE OF-
ANDERSON I'M ALSO FINALLY AYE
TABLETS HAVE BEEN DEPLOYED TO
VALLEY IRONWOOD AND YOU'LL CREEK
STATE PRISONS- SIMPSON'S
IMPLEMENTATION AT VALLEY STATE
PRISON THE POPULATION HAS
COMPLETED NEARLY FIFTY FOUR
THOUSAND VIDEO CALLS SENT AND
RECEIVED FIVE MILLION ELECTRONIC
MESSAGES RECEIVED NEARLY SIXTY
THOUSAND VIDEO MESSAGES AND MORE
THAN ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
SEVEN THOUSAND PHOTOS I HAVE MY
COLLEAGUES HERE- MERION SPEARMEN
AND I'VE BEEN GOING DOWN TO
ANSWER ANY SPECIFIC QUESTIONS
THAT YOU MAY HAVE- ON THIS ITEM.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- ANYONE
FROM FINANCE PLEASE. I JUST NEED
A MAIN DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO
COMMENT AT THIS TIME BUT WE'RE
MORE THAN HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE. OKAY THANK
YOU. AND FANCY I THINK THE-
SECRETARY ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS
NO OKAY- I DO HAVE A FEW- I
THINK YOU MIGHT HAVE MENTIONED
THIS THAT THAT THAT WAS IT
TWENTY MILLION A TWELVE BILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET ALLOCATION FOR
FREE COMMUNICATIONS AND JUST
WANT TO KNOW WHAT'S A THE STATUS
OF THAT IS THAT BEING. USED YES
THAT WAS- ONCE MONEY WAS
RECEIVED AS PART OF THE BUDGET
BEGINNING JULY FIRST- INMATES
HAD THE ABILITY TO MAKE THE
ADDITIONAL SIXTY MINUTES OF FREE
CALLS EVERY TWO WEEKS AND I'M
SIXTY ELECTRONIC MESSAGES EVERY
MONTH. THAT IS ACTIVE IN
AVAILABLE FOR MEMBERS ARE FOR
OFFENDERS TO USE. IT AND IS IT
BEING USED- YOU KNOWS SAID. AND
IT'S AVAILABLE TO THEM BUT IS IT
ACTUALLY BEING USED. ALTERNATE
OVERNIGHT AND THEN STUDENTS ARE
THOSE QUESTIONS SPECIFICALLY
YEAH GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR-
SOME OF THE DATA THAT WE GOT
FROM OUR VALLEY STATE PRISON
DEPLOYMENT THE INITIAL
APPOINTMENT- HAS SHOWN THAT THE
CALL VOLUMES HAVE- ALMOST
TRIPLED. SINCE WE PUT THIS IN
PLACE AND FOR AN EXAMPLE- TRIED
OUT WITH THE FIRST WEEKEND WE
SAW SIX AND HUNDRED DAILY CALLS.
WITH ABOUT SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND
MINUTES OF PHONE CALLS AND PRIOR
TO THAT THE CALL VOLUMES WERE
ABOUT NINETEEN HUNDRED PER DAY-
AND ABOUT NINETEEN. THOUSAND
MINUTES PER DAY SO BASICALLY
TROUBLED ACROSS THE BOARD SO
THEY ARE DEFINITELY UTILIZING
THE- THE- THE FUNDING. GREAT
THANK YOU THANK YOU STRAIGHTEN-
I THINK THIS IS- SO MENTIONED
WHATWITH REGARDS TO THE
APPLICATION- THAT WAS USED TO
BOOK THE VISITS- HOW THAT WAS
ADDRESSED AND- CAN HAVE THOSE
PROBLEMS WERE ADDRESSED. YES
MADAM CHAIR I CAN JUST AS IT
LOOKED LIKE THAT I CAN TAKE THAT
ONE AGAIN- WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH THE STATE FIGHT AND MAKE
FAMILY COUNCIL AND THEY DID- LET
US KNOW THAT THERE WERE MAJOR
ISSUES WITH THE APPLICATION AND
AS A DIRECTOR GIPSON DID NOTE WE
DID IMPLEMENTED ON. DECEMBER
NINTH. THE ABILITY FOR A TIERED
SYSTEM SO BASICALLY NORTHERN
CENTRAL AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
HAS BEEN SPLIT. INTO THOSE
REGIONS AND STARTING AT SIX AM
IN THE MORNING- APPOINTMENTS CAN
BE BOOKED HER. OUR REGION AND
THEN EVERY TWENTY MINUTES IT'LL
OPEN UP FOR THE NEXT REGION AND
THE NEXT REGION- I HAD THE
ANALOGY LIKE THE TICKET MASTER
WHERE EVERYBODY WANTS TO SEE A
CONCERT EVERYBODY GOES IN THE
SAME TIME SO THAT'S WHAT THE
ISSUE WAS CAUSING THE SYSTEM TO
BE BOGGED DOWN SO THIS IS REALLY
A LIMIT. ALLEVIATED THAT ISSUE
WE HAVE MET WITH THAT IT MAKES
ONLY COUNCIL LAST FRIDAY AND
THEY WERE VERY HAPPY WITH THE
SYSTEM AND OVER THE LAST TWO
MONTHS SINC IT'S BEEN AND IT
HAS BEEN IMPLEMENTED WE HAVE HAD
NO. NEGATIVE IMPACTS OR ANY-
ERRORS PRODUCE SO ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS AND FREEDOM- BURKE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- AND-
COULDN'T SOMEONE MAYBE THE
ADMINISTRATION AW. DESCRIBE THE
STRUCTURE OF THE CONTRACT WHICH
BY A PATH. THANK WILL DEFER THAT
TO MADELINE MCCAIN BMB. THIS IS
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE FONG
CONTRACTOR MENTIONING- WE DID
EXECUTE A CONTRACT CONTRACT AND
THERE WAS A CHALLENGE AND IT'S-
UNDER REVIEW RIGHT NOW BUT WE
ARE IN THE STATES THAT WE ARE
ALLOWED TO CONTINUE ON TO
PROVIDE THE SERVICES THROUGH
GTL. OR BY A PATH. RIGHT BUT CAN
YOU JUST DESCRIBE WHAT WHAT THAT
IS THE WHAT'S THE RELATIONSHIP
YOU KNOW WHAT'S THE CONTRACT YOU
KNOW DIZZY THERE I UNDERSTAND
THERE'S A AN ADMINISTRATIVE FEE.
OF THERE'S NO COST IS THE COST
TO THE STATE CAN YOU JUST.
DESCRIBE WHAT THAT IS. THE
BASIC. OF THE BASIC PARTS OF THE
CONTRACT. I WANTED TO GET BACK
TO YOU ON THAT AS I BELIEVE WILL
ON THE TO CHECK WITH OUR LEGAL
TEAM AND OUR CONTRACTS TEAM TO
GET SPECIFIC INFORMATION FOR YOU
BUT THERE'S NO NO COST TO THE
OFFENDERS. IN THE SENSE F
MAKING CALLS OUTSIDE OF WITH
ENOUGH FREE TIME THAT THEY GET
AND THEN WE GET THE STEP THEY
HAVE STANDARD RATES THAT THEY
ARE CHARGE WHICH ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY LESS EXPENSIVE
THAN THEY WERE PREVIOUSLY AS
PART OF THIS NEW NEGOTIATED
CONTRACT. OKAY BOB THANK YOU AND
APPRECIATE IF YOU COULD. GIVE ME
SOME MORE INFORMATION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THAT'S IT FOR ME WE
HAVE NO OTHER QUESTIONS- THANK
YOU EVERYONE RESHAPE YOUR TIME
AND ALL YOUR RESPONSES. ALL
RIGHT WE MOVE ON NOW TO ISSUE
FIVE THE TATTOO REMOVAL PROGRAM
. CDCR WHO WILL BE SPEAKING. I
AM I AM NOW CAN YOU HEAR ME AND
HEAR YOU LOUD AND CLEAR
WONDERFUL LONG GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR I AM KIMBERLY SEIPEL
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR A DIVISION
OF ADULT INSTITUTIONS. CITIES
THERE IS REQUESTING FUNDING TO
IMPLEMENT A STATEWIDE TATTOO
REMOVAL PROGRAM ONE CONTINUED
BARRIER PREVENTING SUCCESSFUL
REENTRY OF THOSE RELEASED IN THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES OF THEIR
ABILITY TO GAIN EMPLOYMENT ON
RELEASE MANY CORPORATIONS AND
BUSINESS. YOU NEED TO DO NOT
PERMIT OR THEY SHY AWAY FROM
HIRING CANDIDATES WITH VISIBLE
TATTOOS COMBINING CD SEARS
EDUCATION BASED REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS WITH TATTOO REMOVAL.
RIZAL PERTINENTES. CURSOR RATED
PEOPLE TO GET OFF OR BLAME IT
pTHEIR COMMUNITY MEMBERS
INCORPORATED CURATOR CHANCE OF
SUCCESS IS PRODUCTIVE MEMBERS OF
SOCIETY. THIS PROPOSAL PROVIDES
FUNDING TO SERVE APPROXIMATELY
FOURTEEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY
OFFENDERS ONLY FOR FOUR YEARS.
TO ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT TO
GATHER DATA YOU VALUE IT PROGRAM
PARTICIPATION AND TO SUPPORT
PROGRAMMING ONGOING I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE
REGARDING THIS HELLO. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- FINANCE ANY COMMENTS. I'M SORRY. JUST A MOMENT
APARTMENT OF FINANCE- WE JUST
WANTED TO EMPHASIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS PROPOSAL AND
REMOVING TATTOOS BOTH FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE. ARE
INTERESTED IN THE BRIEFING AND
LEAVING GANGS OR FROM EXITING-
PRISON INSTITUTIONS WE DO KNOW
THAT THERE ARE SOME
UNCERTAINTIES ABOUT THE
UTILIZATION RATES THAT
INDIVIDUALS MIGHT ACTUALLY TAKE
THIS PROPOSAL BUT AGAIN IT IS A
LIMITED TERM PROPOSAL AND WE CAN
REASSESS AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN- LA- PLEASE. FOR
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE- WE
DO NOT HAVE ANY CONCERNS ABOUT
THIS PROPOSAL AT THIS TIME
TWENTY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
COLLEAGUE STRIP CENTER CORTES
ANY QUESTIONS SO I'M CLEAR THANK
YOU OKAY- FAIBLE. JUST WANNA BE
CLEAR IF YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT
FOURTEEN HUNDRED ARCHITECT TO
REMOVALS PER YEAR OR OVER FOUR
YEARS. AT THAT WOULD BE PER YEAR
PER YEAR FOR FOUR YEARS YES-
AND- THE DEMAND IS HIGHER THAN
WHAT YOU'RE ESTIMATING- HOW
WOULD YOU HANDLE THAT GREATER
DEMAND. WELL WE WOULD WE WOULD
DEFINITELY RE EVALUATE THE
CONTRACT AND WE EVALUATE THE
SERVICES- HOWEVER WE HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY BECAUSE WE REALIZE
THAT SOME INSTITUTIONS BUT HAVE
A HIGHER DEMAND WORKS IS ANOTHER
INSTITUTION OR YOU CAN
REALLOCATE THE RESOURCES BASED
ON THE NEED. AND BASED ON THOSE
THAT ARE DESIRING TO HAVE THEIR
FACIAL GANG TATTOOS ARE THEIR
HANDS TIED TO TREAT WE WOULD
DEFINITELY REVALUING. OKAY WELL-
I REMEMBER VISITING A TATTOO
REMOVAL WHEN AN ORGANIZATION IN
LOS ANGELES. DOES AND- THE WAY
IT WAS EXPLAINED TO ME IS IT'S
NOT ONLY THE- THE- PROCEDURE OF
REMOVING THE OF THE TATTOOS
WHICH COULD TAKE. SEVERAL TIMES
A TO PAY HOW MUCH. HOW MUCH THE
TATTOO IS- BUT THERE WAS ALSO A
NEED FOR- TO ADDRESS THE TRAUMA.
THAT EITHER LED TO OR WAS PART
OF OR COULD BECOME. A NEW ISSUE
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUE AT AFTER THE
REMOVAL- DO YOU HAVE
CORRESPONDING- YOU KNOW IT.
MENTAL HEALTH FOR SOCIABLE-
PROGRAM THAT WOULD HELP ADDRESS
THAT AS WELL. WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OCCURRED WE HAVE A
VERY ROBUST MENTAL HEALTH
PROGRAM IN SHOULD TIME A PERSON
WOULD- LIKE A REFERRAL OR LIKE
TO TIE UP WITH THE MENTAL HEALTH
COMMISSION REGARDING ANY TRAUMA
IT'S GOING ON WITH THEIR LIVES-
IT THEY HAVE THAT ACCESS- ACCESS
TO MENTAL HEALTH. IS VERY
PREVALENT AND BEAR AND AVAILABLE
TO ANY INMATE THAT ARE IN ANY
RIGHT TO ANY RESIDENT WITHIN
OUR- COPULATION. OKAY BUT YOU
SEE THAT CONNECTION WITH THE
TATTOO REMOVAL PROGRAM. I'M I
HAVE NOT I PERSONALLY HAVE NOT
SEEN A CONNECTION REGARDING
TATTOO REMOVAL AND TRAUMA
HOWEVER THE REHABILITATION
PROCESS IS IT IS IT'S ALL
ENCOMPASSING IT'S NOT JUST
EDUCATION OUR VOCATION AS ALSO
ADDRESSING TRAUMA INFORMED AND
ISSUES THAT HAVE HAPPENED WITHIN
THE INCARCERATED PERSONS-
LIFESTYLE OR LIFE PRIOR TO
INCARCERATION AND DEALINGWITH
THOSE THINGS. THE REHABILITATION
IS MORE THAN JUST- THE REMOVAL
OF A TATTOO IT'S THE MENTAL
HEALTH COMPONENT- THAT IS A
WORKED ON AT THE INSTITUTION
IT'S THE EDUCATION COMPONENT
IT'S KIND OF AN- AN ALL
ENCOMPASSING- GRAHAM FOR THE-
RIGHT. OKAY FLY PRECIADO THANK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND EVERYONE
WHO SPOKE ON THIS ISSUE
OBVIOUSLY VERY IMPORTANT PROGRAM
THAT- WE WILL SUPPORT. THEY ARE
ACTUALLY THE SAID THAT BUT THAT
WAS MY PERSONAL. WAIT A MINUTE
THINK THAT BUT- NO I THINK IT'S
A REALLY REALLY GREAT THING.
OKAY LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE SIX-
ARE REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMMING
SUPPORT- CDC ARE PLEASE. WORKING
LARA ELDRIDGE ASSISTANT DEPUTY
DIRECTOR WITH ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT
DIVISION OF ADULT INSTITUTIONS.
THE DIVISION OF ADULT
INSTITUTIONS IS REQUESTING
FUNDING OPPOSITION TO SUPPORT
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMMING.
INNKREIS REGION INDIVIDUALS HAVE
THE ABILITY TO EARN CREDIT BASED
ON PARTICIPATION AND COMPLETION
OF SPECIFIC REAL BALLOTS WHERE
THE BILL LOOKING AT FOR
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS. SINCE
200-016-1717 THE DEPARTMENTS
INCREASED INMATE ACTIVITY GROUPS
FROM ELEVEN HUNDRED IT
PROXIMALLY FORTY SIX FIFTY IN
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO FISCAL
YEAR. INMATE ACTIVITY GROUPS
INCLUDE PROGRAMS SUCH AS A IN A
AFTER STAYING AND ARTS IN
CORRECTIONS. WITHIN THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS DEPARTMENTS
ESTABLISHED NURSE NURSING LET
THEIR PEER GROUPS AT INSTEAD AT
TEN INSTITUTIONS. AND IS
PROPOSING TO EXPAND THEM
STATEWIDE. NURSING LED
THERAPEUTIC GROUPS COVER TOPICS
SUCH AS MENTAL AND PHYSICAL
HEALTH AND WELLNESS. AND
SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND LYFT SKILLS
. THE DEPARTMENT DOES NOT HAVE
SUFFICIENT RESOURCES TO SUSTAIN
OR HANDLE THE EXPANSION OF THESE
GROUPS. THIS REQUEST WILL
PROVIDE STAFF RESOURCES TO
OVERSEE THE INMATE ACTIVITY
GROUPS TO ENSURE THEY MEET THE
REHABILITATIVE OBJECTIVES. AND
PERFORM THE ADMINISTRATIVE
FUNCTIONS NECESSARY TO SUPPORT
THE NURSING LAST CARE PETER. AND
I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE. OKAY
THANK YOU- SALT ELDRIDGE OF
FINANCE PLEASE. I SENTIMENT DOES
NOT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WHILE
WE'VE BEEN DEALING WITH COVERED
OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS AND IT'S
STILL A FLUID SITUATION WITH THE
CURRENT OUTBREAK ON THE CITY'S
NORTH BOUND OPPORTUNITIES TO
PROVIDE THE REHABILITATIVE
CREDIT EARNING PROGRAMS AND THE
STAFFING RESOURCES REQUESTED
WILL GO A LONG WAY IN HELPING
CDCR CONTINUE THEIR EFFORTS TO
PROVIDE INMATE ACTIVITY GROUPS
ANNOUNCED NURSING LED
THERAPEUTIC GROUPS OVER THE NEXT
YEAR. SO THIS ACTUALLY THIS
PROPOSAL IS- REQUESTING
APPROXIMATELY CHU OFFICE
TECHNICIAN STOP- INSTITUTION SO
THEY CAN CONTINUE TO PROVIDE THE
STABILITY NEEDED TO RUN THESE
PROGRAMS. THANK YOU. HELLO THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR. AT THE MOMENT
WE DON'T RAISE ANY CONCERNS.
OKAY SENATE QUARTERS HE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. THE BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I- WILL FALL
IN LINE WITH THE L. A- ON THIS
ONE THANK YOU. OKAY I HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS- OF- BECAUSE
OF THE PANDEMIC CONCERT SHIRTS
THAT HAD AN IMPACT ON ON
PROGRAMMING- SO- ARE THERE HAVE
THERE BEEN ARE THEIR ALTERNATE.
PROGRAMMING IN AND DOC CREDIT
EARNING OPPORTUNITIES- AND- IF
THE ARE THE GROUPS CURRENTLY
OPERATING IF NOT ARE THEY READY
TO RESUME OPERATIONS. CURRENTLY
FOR A DANCE FLOOR AND WE HAVE
WHAT WE CALL ROAD MAP TO REOPEN
AN EFFORT FACED ONE-
UNFORTUNATELY WE DON'T HAVE TO
ACT SOCIAL- INTERACTION- AS WE
REOPEN DUE TO THE NUMBER OF KOBE
CASES DECREASED THEME WE DO
START THAT INTERACTION WITH
SOCIAL DISTANCING. I AM IN BOTH
PARENTS AN INMATE ACTIVITY
GROUPS AS WELL AS THE NURSING
LIKE. SO CURRENTLY THERE ARE NO
ALTERNATE I MEAN. YOU SAY NAP
UNTIL AFTER THE- AT WHAT POINT
DO YOU START OF THE PROGRAMMING
OR HOW DO YOU MAKE UP FOR IT.
WHEN IT'S NOT WHEN THE PROGRAM
STOPPED. RIGHT NOW WE'RE
EXPLORING- WHAT WE CALL A PILOT
FOR RANCH FOR THAT AND WAIT THEY
DON'T REAL BAD. CREDIT YEAH- AND
THAT'S GOING TO BE LOOKING AT
INCEL PROGRAMMING TO EARN THESE
CREDITS WE OF COURSE PREFERRED
TO DO THINGS- SOCIALLY
INTERACTIVELY BECAUSE WE
ACTUALLY SEE THE INMATES
INTERACT IN A DIFFERENT WAY THAN
YOU IGHT SEE THEM- WHEN THEY'RE
DOING AND SELF STUDY SO WE WOULD
REALLY. WE REALLY HOPE TO
CONTINUE WITH THE SOCIAL FACTOR
OF IT. BUT WE UNDERSTAND WITH
TIMES LIKE THIS THAT WE CAN
OFFER AS MUCH AS WE CAN- AND
SENSELESS WELL. SO THEY CAN. TO
EARN THESE CRY. OKAY AND OF THE
UP PROGRAMMING HAS BEEN
SUSPENDED- HOW WILL YOU USE THE
RESOURCES. WE WOULD USE IT TO
SUPPORT THE END SALE- RACKS
PROGRAMS. OKAY I'M SORRY CAN YOU
JUST GIVE ME A REALLY QUICK
DESCRIPTION OF WHAT YOU MEAN BY
THE INCEL. WE WOULD OFFER THE
PROGRAMS- WE GO HEAD MAKE
PACKETS AND GIVEN TO THE INMATE
POPULATION. AND ENTER ALL THE
DATA JUST LIKE WE WOULD HAVE TO
BE NORMALLY IN A CLASSROOM
SETTING. BUT MEAN BY THEMSELVES
IN THEIR IN IN THEIR CELL. SO IF
THEY'RE IN SELF WE CAN'T COME
OUT TO SOCIALIZE WE PUT THE
PACKAGE TOGETHER THAT THEY WOULD
NORMALLY HAVE IN A CLASSROOM
SETTING WE WOULD DISTRIBUTE THEM
TO THAT POPULATION- GET THEM LOG
IN GET THEIR ATTENDANTS TAKE AND
GET THE PACKETS BACK REVIEW THE
PACKETS JUST LIKE WE WOULD
NORMALLY END UP. IN A REGULAR
CLASSROOM I THINK. THAT OKAY I
DON'T HAVE ANY MORE QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR ELDRIDGE
AND OTHERS FOR YOUR COMMENTS AND
FOR BEING WITH US TODAY. FIVE
OKAY ISSUE SEVEN IS THE
BACHELOR'S DEGREE EXPANSION CDCR
PLEASE. I HELLO PARDON MY PARDON
MY TECHNOLOGY CHALLENGE THERE. I
AM SHANNON SWAIN SUPERINTENDENT
OF THE OFFICE OF CORRECTIONAL
EDUCATION FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION AND I'M HERE TO
EXPLAIN BUT THERE IS A RULE
REHABILITATIVE REVOLUTION
UNDERWAY IN CALIFORNIA'S
PRISONS. IN THE PAST SEVEN YEARS
. SINCE THE PASSAGE OF SENATE
BILL THIRTEEN NINETY ONE WHICH
ALLOWED CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACULTY TO
TEACH CLASSES INSIDE CDCR
INSTITUTIONS. HIGHER EDUCATION
HAS GROWN ENORMOUSLY IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY LOS ANGELES BECAME
THE FIRST CSU OFFERING A BA
INSIDE CDCR SINCE THEN IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WE PILOTED **** AGREE
PATHWAYS IN FOR ADDITIONAL
INSTITUTIONS. I AM HERE TO
EXPLAIN TO EXPLAIN THAT
CORRECTIONAL EDUCATION IS
TRANSFORMATIVE. THE OFFICE OF
CORRECTIONAL EDUCATION SIX
EXTENT THE INVESTMENT CALIFORNIA
IS MAKING THROUGH ITS WORLD
CLASS HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM
YOU INCARCERATED CALIFORNIANS I
FUNDING BACHELOR OF ARTS DEGREE
PROGRAMS IN SEVEN CDC OUR
INSTITUTIONS. WE ARE REQUESTING
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS THE GENERAL
FUND DECREASING TO FOUR POINT
SEVEN MILLION ANNUALLY BEGINNING
IN TWENTY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE AND FIFTY POSITIONS TO
MAINTAIN AND EXPAND THE NUMBER
OF PRISONS OFFERING BACHELOR'S
DEGREE PROGRAMS IN PARTNERHIP
WITH SEVERAL. DIFFERENT
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
CAMPUSES. THE RESOURCES WOULD BE
USED TO MAINTAIN PROGRAMS THAT
FOR PRESENTS WHOSE EXISTING
FUNDING IS EXPIRING AND CREATE
NEW PROGRAMS AT THREE ADDITIONAL
PRESENCE FUNDING THOSE POSITIONS
TO PARTNER WITH CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY IS. ULTIMATELY THE
GOAL WOULD BE TO HAVE SEVEN
HOBBY INSTITUTIONS OFFERING A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE ENSURING
EQUITY FOR EVERY SECURITY LEVEL
AND ALL GENDERS. ELIGIBLE
STUDENTS WHO HAVE EARNED A FULLY
TRANSFERABLE ASSOCIATE OF ARTS
DEGREE IN ONE OF OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE PROGRAMS. ARE THEN ABLE
TO APPLY TO ONE OF THE C. ISSUES
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
STATUS PART AND PARTNERING WITH
CDCR. AND COMPLETE THE FINAL TWO
YEARS OF UPPER DIVISION COURSES.
WHAT YOU MIGHT THINK OF AS THEIR
JUNIOR AND SENIOR YEARS.
RESEARCH SUPPORTS HIGHER
EDUCATION AS EXTREMELY EFFECTIVE
AT RISK REDUCING RECIDIVISM. AND
THIS THAT THE FUNDING OF THE
SEVEN BE A PROGRAMS WOULD BE A
LONG TERM INVESTING. FUTURE ALL
OF THE OFFICE OF CORRECTIONAL
EDUCATION IS TO PROVIDE A TRUE
EDUCATION CONTINUUM. BUT THAT WE
CAN MEET STUDENTS WHERE THEY ARE
WHEN THEY ENTER THE CORRECTIONAL
SYSTEM. ASSESS THEIR SKILLS
ABILITIES AND DESIRES AND THEN
ASSIST THEM TO COMPLETE THEIR
GOALS WITHOUT A CERTIFICATION IN
A CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
PROGRAM. OR A COLLEGE DEGREE.
THE MULTI GENERATIONAL IMPACT.
BUT THAT IT COLLEGE HAS ON THE
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES
CANNOT BE OVERSTATED. THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO SHARE MY
ENTHUSIASM FOR HIGHER EDUCATION
IMPRISONMENT AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWERING. THANK YOU FOR SHARING
YOUR ENTHUSIASM. IT BRINGS VERY
GOOD PART OF YOUR PRESENTATION
THANK YOU I'M SORRY IS IT SWAY
DID YOU SAY YOUR LAST NAME PLANA
WITHIN AND SLAIN WAYNE OKAY
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT- THIS IS
OPPORTUNITY FOR FINANCE PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
SOME PRETTY MEMBERS ANY FRIENDS
OR WITH PARTNER FINANCE- NOTHING
SPECIFIC TO ADD AT THIS POINT IN
TIME IN ADDITION TO WHAT JAMES
SAID I WOULD JUST NOTE THE- CCR
IN FINANCE AND WORKING TO
PROVIDE RESPONSIVE INFORMATION
OF THE ALLEY I WAS QUESTIONS.
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH BOTH- THE
SUBCOMMITTEE AND THE L. A. OUR
TO PROVIDE ANY ADDITIONAL.
JUSTIFICATION FOR THE PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU- FROM FROM LA PLEASE.
YEAH THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND-
SENATORS AT THE AT THIS POINT
WE'RE CONTINUING TO ANALYZE THIS
PROPOSAL I WORKED WITH THE
DEPARTMENT AND ADMINISTRATION TO
RECEIVE FURTHER INFORMATION. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS THAT WE BROUGHT
UP IN THE AGENDA HAVE BEEN SINCE
ANSWERED. AND THE ADMINISTRATION
COULD SPEAK TO SOME OF THOSE WHY
WE THINK THAT THE PROPOSED
EXPANSION IS PROMISING GIVEN
THAT RESEARCH SUGGESTS. YEAH
HIGHER EDUCATION AS POSITIVE
OUTCOMES THERE IS A CONCERN WE
WANNA REYES TO THE LEGISLATURE
AT THIS POINT. SPECIFICALLY IT'S
NOT CLEAR WHY THE DEPARTMENT'S
FULL REQUESTED AMOUNT IS
NECESSARY SOME OF THE PROGRAMS
WERE ESTABLISHED AND OPERATED
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT'S EXISTING
BUDGET. HELLO LOOKS LIKE IT'S
FROZEN USE FROM MADAM CHAIR-
SORT OF BORED WITH THE-
LEGISLATIVE ANALYSTS OFFICE I
THINK MY COLLEAGUES VIDEO IS
FROZEN I CAN COMPLETE HIS
COMMENTS BOB ESSENTIALLY WHAT WE
ARE STILL WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT TO BE ABLE TO ANSWER
IS WHY ADDITIONAL FUNDING IS
NEEDED FOR THE EXSTING PROGRAMS
GIVING THAT GIVEN THAT THEY WERE
SUPPORTED WITHIN EXISTING
RESOURCES. BY THE DEPARTMENT
PREVIOUSLY- AND THIS INFORMATION
IS IMPORTANT FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO HAVE TO BE ABLE TO ASSESS
WHETHER OR NOT THE FULL AMOUNT
OF REQUESTED IS NECESSARY OR
IMAGE CDCR CAN CONTINUE TO USE
SOME OF ITS EXISTING FUNDING TO
SUPPORT THE PROGRAMS- AS MY-
COLLEAGUE INDICATED- WE'RE STILL
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT TO
GETHIS INFORMATION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
OTHER ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR FILLING TO- SENATE
QUARTERS HE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS YES IT IS A FOLLOW UP
THE TO THE OLEO. WHAT THE
CONCERNS OF ANY IDEA HAVE ABOUT
- IN A TIME. THOSE ACTUAL FISCAL
. COMECEI JUST MADE TO THE
SUNSET- SUNSETTING OF THE PILOT
PROGRAMS IS SAID HOW DOES A PLAY
TO JUST GET A LITTLE IN MY MIND
HERE ABOUT- MAKING THESE
INVESTMENTS RELATIVE TO ANY NEED
FOR LEGISLATION TO EXTEND THE
PILOTS IF THAT'S WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE WANTS TO DO. TO OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE REASON
THAT ADDITIONAL FUNDING IS BEING
REQUESTED IS BECAUSE B. THE
FUNDING FOR THE EXISTING
PROGRAMS IS EXPIRING HOWEVER
IT'S NOT CLEAR TO US WHY THAT'S
THE CASE OR WHY THE- FUNDING
CAN'T BE EXTENDED FOR EXAMPLE.
THE DEPARTMENT HAS INDICATED
THAT A PORTION OF THE FUNDING
THAT WAS SUPPORTING THESE
PROGRAMS RELATED TO BANKING
POSITIONS AND IT'S UNCLEAR TO US
AT THIS POINT WHAT THOSE MAKING
POSITIONS ARE OR WHY IT WOULD BE
POSSIBLE BERKELEY- DEPARTMENT TO
CONTINUE USING THE FUNDING
ASSOCIATED WITH THOSE POSITIONS.
TO SUPPORT THESE PROGRAMS. YEAH
I GIVE THEM I GUESS SOME PART
I'M ASKING IS IF. WE GOT PROGRAM
EXPIRATION DATES COMING FORWARD-
IT IN IN MAYBE I'M READING THE
REPORT WRONG- SO MAYBE MEASURE
WE COULD ASSESS A QUESTION OF-
THE OF THE DEPARTMENT ITSELF.
HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO THE ELOISE
COMMENTS AND TO WHAT EXTENT. ARE
WE FACING EXPIRATION DATES ON
THE PROGRAMS THEMSELVES. YES
SORRY THIS IS ALL JUMP IN VERSUS
BATTLE IN THE CLEAN- AND I CAN.
IF THERE'S ANY ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION NEEDED. TO BE CLEAR
WE DID A START THIS PILOT
PROJECT ON A VERY SMALL SENATE
POPULATION IF YOU'RE ABLE TO
SUPPORT IT LESS THAN FORTY. WHEN
THIS PROGRAM IS FULLY UP AND
RUNNING IT WILL SERVE OVER FOUR
HUNDRED AND TWENTY. PARTICIPANTS
AND SO IF THE- SAVINGS THAT WE
ARE CURRENTLY ANALYZING WAS
AVAILABLE ON A ONE TIME SPACES
TO SUPPORT THIS PROGRAM. I'M SO
WE IT'S NOT AN ONGOING SOLUTION-
FOR IT'S NOT. OPERATE YOU
POSSIBLY TRY TO FIND ONE TIME
SAVINGS TO SUPPORT THIS PROGRAM
ONGOING SPECIALLY CONSIDERING
HOW CRITICAL IT IS AND WE HAVE
THE AVAILABLE THANK YOU SO HOW
GRANT FUNDING TO OFFSET SOME OF
THIS AS WELL SO I. ALSO WANTED
TO POINT OUT THAT IT'S NOT ALL
GENERAL FUND THERE IS A PORTION
THAT WILL BE ABLE TO UTILIZE-
FEDERAL FUNDS FOR AS WELL. OKAY
ABSOLUTE AMOUNT I'M NOT SURE
THAT. CLEARS UP THE OLD L. L. A.
O.'S QUESTION AND IN MY MIND I
MEAN WHEN YES I DID NO AND HAVE
IN MY NOTES THE PROGRAM FUNDING-
BUT THAT ALMOST GOES. IN THE
DIRECTION OF THEIR CONCERN IF
YOU'RE A PELL GRANT FUNDING IN
EXISTING. FUNDING I KNOW YOU
SAID IT WAS ONE TIME- THAT IS
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IF I ME JUST
FOLLOW UP IS WHAT YOU'RE SAYING.
THAT YES WE'VE HAD EXISTING
FUNDING- CAPACITY AVAILABLE BUT
IT'S BEEN ONE TIME AND WE'RE
TRYING TO CONVERT THAT TO ON
GOING TO KEEP UP WITH THE GROWTH
OF THE PROGRAM. THAT'S CORRECT
SO WE HAVE. SALARY SAVINGS IS
ONLY ONE TIME IN NATURE IT'S AS
A RESULT OF A VACANT POSITIONS
THAT DEPARTMENT HAS THE ONE
POINT TIMES IT'S NOT SOMETHING
THAT WE- CANNOT I'M GOING. AT
THIS POINT WE DETERMINED THAT
THIS. PROJECT WAS VERY IMPORTANT
WE HAD SOMEAVAILABLE RESOURCES
TO START UP AGAIN ON A VERY
SMALL LIMIT. THAT SERVES LESS
THAN FORTY EIGHT OFFENDERS AS OF
THIS PROPOSAL. TAKES INTO
CONSIDERATION THE FEDERAL FUNDS.
OFFSET AND EXPANDS IT TO SEVEN
MORE INSTITUTIONS TOGETHER TO
GET UP TO A COURT COURT OF FOUR
HUNDRED TWENTY- OFFENDERS THAT
CAN JUST BE IN THIS PROGRAM
ANNUALLY. AGAIN IT'S- THE
SAVINGS WAS THERE ON A ONE TIME
BASIS TO DO THE PILOT PROGRAMS.
ACTIVE NESTS AND TO EVALUATE IT
AND THEN THIS PROPOSAL BRINGS
FORWARD- I'M MORE CONSOLIDATED
APPROACH- THAT COVERS. IT CAN
COVER MORE OFFENDERS. GET THE IF
I AGAIN THROUGH THE SURE WOULD
I'D REQUEST MET CHAIR IS. SOME
KIND OF OUT OF SPREADSHEET IT
DOESN'T SEEM LIKE WE NEED TO BE
VERY COMPLEX ARE VERY MANY CALLS
ON IT THAT SHOW- THE POSITION.
THESE THESE POSITION DOLLARS-
THE POSITIONS THAT ARE
ELIMINATED OR THE UNF ARE THE
POSITIONS THAT ARE COMPLETELY
ELIMINATED OR JUST VACANT FUNDED
POSITIONS WHICH I THINK WOULD BE
OF CONCERN TO THE LA- BECAUSE
HAVE HAD BIG FUNDED POSITIONS-
SURE YOU HAVE ONE TIME SAVINGS
RIGHT NOW BUT ALSO RAISES A
QUESTION ABOUT WHY YOU WOULDN'T
ROLL THOSE VACANT FUNDED
POSITIONS FORWARD TO- TO FILL
SOME OF THE NEED HERE THE STAR
FOR DOLLAR- BUT IF YOU COULD
JUST GIVE US. IS SOCIALLY WITH
THE ALEJO'S ASKING FOR AND I
THINK. BUT BUT WE'RE ASKING FOR
AT THE COMMITTEE HERE JUST IN A
SUPPLEMENTARY. STACK SUPPLE A
SUPPLEMENTAL SPREADSHEET- YOU
KNOW SOMETIME SOON AFTER THIS
COMMITTEE MEETING I THINK THAT
WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL ON ON NOT
SPEAK VERY SPECIFIC TOPIC OF. OF
ONE TIME POSITIONS VERSES
ONGOING POSITIONS OF PURSES YOU
KNOW THE BUDGET MADE HERE. BUT
I'M NOT I'M NOT CHALLENGING ON
THE THEY JUST WANNA MAKE SURE WE
UNDERSTAND THAT. THANK YOU.
UNDERSTOOD AND THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
L. A. O. ON AND THIS IS.
POSITIONS THAT WE HAVE THEIR
PERMANENT POSITIONS ARE BIG WHEN
THEY'RE BIG AND THEY'RE ONLY
BAKE AT ONE TIME YEAH I JUST
CERTAIN POINT IN TIME WE ONLY
CAPTURE THAT SAVINGS- FOR THAT
ONE SMALL PERIOD OF TIME THAT
THEY ARE VACANT. AND SO TO THE
EXTENT WE ARE WE HAD A
SUPPOSITIONS BACON TO UTILIZE
THAT'S WHAT WE DID BUT YOU CAN'T
KEEP THOSE POSITIONS BAKER I'M
GOING ARTS CENTER MY- OPERATION.
I. UNDERSTAND THE POINT YOU'RE
MAKING THANK YOU. THE THING
THAT- I THINK WOULD BE HELPFUL
TO ADD ON TO THAT IS THAT- THE
LEGISLATURE IN ITS DISCRETION
COULD TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT THOSE
MAKING POSITIONS WARRANTY EXTENT
THOSE POSITIONS WERE ASSOCIATED
WITH PROGRAMS OR ACTIVITIES THAT
THE LEGISLATURE. DOESN'T
PRIORITIZE ANYMORE IT COULD
DIRECT THE DEPARTMENT TO
PERMANENTLY REDIRECT THAT
FUNDING FOR SUPPORTED THIS
PROGRAM. YEAH THAT WAS PART OF
MY QUESTION EXACTLY THANK YOU
ANYWAY IF WE COULD JUST GET THE
SPREADSHEET ON THAT ARE. YOU
KNOW SORT OF THE NUANCES THERE
ARE- ON A SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT
THAT WOULD BE GREAT THANK YOU
MANAGER THANK YOU. UP MISTER
KLEIN IS THAT REQUEST. FONG
CLEAR. YES YEAH THANK YOU RIGHT
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I
JUST HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS
ON THE- ON THE PROGRAM ITSELF-
OF WHAT WAS THEIR INVOLVEMENT OF
THE C. ISSUES AND- PUTTING THESE
PROGRAMS TOGETHER BEACON. JUST
TAKE A MINUTE TO TALK ABOUT THAT
. SURE WE COLLABORATED SO WHAT
WHAT HAPPENS AS FREQUENTLY WE
HEAR FROM FACULTY FROM DIFFERENT
COLLEGES THAT THEY'RE INTERESTED
ON WHAT WE'VE LEARNED OVER THE
LAST YEAR OR TWO IS THAT IT
REALLY REQUIRES A COMMITMENT
FROM THE VERY TOP LEVEL OF THE
UNIVERSITY- SO. WE WORKED WITH
SAC STATE TO GET A VERY SMALL
PROGRAM UP AT FOLSOM STATE
PRISON AND MULE CREEK STATE
PRISON- AND WE UTILIZED-
TECHNOLOGY TO DO THAT BECAUSE OF
THE PANDEMIC- WE ALSO BROUGHT
UP. A SORT OF. INTRO PROGRAM IF
YOU WELL AT VALLEY STATE PRISON
AND AT C. C. W. F. THE
CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S FACILITY.
WITH ALL STATE FRESNO AND FOR
THAT PROGRAM THAT WHOLE PROCESS
OF DEVELOPING THE- FORMAL
CURRICULAR PARENTS AND WORKING
WITH THE ACADEMICS BENNETT IS
ALL BEING TAKEN CARE OF. BY
FRESNO STATE. AND THEN OF COURSE
OUR PROGRAM AT LEC. SERVE OUR
GRANDDADDY OF OUR BA PROGRAMS
THAT REALLY GOT OFF THE GROUND
INITIALLY UTILIZING SECOND
CHANCE PELL DOLLARS AGAIN AS AN
EXPERIMENT. AND NOW WE HAVE SEEN
THE SUCCESS WE HAD A MANY MEN
GRADUATE LAST YEAR INCLUDING
CINEMA FORMER LIFE FOR INMATES
WHO WERE ABLE TO RELEASED AND
GRADUATE ON CAMPUS AT CAL STATE
LA. SO WE ARE SEEKING TO EXTEND
FOR SIX OF THOSE PROGRAMS TO
OTHER INST ANCE. MIGHT IS THAT
WE WILL HAVE. A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE OPPORTUNITY AVAILABLE TO
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS AND EVERY
SECURITY LEVEL IN EVERY
GEOGRAPHIC AREA AND THE STATE.
AND IN BOTH GENDERS. GREAT THANK
YOU AND THEN JUST ONE MORE
QUESTION ON THAT- WELL HOW DO
YOU SUPPORT- THE INMATES- YOU
KNOW AS THE YOU KNOW THERE IF
THEY SAY THEY'RE ELIGIBLE HOW DO
YOU MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE
SUCCESSFUL IN AND COMPLETING THE
BACHELOR'S DEGREE. WELL I'M WE
DEDICATE NOT ONLY IS A- AT THE
UNIVERSITY FACULTY WHICH
PROVIDES THE SAME LEVEL OF
COUNSELING SUPPORT AND
ASSISTANCE WITH PLANNING WHERE
I. DEGREE PATHWAY ETCETERA. AND
THE INSIDE OF THE INSTITUTIONS
ARE WE'VE BEEN UTILIZING STAFF
FROM- FROM. FROM FROM R. A. B.
E. PROGRAMS ADULT BASIC
EDUCATION PROGRAMS I BECAUSE WE
WERE IN A PANDEMIC AND THEY WERE
NOT INSTRUCTING ONE ON ONE WE
UTILIZE THEIR SERVICE ASSIST TO
ASSIST US IN PUTTING THIS
TOGETHER AND WHAT THEY DO IS AND
THE REASON THAT WE NEED STAFF TO
RUN THIS PROGRAM. IS THAT THEY
NEED TO ATTEND A COMMITTEE
MEETINGS. THE PROSECUTION
COMMITTEE MEETINGS THEY NEED TO
COORDINATE WITH UNIVERSITY
FACULTY ON SETTING UP THE
SCHEDULE ON ARRANGING SPACE
HONEST THE STING TO BRING UP
THAT TECHNOLOGY A WHEN NEEDED-
UNTIL WE CAN GET BACK TO FACE TO
FACE WHICH IS HOPEFULLY SOON-
AND THEN THEY ALSO ASSIST WITH
ALL OF THE- KEEPING FUNCTION.
CDCR REQUIRES IN OUR US
STRATEGIC OFFENDER MANAGEMENT
DATABASE MAKING SURE THAT ALL OF
THAT GETS- PUT INTO THE DATABASE
AND COMMUNICATE REGULARLY WITH
FACULTY I HADN'T SAID THAT THERE
IS A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF WORK
INVOLVED- AT THE STATE LEVEL.
MOST OF THESE PROGRAMS OCCUR IN
THE EVENING I BECAUSE WE DO HAVE
SPACE. CONSIDERATIONS AND DURING
THE DAY. A CLASS. WITH ADULTS
IS. THE CHEAPER IN HIGH SCHOOL
AND ALL OF THE OTHER. AMAZING AT
OPPORTUNITIES EXPATS SO WE BEEN
. THE MAJORITY OF THE CLASSES
DURING THIRD WATCH. AND SO
THERE'S ALSO- YOU KNOW WE NEED
TO CONSIDER THINGS LIKE CUSTODY
ESCORT AND MAKING SURE THAT WE
CAN GET. IT GOES FROM ONE YARD
TO THE OTHER WHERE WHERE THE
CLASSES MAY ACTUALLY BE
CONDUCTED. HOPE THAT HELPS
THAT'S YOUR QUESTION YEAH GREAT.
THANK YOU- MISS WHEN PRECIADO
YOUR ENTHUSIASM. AND THANK YOU
TO EVERYONE WHO PRESENTED I JUST
WANT TO SHARE THAT I A FEW YEARS
AGO I DID VISIT- OF FACILITY AND
WAS GOING TO CLASSROOM AFTER
CLASSROOM. AND AS IT DOES THE
GENTLEMEN WERE STANDING UP TO
TALK ABOUT WHY THEY- LOVE YOU
KNOW TAKING THESE CLASSES I
NOTICED THAT THERE WERE MANY OF
THEM WHO HAD. TWO OR THREE OR
FOUR EIGHT EIGHTIES. BUT
MULTIPLE CALLS ARE LIKE OKAY LET
ME DO IT HERE AND THEY COULDN'T
GET FURTHER. IN THEIR SPECIALTY
IN THERE AND THE AREA THAT THEY
REALLY WANTED TO BECAUSE THEY
WERE STUCK. SO YEAH THIS IS A
HUGE REGION ARE I'M SORRY REASON
I'M REALLY PURSUING THIS WE WANT
OUR STUDENTS TO BE ABLE TO
START. ON THE DAY THEY COME INTO
THE TO THE PRESENT I'M I'M BE
ASSESSED AND THEN WE TAKE THEM
AS FAR AS THEY WANT TO GO IN
TERMS OF EDUCATION. SO FIRST
WORKING ON THAT HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA THEN INTO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AND THEN SHE STATE FARM
ESPECIALLY IN THOSE
CORRESPONDENTS COMMUNITY COLLEGE
PROGRAMS IT ONLY TAKES THREE
ADDITIONAL CLASSES SOMETIMES. ON
AN ADDITIONAL. EIGHT FORTUNATELY
THOSEIT AGREES OR NOT- ALWAYS
TRANSFER TO CALIFORNIA STATE%
UNIVERSITY WHICH IS WHY WE'VE
INVESTED SO MUCH TIME. ENERGY
AND RESOURCES INTO MAKING SURE
THAT OUR ASSOCIATE OF ARTS
DEGREE PROGRAMS NOW MEET WHAT
ARE CALLED THE GOLDEN FOR- WITH
THAT REPAIR STUDENTS TO BE. BE A
STUDENTS AT AT CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY. RIGHT OKAY THANK YOU
ALL VERY MUCH THANK YOU MISS
LANE- WE MOVE ON NOW TO ISSUE
EIGHT WHICH IS THE CELLULAR
INTERDICTION PROGRAM AND A WILL
HAVE CDC ARE PRESENT. MORNING
SENATORS I'M CAMMIE IRWIN I TEAM
MANAGER TO AT CDC OUR-
ENTERPRISE INFORMATION SERVICES
. AT THIS BCP PROVIDES FUNDING
POSITIONS TO SUPPORT THE
STATEWIDE EXPANSION AND UPGRADE
OF THE MANAGED ACCESS SYSTEMS
MANAGE ACCESS IS A CRITICAL
COMPONENT OF THE DEPARTMENT'S
CONTRABAND CELLULAR PHONE
INTERDICTION STRATEGY AND IS
DESIGNED TO DISRUPT CONTRABAND
CELLPHONE COMMUNICATIONS AND
ENABLE THE DEPARTMENT TO
INTERFERE WITH AND DISMANTLE
CONTRABAND DISTRIBUTION
CHANNELS. CONTRABAND DIRECTLY
IMPACTS THE SAFETY OF THE
INCARCERATED POPULATION STAFF
AND THE PUBLIC THE PRESENCE OF
CONTRABAND ALSO HAS MANY
NEGATIVE OUTCOMES INCLUDING
VICTIMIZATION ITS CITIZENS
AUSTERITIES WITHIN THE
INCARCERATED POPULATION. RISK OF
OVERDOSE AND THE INTERFERENCE
WITH AN ENVIRONMENT CONDUCIVE TO
SUCCESSFUL REHABILITATION.
CONTRABAND CELLPHONES DELIVER A
LINK BETWEEN INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS AND OUTSIDE ACTORS
ENABLING THE CONTINUOUS
OPERATION OF CONTRABAND
DISTRIBUTION NETWORKS AND OTHER
CRIMINAL ACTIVITIES. I WAS AS
BIG UPGRADE OF THE MANAGED
ACCESS SYSTEMS AT THE EIGHTEEN
INSTITUTIONS WHERE IT CURRENTLY
EXISTS AND EXPANSION OF THE
INVOLVED TECHNOLOGY TO THE
REMAINING INSTITUTION. MY
COLLEAGUES AND I ARE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY OF YOUR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU IS THERE A WIN ON
FINANCE PLEASE. LAST NAME IN THE
PARTMINER FINANCE WE JUST WANTED
TO AGAIN EMPHASIZE AND STRESS
THE IMPORTANCE OF THE SAFETY
ASPECTS OF THIS PROPOSAL AND
NOTE THAT- IT IS A THREE YEAR
ROLLOUT FOR THE EQUIPMENT AND
INSTALLATION SO THERE IS SOME
FLEXIBILITY AS FAR AS WHICH
INSTITUTIONS. HE PROPOSAL HITS
AT WHICH TIME AND THAT'S IN
MEDIATION TO THE L. A. AS
CONCERNS ABOUT INVESTING IN
INFRASTRUCTURE AND INSTITUTIONS
THAT MAKE CLOTHES IN THE FUTURE
OKAY. I'M SORRY WITH THAT LAST
REMARK YOU SAID- STRATUM AND
WHAT WAS IT ABOUT. THE
CONNECTION WITH THE- BOB THE
FUTURE CLOSURES. A. L. A. O. HAD
NOTED SOME CONCERNED WITH MAKING
THIS INVESTMENT AND PROVIDING
RESOURCES FOR INSTALLATION AND
EQUIPMENT OF THE SYSTEM AT
INSTITUTIONS THAT MAKE CLOTHES
IN THE FUTURE AND AGAIN I JUST
WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT IT
INCLUDES INSTALLATION OVER THREE
YEARS SO THE BUDGETING IS
FLEXIBLE IN ALLOWING FOR YOU
KNOW FUTURE DECISIONS ABOUT
FACILITIES TO BE MADE. BUT THIS
WILL BE PART OF. THAT PLAN THE
INTERNET NOW WITH THE PLAN IS TO
AND COULD BE INSTALLATION AT
THIRTY THREE INSTITUTIONS. TO DO
THIS YES. BUT THAT DOES THAT
INCLUDES THE POSSIBILITY OF.
WHAT IS THE ISSUE OF POTENTIAL
CLOSERS COMMAND AS FAR AS THOSE
THIRTY THREE INSTITUTIONS. MY
POINT SORRY SENATOR WITH BET WE
ARE MAKING THE COMMITMENT ALL AT
ONCE IN A SINGLE YEAR SO IN THE
FUTURE YEARS AS WE'RE ROLLING
OUT IN IMPLEMENTING THIS
PROPOSAL AND THERE IS SOME
FLEXIBILITY AS FAR AS THE
BUDGETING IS CONCERNED CREDIT
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
CLARIFICATION. OKAY OUT PLEASE.
WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WITHHOLD ACTION ON
THIS PROPOSAL AS WELL AS THE
NEXT PROPOSAL ON YOUR AGENDA
ISSUE NINE WHICH IS THE
STATEWIDE CORRECTIONAL VIDEO
SURVEILLANCE CONTINUATION
PROPOSAL AND THAT'S BECAUSE BOTH
OF THESE PROPOSALS INVOLVES
MODIFYING INFRASTRUCTURE AT
SEVERAL PRISONS AND- THE
ADMINISTRATION IS EXPECTED TO
RELEASE VERY SOON A REPORT
IDENTIFYING- AND PRIORITIZING
THE CAPITAL OUTLAY AND DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS OVER FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS. THAT IT EXPECTS
TO NEED OVER THE NEXT TEN YEARS-
ACROSS THE PRISON SYSTEM AND SO
WE THINK THAT WHEN THE
LEGISLATURE HAS THIS INFORMATION
IT WOULD BE IN A BETTER POSITION
TO. ASSESS THESE PROPOSALS AS
WELL AS WELL AS OTHER PROPOSALS
THAT INVOLVE MODIFICATION TO
PRISON INFRASTRUCTURE- AND THEN
JUST TO ADDRESS MYSTERY ALMONDS
COMMENT- WELL IT'S TRUE THAT
THIS FOR WOULD INVOLVE
MODIFICATION OF. THE THIRTY
THREE CURRENTLY OPERATED BY
STATE OWNED PRESENTS OVER THE
NET OVER A FEW YEARS- THE
LEGISLATURE COULD ALSO. SIMPLY
APPROVE ONE YEAR OF FUNDING IF
IT'S- YOU'RE NOT COMFORTABLE. AT
APPROVING FUNDING AT ALL PRISONS
GIVEN THE POSSIBILITY OF CLOSURE
AND. IF YOU CAN'T INFRASTRUCTURE
MODIFICATIONS REPAIR YOU KNOW
LARGER OVERHAULS OF CERTAIN
FACILITIES ETCETERA. THANK YOU
IS AN ILL- CONGRESS CENTER
COURTESY ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. MY ONLY COMMENT IS-
YOU KNOW I WOULD I WOULD SHARE
THE CONCERNS OF THE L. A. O.
WITH REGARD TO. ADDRESSING
PERSPECTIVE FACILITY CLOSURES OR
YOU KNOW. REDUNDANCY WITH IS
WHAT I'M HEARING POTENTIALLY
WITH- THE UPCOMING DEFERRED MADE
ITS BUDGET SO AT I THINK WE
SHOULD PAY ATTENTION TO THAT- NO
DOUBT IN IN I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S
A- IF IT'S ABOVE. METHODOLOGY
THAT SERVER USING IN TERMS OF
BUDGETING- YOU KNOW ESSENTIALLY
TO SET UP A TIERED- A DECISION
MAKING ESSENTIALLY AND WITHIN
THE BUDGET ITSELF SO IN OTHER
WORDS IF YOU WANT TO APPROVE
THIS AND GO FORWARD WITH IT BOB
BUT WITH THE STIPULATION THAT-
THAT THE DOLLARS BE TURNED BACK
OVER TO DEFERRED. MAINTENANCE IF
INDEED GENERAL DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE FOR- FOR CDC ARE. IF
INDEED A PARTICULAR FACILITY IS
SHUT DOWN SO THAT WE DON'T HAVE
TO KEEP REVISITING THAT DECISION
YOU KNOW IF THEY'RE IF THEY'RE
ONE YEAR INTO THIS AND THEY SAY
OH WE'RE NOT GOING TO NEED THESE
DOLLARS ANYMORE- ON VIDEO
SURVEILLANCE FOR THIS PARTICULAR
FACILITY WHY NOT JUST HAVE THEM.
GIVE THEM THE DISCRETION IN
ADVANCE TO IMMEDIATELY SHIFT
THOSE OVER. THE SIMPLY CO MINGLE
THOSE DOLLARS WITH GENERAL
MAINTENANCE STORE SOLD ACT.
THAT'S WHAT I'D LIKE TO SEE I
JUST DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S EVER
DONE BUT- WE'RE GOING TO MAKE
THOSE KIND OF STIPULATIONS.
ANYWAY THANK YOU FOR. ALLOWING
ME TO COMMENT. WELL AS I RECALL
LAST YEAR WE HAD A LOT OF
DISCUSSION HERE. ABOUT THE-
ADMINISTRATION'S PLANS OR LACK
OF PLANS OR LACK OF SHARING
THOSE PLANS AND IT WAS ALL
AROUND OUR- ABILITY. TO BE ABLE
TO MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT FUNDING
THEN. OF RENOVATIONS AND OTHER
YOU KNOW BIG- CAPITAL OUTLAY SO
WE HAD THAT DISCUSSION. WE YOU
KNOW ESTABLISH THE NEED TO HAVE
THAT INFORMATION AND I DON'T
THINK WE HAVE GOTTEN THAT
INFORMATION IN A VERY
STRUCTURED. PLANNED WAY I DON'T
KNOW IF FINANCED WANTS TO
RESPOND TO THAT BUT- IT IS
IMPORTANT TO US AS THE
LEGISLATURE. TO KNOW WHERE WE'RE
GOING SO THAT WE CAN MAKE THOSE
DECISIONS NOW AND I APPRECIATE.
THAT THE COMMENT WAS MADE ABOUT
HAVING FLEXIBILITY BUT THERE'S A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN HAVING
FLEXIBILITY WHEN YOU'RE- FACED
WITH IT AND HAVING TO MAKE THESE
DECISIONS SO- I TOTALLY AGREE
WITH YOU US SECRETARY Z. ABOUT.
THE IMPORTANCE OF PAYING
ATTENTION TO THAT- AND WE'RE
JUST GOING TO KEEP ON INSISTING
HAVING THAT INFORMATION IN ORDER
FOR US TO MAKE THE BEST POSSIBLE
A DECISIONS AND JUST. ALONG
THOSE LINES THERE IS- THIS
REPORT- ON DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
AND CAPITAL OUTLAYS THAT WAS
EXPECTED IN JANUARY- WHEN. DO WE
EXPECT TO GET THAT REPORT. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR JUST NAMED THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AGAIN I WE
UNDERSTAND AND APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S CONCERNING AND
WE ARE CONTINUING TO WORK WITH
THE DEPARTMENT ON RELEASING THE
MASTER PLAN ANNUAL REPORT. IN
THAT WOULD BE SUPPLEMENTAL
REPORTING LANGUAGE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE PROVIDED I DON'T
HAVE A GAME RIGHT NOW BUT WE ARE
WORKING TO GET THAT TO YOU AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE. OKAY REMEMBER
THAT I WANT THAT. WRITTEN DOWN
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE I WANT TO
SEE OF MY DEFINITION OF AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE IS SIMILAR TO YOUR
BUSINESS TO EDELMAN. OKAY LET'S
MOVE ON THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH
FOR BEING WITH US AND END UP
PRESENTING TO US TODAY- WE MOVE
ON NOW TO ISSUE NINE- WHICH IS A
STATEWIDE CORRECTIONAL VIDEO
SURVEILLANCE. CONTINUATION OF
CDCR PLEASE. MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS MERRY INSTRUMENT I'M AN
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS REHABILITATION. LET
ME SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY. THIS
REQUEST IS TO CONTINUE OUR
STATEWIDE CORRECTIONAL VIDEO
SURVEILLANCE ROLLOUT WHICH WILL
INCLUDE FINDING A POSITION TO
DEPLOY SIX CAMERAS AT TEN
ADDITIONAL PRISONS. AND BODY
WORN CAMERAS AT FOR ADDITIONAL
PRISONS. THIS IS WORK REQUESTS
ALSO PROVIDES FUNDING TO MANAGE
AND MAINTAIN THE RECORDED VIDEO
. AT SIX CAM RISEN BY ONE CAMERA
TECHNOLOGY CAPTURES AND STORES
VIDEO EVIDENCE TO IMPROVE THE
DEPARTMENT'S ABILITY TO CONDUCT
INVESTIGATIONS OF ALL DIFFERENT
KINDS AND GET DOWN TO THE BOTTOM
OF WHAT TOOK PLACE. TO THE BEST
OF OUR ABILITY. THIS REQUEST
CONTINUES ON PREVIOUSLY APPROVED
PROJECTS JUST KIND OF MENTIONED
EARLIER BY YOURSELF AND OTHERS
THAT HAVE BEEN COMPLETED.
BECAUSE WE'VE COMPLETED
INSTALLATION OF THE NEWER
TECHNOLOGY AT EIGHT OF OUR
PRISONS AND ABOUT WE HAVE BODY
WORN CAMERAS ACTIVE AT SIX OF
REPRESENTS RIGHT NOW. AND THE-
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT
INCLUDE A RESOURCES FOR OUR
DEPARTMENT TO DEPLOY SIX CAMERAS
AT FOR ADDITIONAL PRISONS. AND
SO THIS KIND OF CONCLUDES MY
COMMENTS AND I'M AVAILABLE FOR
ANY QUESTIONS. OKAY COMMENTS BY
. PLEASE. I'M SURE THIS IS A
FRIENDS WAY FROM DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AGAIN- IT NOW SEEMS
SPECIFIC TO ADD- TO MISTER
STURMAN COMMENTS AT THIS POINT
IN TIME- I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT
THE MINISTRATION MEANS COMMITTED
TO THE POLICY BENEFITS A VIDEO
SURVEILLANCE WHICH IS MORE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
WITHIN IT'LL INSTITUTIONS AND
NOT ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT.
YOUR MAPS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
R. L. A. O. COMMENTS PLEASE.
MISS O'NEILL. IN YOU AS I NOTED
IN COMMENTS ON THE PREVIOUS AYE
WE READ WITHHOLDING ARE ON THIS
. AND JUDITH ANTICIPATED
FACILITY WORK- HOWEVER IT ALSO
WITH RESPECT TO THIS PROPOSAL
THAT- PROPOSED IT INCLUDES FOUR
NEW POSITIONS THAT WOULD BE- I'M
FOCUSED ON REDACTION OF VIDEO
AND AUDIO RECORDS. AND WE-
THERE'SAT A COUPLE OTHER
PROPOSALS THAT ARE COMING UP-
LATER IN THE AGENDA THAT ALSO
INCLUDE RESOURCES FOR REACTION
WHEN WE FIRST TOOK A LOOK AT
THESE PROPOSALS- WE FOUND THAT
THERE WASN'T. A SUFFICIENT
INFORMATION PROVIDED TO JUSTIFY
THE NEED FOR IT THESE- REDUCTION
RESOURCES ADMINISTRATION HAS
SINCE PROVIDED ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION AND WE'RE STILL
WORKING THROUGH IT SO- WE WILL
AND GO TO FIND THE LEGISLATURE
WHEN WE- REACH. CITIES
PRODUCTION RESOURCE THAT ARE IN
ACROSS MULTI PROPOSALS. GREAT
THANK YOU MUCH I COLLEAGUES
QUESTIONS- CA. THIS IS THE SAME
COMMON BEFORE YOUR THAT FORWARD
FROM THE PREVIOUS ITEM THANK YOU
OKAY GREAT OKAY OKAY- I HAVE A
COUPLE QUESTIONS- HOW ARE THINK
PROBABLY FOR YOU MR SPEARMAN.
HOW ARE THE TEN STATES TEN
PRISONS BEING SELECTED- FOR
INSTALLATION OF THE FIXED
CAMERAS- AND THEN A COUPLE OF
OTHER QUESTIONS AFTER THAT. BUT
BASS MAN SHARE WE LOOKED AT THE
INSTITUTION'S KINDA THINGS THAT
TAKE PLACE IN PRISON CERTAIN
INCIDENCES AND DIFFERENT
ALLEGATIONS. WE LOOK AT THAT WE
ALSO LOOKED AT THE FACT THAT
I'LL JUST KIND OF MENTION LIKE
THERE'S- FOR PRISONS DOWN AND
APPLIES THEN THIS COMPUTER ABOUT
LATE SO WE PICKED WILL BOTH
PRISONERS TO DO AT THE SAME TIME
CALIPATRIA SOMETHING OUT OF
pTHEIR- AND THE SAME THING. WITH
THE TWO PRISONERS AND BLIGHTS-
CHUCKWALLA US HERE PRESENT
HIGHEST P. AND THE SAME THING
WITH CMF AND SALON ALSO WE LOOK
AT PRISONS IN OUR SCHEDULE OF
HOW WE ROLL THEM OUT KIND OF THE
LEVEL THREES BECAUSE WE GOT
FORCED DOWN. I WORK IN THE LEVEL
THREE IS LAW HIGHER CUSTODY AND
THEN AT THE PRISON HAS A PRISON
COLOCATED IT'S KIND OF PRUDENT
FOR THE TAXPAYER FOR US TO HAVE
PEOPLE WHO INFRASTRUCTURE INTO
THINGS OF THAT NATURE AT THOSE
TO PRESERVE THE SAME TIME. IN
DOING ONE OF THOSE PRESENTS AND
GOING SOMEWHERE ELSE. AND COMING
BACK AND SO FORTH. OKAY THANK
YOU- I S. SEE THAT THERE ARE
SEVERAL OF EVENTS THAT REQUIRES
SURVEILLANCE FOOTAGE TO BE KEPT
LONGER THAN THE STANDARD NINETY
DAY- HOW ARE THOSE INCIDENTS
FLAGGED. WHAT HAPPENS IT MADAM
CHAIR IS IF THERE'S AN INCIDENT
THAT REQUIRES COLLEGE TRIGGERING
WHICH IS IN OUR DEPARTMENT
POLICY IF IT. EVENT TAKES PLACE
ON IT NEEDS BE FLAG OR WILL SAVE
EVIDENCE THESE PRESENT SERVE
GENERALLY A COOK AT THE LEVEL OF
A CORRECTION LIEUTENANT. SECOND
ANSWER COMMANDER THAT PERSON
WOULD BE THE PERSON TO BOOKMARK
THE- EVENT THAT NEEDS TO BE
PRESERVED THE EVIDENCE AND THEN
IT SAID OVER TRIMESTER GAVE
SERVICES UNIT AND INNOVATE WILL
PRESERVE THAT EVIDENCE ALSO IF I
A COMPLAINT CAME IN FROM A
CITIZEN SOMEONE'S LOVE ONE OR
ITS- REPENTANCE INVESTIGATION
SOMETHING IS BROUGHT UP TO HATE.
THERE COULD BE VIDEO EVIDENCE
THEN THAT. SAME EVIDENCE COULD
BE FLAGGED. OKAY BUT THE AND
THOSE ARE SO. OF KEEPING THEM
LONGER KEEPING THE FOOTAGE
LONGER THAN THE NINETY DAYS.
THAT STANDARD. THAT'S CORRECT.
OKAY ALL RIGHT AND THEN- THERE
IS AN ISSUE OF CAMERA DOWNTIME-
HOW WILL YOU MONITOR THAT DOWN
TIME TO IDENTIFY STAFF OR
FACILITIES WHERE CAMERAS ARE
TURNED OFF- PARTICULARLY FOR A
BODY WORN CAMERAS ARE TURNED OFF
MORE. THAN USUAL. IT MANAGER
WE'VE HEARD THOSE CONCERNS AND
SOLD THEIR DEPARTMENT STARTED
BACK A FEW MONTHS AGO PUTTING
TOGETHER OR OF COURSE CALL OUT
BODY WORN CAMERA YOU SHOULD
AUDIT REPORT. FOR HIRING AT THE
WAY BEING A WHARTON OR THEIR
CHIEF DEPUTY A COUPLE OF THE
DESIGNEES TO PRESENT COULD TAKE
A LOOK AT THE REPORT TO SEE HOW
MANY HOURS THE CAMERA IS ON. AT
THIS POINT THE SIX BODY WORN
CAMERAS WE STARTED EIGHT TEST OF
THAT PROCESS LAST WEEK I THINK
IT STARTED ON MONDAY WE HAD A
MEETING WITH ALL THE SIX PRISONS
AND GAVE THEM THE REPORT THAT
CAME FROM OUR PARTNERS BUT MRS
IRWIN PROVIDED. ACTUALLY
STRUCTURE AND A MEMORANDUM HOW
WITH DO THAT SO THAT'S TAKING
RIGHT NOW FOR US TO IF IS THERE
SOME ACTS TRAINING OFF IF THERE
IS AN THAT WILL ALLOW THE HIGHER
AUTHORITY A LOOK THAT WE
RESTRUCTURED DISCIPLINARY MATRIX
TO WHERE IF SOMEONE
INTENTIONALLY IS TRAINER CAMERA
OFF WE'RE NOT TURNING IT ON AT
ALL THROUGHOUT THEIR WHOLE GROUP
OLDER OLD SHIFTS. AT THAT POINT
A PERSON WILL RECEIVE SOME FORM
OF THE DISCIPLINARY ACTION
INCLUDING UP INTO. INCLUDING
DISMISSAL. OKAY THAT'S ALL FOR
ME- MR SPEARMAN JUST WANTED YOU
KNOW MORE OKAY MRS HERMAN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION WITH US TODAY AND-
ONE. MOVE ON TO ISSUE TEN. AND
THIS IS A VARIOUS LEGAL AND I.
T. PROPOSAL SO SOMEONE FROM CDC
ARE. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
MADELINE MACLEAN AGAIN FROM CDC
ARE I'M GOING TO BRIEFLY RUN
THROUGH MOST OF THESE THERE ARE
SEVERAL PROPOSALS CONTAINED
WITHIN THIS ONE ITEM THE FIRST
ITEM IS CLASS ACTION STAFF- THIS
BC HE IS REQUESTING FUNDING IN
POSITIONS TO HANDLE THE COMPLEX
LEGAL WORK INVOLVED IN CLASS
ACTION LAWSUITS. WITH THE GOAL
OF CREATING EFFICIENT EFFECTIVE
EXIT STRATEGIES AND INCREASE THE
ABILITY OF OUR OFFICE OF LEGAL
AFFAIRS TO BE MORE PROACTIVE IN.
OTHER RESOURCES STOP BY THIS
REQUEST WILL PROVIDE ADVICE AND
ASSISTANCE TO SEE IF YOU'RE
EXECUTIVE STOPPED IDENTIFY.
POLICIES THAT ARE. I NEED WE
NEED. ON NEGOTIATION HELP LIST
OUT AGREED UPON OR COURT
MANDATED. IN THE CLASS CASE. AND
DEVELOP EVIDENCE I'M SUBSTANTIAL
COMPLIANCE. ABILITY ALL OF WHICH
WILL LEAD TO PROGRESS. UP TO AND
INCLUDING TERMINATION IN THE
CASE- THE NEXT I OUT IS O. J.
LEE SERVICE. OUT WE ARE
REQUESTING TO INCREASE OUR BASE
BUT SPECIFICALLY LEGAL FOR BY
DEPARTMENT JUSTICE AS REQUIRED
BY GOVERNMENT CODE CECERE RELIED
ON THE DEAL. OFF OF ATTORNEY FOR
LEGAL REPRESENTATION FOR CDC ARE
NOT PLEASE IN STATE AND FEDERAL
CASES. AS LEGAL FEES AND OTHER-
LITIGATION COSTS AND INCREASING
USE YOURS BUDGET HAS NOT KEPT
PACE TO COVER COSTS. AS
REFERENCED IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN WE WERE BILLED
APPROXIMATELY THREE HUNDRED AND
FOUR THOUSAND HOURS AND IN
TWENTY. TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WE WERE UP TO THREE
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS. THE NEW ITEM IS YOU
JUST. ARE WE ARE REQUESTING
FUNDING IN POSITIONS TO
IMPLEMENT A SOLUTION TO INDEX
ELECTRONICALLY STORED
INFORMATION WITH THAT CASE
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM AND ASSOCIATED
REDUCTION TOOLS TO HAVE
ADDRESSED MEDICATION SUPPORT AND
PUBLIC RECORDS ACT REQUEST AND
MANAGE LEGAL IMPURITY WORKLOAD
WE DON'T HAVE A SINGLE
COMPREHENSIVE SYSTEM- OR PROCESS
TO CAPTURE THIS VARIOUS FORMS OF
ELECTRONIC DATA SUCH AS WRITTEN
WRITTEN DATA EMAIL AND VIDEO.
AND THIS IS LED TO INCONSISTENT
RETENTION AND DATA EVIDENCE
MANAGEMENT AND COLLECTIONS
STRATEGIES WHICH PARTS
DEPARTMENT AT RISK. THIS REQUEST
IS A COMPOSITE COMPONENTS- THE
FIRST ONE IS ONE TIME FUNDING TO
ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT- TIME TO
WORK WITH THE STATE'S
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
PROCUREMENT PROCESS IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE E. T. TO
IMPLEMENT A CENTRALIZED A
STORAGE IN CASE MANAGEMENT
PLATFORM AND ASSOCIATED
REDUCTION SOFTWARE. FIRST YOUR
PROPER PRESERVE THINK. ALL TIED
OF DID YOU EVIDENCE. AND ONGOING
FUNDING FOR POSITIONS THAT
SUPPORT OUR DIVERSE A DIVISION
OF ADULT INSTITUTIONS PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT UNITS. THE NEXT ITEM
IS SB SIXTEEN. A REDUCTION
RESOURCES OUR WORK BUSTING
FUNDING IN POSITIONS- AS A
RESULT OF SB SIXTEEN WHICH
EXPANDED THE CRITERIA OF CASES
THE DEPARTMENT IS REQUIRED TO
DISCLOSE. HIS OFFICE HE'S
OFFICER RECORDS- DOES RIGHT HERE
OUTLINED IN PENAL CODE EIGHT
THIRTY TWO POINT SEVEN. THIS
WILL BE ON RESOURCES TO PROVIDE
REDUCTIONS TO REMOVE DATA
PERSONAL DATA OR INFORMATION TO
PRESERVE THE ANONYMITY OF
COMBATANTS AND WITNESSES AND TO
PROTECT CONFIDENTIAL MEDICAL
FINANCIAL OR OTHER INFORMATION
BUT THE SAFETY OF INMATES HE'S
OFFICERS DON'T YOU OFTEN. ARE
OTHERS. THE NEXT ITEM IS PRIVATE
OFFICE OF. R. C. C. H. C. S.
TEAM REQUEST IN POSITIONS
IMPLEMENT PRIVACY INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY SECURITY
ENHANCEMENTS. TO ENSURE SECURITY
OF THE DEPARTMENTS HAVE A DATA.
ECHS IS EXPERIENCED AN INCREASE
IN ATTACKS ON NETWORK
INFRASTRUCTURE DEPLOYED DEVICES
AND EMAIL SYSTEM AND THESE
REQUESTED RESOURCES WELL
INCREASED. BUT APARTMENTS
ABILITY TO A ADDRESS PRIVACY
CYBER SECURITY INFORMATION
SECURITY INCIDENTS- MITIGATE
BREACHES MAINTAIN THAT- AND OR A
CHIEF COMPLIANCE WITH STATE AND
FEDERAL LAWS AND CORRECTIVE
ACTION PLANS AND MITIGATE LEGAL
LIABILITIES ASSOCIATED WITH
PERSONALLY IDENTIFY AND
IDENTIFIABLE OR PROTECTED HEALTH
INFORMATION INCIDENT. OUR NEXT I
IS SOLUTIONS. US CITY C. R. E.
I. S. IS REQUESTING FUNDING
POSITIONS TO ADDRESS INFORMATION
SECURITY AND CYBERSECURITY
INITIATIVES THESE WILL BE USED
TO ENHANCE AND AUGMENT
CAPABILITIES THAT ALIGN WITH DDT
DIRECTIVES THAT WILL BE DEPLOYED
TO ADDRESS VULNERABILITY
MANAGEMENT DATA MANAGEMENT
SECURITY AND PRIVACY AWARENESS
TRAINING PRIVILEGED ACCESS
MANAGEMENT. TECHNOLOGY RECOVER
PLANNING AND BUSINESS IMPACT
ANALYSIS EFFORT. SOFTWARE
RESOURCES ALSO BE USED TO EXPAND
TO SECURITY AND OPERATIONAL
VISIBILITY AND CONTINUOUS
CONTINUOUS MONITORING
CAPABILITIES AS WELL AS ENSURE
CCAR'S NETWORK IS ADDED
ADEQUATELY PROTECTED. AND
FINALLY WE HAVE OF OUR MICROSOFT
OFFICE LICENSE B. C. P. C. C. R.
AND C. C. H. U. S. ARE
REQUESTING FUNDING TO COVER THE
INCREASED COST OF MOVING TO A
NEW STATEWIDE CONTRACT FOR
MICROSOFT END USER LICENSE
AGREEMENT. IN THE SPRING OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE CALIFORNIA
T. T. NEGOTIATED A STATEWIDE
LICENSING STRUCTURE FOR THE NEW
OFFICE THREE SIXTY FIVE WHICH
PROVIDES A LEVERAGED CONTRACT
VEHICLE FOR ALL DEPARTMENTS EASE
OF USE. AS WELL AS PRE
NEGOTIATED RATE TERMS AND
PRICING THESE UPGRADED SECURITY
FEATURES THAT THE REST OF THE
STATE IS TAKING ADVANTAGE OF-
WILL PUT IS IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THE STATEWIDE STRATEGIC I. T.
SECURITY GOALS AND OBJECTIVES.
THAT IS COMPLETE THE ITEM THAT
ARE UNDER THE VARIOUS ISSUES
PROPOSED- WOULD YOU. SUBJECT
MATTER. YEAR TO JUST PAST ANY-
ANY QUESTIONS MEMBERS MAY HAVE
ON THESE ITEMS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISS MACLAINE OF FINANCE
PLEASE IN THE COMMENTS. ANY
FRIENDS OR WITH A PARTNER
FINANCE AGAIN- NO SPECIFIC
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME I'M SURE
BUT- MY CHINESE COLLEAGUES AND I
ARE HAPPY TO HELP ANSWER ANY
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS ON RIPPLES.
THANK YOU L. A- PLEASE. I WOULD
JUST NOTE THAT THERE ARE TWO
PROPOSALS WITHIN THIS ISSUE- AND
THOSE ARE REDUCTION WORKLOAD SB
SIXTEEN AND EDISCOVERY PLATFORM
REDUCTION AND DELIVERY THAT. OF
COURSE INCLUDES. RESOURCES FOR
REDACTION AS THE NAME SUGGESTS
AND- WE ARE STILL REVIEWING
INFORMATION THAT WE'VE RECEIVED
RECENTLY FROM THE DEPARTMENT ON
DIDN'T NEED FOR THESE RESOURCES
. THANK YOU OKAY COLLEAGUES ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. TO GO I
JUST HAVE A COUPLE HERE- THE
ADMINISTRATION INDICATED THAT-
THIS FUNDING WOULD HELP CDC ARE
MOVING. TERMINATION AND SOME OF
IT SAW A LONG RUNNING CLASS
ACTION LAWSUITS- I GUESS MY
QUESTION IS WHAT HOW BIG OF A
FACTOR ARE THE LEGAL WORKLOAD
ISSUES COMPARED TO THE- ONGOING
ISSUES WITH THE TREATMENT OF
INCARCERATED. PEOPLE. THE
MANAGER OF A SMALL RENTERIA OUR
CHIEF DEPUTY GENERAL COUNSEL ARE
FOR CAESAR'S OFFICE OF LEGAL
AFFAIRS- AND SO WE ARE CLASS
ACTION WORK ON WHEN YOU.
ACTUALLY ASKED FOR CLARIFICATION
ON YOUR QUESTION REGARDING THE
TREATMENT OF- THE INCARCERATED
POPULATION. WELL LAWSUITS THAT
HAVE TO DO WITH OUT NOT
INCARCERATED I HAVE BEEN TREATED
WHATEVER THE DIFFERENT ISSUES OR
CIRCUMSTANCES. SURE AND SO I'M
NOT VERY GOOD RECENTLY WE'VE HAD
A LITIGATION DIRECTLY WITHIN THE
ARMSTRONG CASE- THAT HAS LED TO-
SOME OF THE OTHER PROPOSALS HERE
AND- URBAN MIDDLE EFFORTS AT THE
DEPARTMENT HAS MADE ARE
PARTICULARLY WITH REGARD TO THE
BODY ONE CAMERAS- AND THE FIXED
CAMERAS I HAVE BEEN- DEPLOYED IN
THE VARIOUS INSTITUTIONS- AND
ONE OF THE G. OUR GOALS ARE IN
THIS PROPOSED. IS TO- ADD STAFF
TO ENABLE OUR THE OFFICE OF
LEGAL AFFAIRS STOCK MORE
PROACTIVELY- AND TRY TO IDENTIFY
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT END UP
BEING RAISED BY PLAINTIFFS
COUNSEL ON THAT END UP- BEING
LITIGATED IN MANY OF THESE CLASS
ACTIONS EXPANDING ACROSS ACTIONS
OR THE RESULT OF. FILING NEW
ONES. CURRENT THE ARE WITH THE
CURRENT WORKLOAD I THAT PROCESS
TEAM BUILT ON THE SO. AND THE
ADMINISTRATORS OF SIDE- ARE JUST
ABLE TO. KEEP WITH THE KERR WORK
ARE. HOWEVER WE DON'T HAVE THE
CURRENTLY THERE ARE. I'M SORRY
THAT STAFF. TO UNTIL IT IS
PROPERLY MEASURES WOULD WHAT
ASIDE THOSE PROBLEMS IN ADVANCE
. TO NEGOTIATE OUT WITH CAN AT-
AND TO MAKE THOSE BEFORE WE
ACTUALLY END UP THE TO- ONE OF
THE AND GETTING OF IS THAT THE
CLASS ACTION. SPEND IN ORDER
AMOUNT OF. OUR MONTHLY ARE
RESPONDING TO THE PRODUCTION.
AND ALL OF THE SIX- CASES ABOUT
THE BIG FOR IF YOU WORLD I AND
JUST HAVE ENOUGH TIME TO.
DELIVER ON THE DOCUMENT AND
DON'T HAVE THE TIME OR THE RE.
TO REALLY I DON'T ANALYZE THOSE
DOCUMENTS TO REALLY GO THROUGH
THEM TO TREND DOWN OUR TO DO
SOME DATA MINING ON THOSE
IDENTIFY THOSE TRENDS ON THOSE
POSSIBLE PROBLEMS THE DEPARTMENT
MIGHT BE FACING. ARE THAT MAY
END UP IN THESE CLASS. ACTIONS
OR RESULT IN NEW ONES. THANK YOU
I- APPRECIATE- WHAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT MORE NOW
PROACTIVELY SO ALONG THOSE LINES
WOULDN'T- ADDITION JUST AS AN
EXAMPLE ADDITIONAL OVERSIGHT BY
THE OFFICE OF THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL. HELP WITH REGARDS TO
SHOWING CTC ARTS PROGRESS AND
THEN MOVE TOWARDS TERMINATION OF
SOME OF THOSE LAWSUITS. THE ROLE
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT AND SO AS
IN HOUSE COUNSEL ARE ONE OF THE
RULES THAT WE PLAY IS NOT JUST
ONLY IN THE IDENTIFICATION- ARE
POTENTIAL PROBLEMS BUT HOW DO
YOU ACTUALLY ADDRESS THOSE ON
TOOK INTO CONSIDERATION. THE
CURRENT STATUS OF THE LONG
HISTORY OF THOSE CASES ON THE
ORDERS THAT WERE CURRENTLY
UNDER- ASWELL AS THE
OPERATIONAL NEEDS OF THE
DEPARTMENT AND THE DEPARTMENT'S
OWN GOALS AND SO TO COMBINE ALL
OF THOSE THINGS ARE TO WORK WITH
EXECUTIVE STAFF ON TRYING TO
IDENTIFY THOSE THINGS IT'S ALSO
ON THE IN HOUSE COUNSEL
FUNCTION- SOMETIMES ARE
INVOLVING ALSO ARE THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE. THAT
NEGOTIATES WITH OPPOSING COUNSEL
TO IDENTIFY SOLUTIONS AND SO-
DESPITE B. R. MS RENTERIA. NOPE
HELLO I'M JENNIFER NEAL
ASSISTANT SECRETARY OF LEGAL
AFFAIRS AND SHE ALSO I WILL TAKE
OVER I KNOW I'M SACRAMENTO IT'S
QUITE WINDY TODAY AND IT'S
KNOCKING SOME FOLKS- INTERNET
OUT SO I THINK THAT MAYBE WHAT'S
HAPPENING HERE SO I'M HAPPY TO
TAKE OVER FOR MISS RENTERIA SO I
DO THINK WHAT SHE WAS GOING TO
SAY IS THAT THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL'S OFFICE. A DIFFERENT
STRAND ROLE WHAT WE DO HERE IN
OVERSIGHT OF CERTAIN CATEGORIES
OF CASES BUT AT THE OFFICE OF
LEGAL AFFAIRS HAS A MUCH
BROADER- ROLE IN THE DAY TO DAY
OPERATIONS OF THE LEGAL
FUNCTIONS OF. THE DEPARTMENT.
OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
JUMPING IN THERE. ALL RIGHT- I
DON'T HAVE ANYMORE- QUESTIONS-
I'M SORRY JUST ONE LAST ONE ON
THE- THE CONTRACT WITH THE-
MICROSOFT WORD MICROSOFT SYSTEM.
I AND I UNDERSTAND THAT IT'S
MORE EXPENSIVE THAN THE SYSTEMS
AT C. D. C. R. AND C. C. H. C.
S. R. WERE USING BEFORE COULD
YOU IS THERE A QUICK ANSWER TO
THAT. WHY IT'S MORE EXPENSIVE.
THIS IS MADELEINE MCLEAN I CAN
CERTAINLY START AND I CAN TURN
OVER THE SPECIFICS ON THE CAR
LICENSE FEE BUT I WAS SO IT'S
BECAUSE IT'S AN ENHANCED PRODUCT
- WE WERE PREVIOUS RUNNING AND
THE STATE WAS RUNNING WHAT IT
CALLED A G. AND SO NEW I'M SURE
IS WHAT WE CHIEF. AND IT
PROVIDES A HIGHER LEVEL OF
SECURITY AND OVERSIGHT- THAT ALL
DEPARTMENTS ARE NOW USING AND SO
- THAT IS BASED ON A PER USER
FEE AND SO JUST FRAZIER NATURE
OF DC R. NG A LARGER ENTITY IT
JUST IT COST US A LITTLE BIT
MORE MONEY JUST IN TERMS OF
OBSCURE NUMBER OF USERS. OKAY
THAT'S FINE. OKAY I THAT'S IT-
ON THIS ISSUE MACLAINE YOU
EVERYONE WE WANT TO MOVE ON NOW
TO. ISSUE ELEVEN DOT OUR LAST
ONE. OKAY ISSUE ELEVEN A STAFF
FOR VICTIM RESTITUTION
COLLECTION SERVICES- CDCR. A
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR GIVE ME
WENT UP ONCE ONE SECOND HERE WE
GO CAN YOU HEAR AND SEE ME NOW
YES THIS CALL. THANK YOU AYE AYE
AYE AGAIN ALL- BAKER- MAKES
MEALS COMMENTS AM IN A VERY VERY
WINDY AREA THIS MORNING OUT YOLO
COUNTY SO BEAR WITH ME AND I DO
HAVE MY ASSISTANT CHIEF MIKE
YOUNG ON THE LINE AND HE CAN
HELP AS WELL. GOOD MORNING MADAM
pYOU HAVING ME I'M KATIE JAMES
I'M THE CHIEF OF THE OFFICE OF
VICTIMS SURVIVOR RIGHTS AND
SERVICES THISMORNING- THE SRS
IS REQUESTING FUNDING FOR FIVE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN RESTITUTION ADMIN FEE
FUNDING AND SIX POSITIONS WHICH
IS ONE STAFF SERVICES MANAGER TO
OFFICE TECHNICIANS AND THREE
ASSOCIATE GOVERNMENTAL PROGRAM
ANALYST AT GPAS. IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE AND
ONGOING SUPPORT INCREASED OF
VICTIMS RESTITUTION SERVICES FOR
ONGOING SUPPORT OF VICTOR
RESTITUTION INCREASE SERVICES.
THESE RESOURCES RESOURCES WILL
BE TO SUPPORT IMMEDIATE MEANS AN
ADDITIONAL FULL TIME POSITIONS
DEDICATED TO A DIRECT. COURSE
RATED PER RESTITUTION SERVICES
ENSURING PROPER TIME FRAMES ARE
PROCESS FOR VICTIMS INCARCERATED
PERSONS REQUEST SHOULD BE IN
ENSURING PROPER TIME FRAMES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH OUR CURRENT
STATUTES AND LAWS ALSO ENSURING
ACCURATE AND CONSISTENT
CONSISTENT DATA. WITH REQUEST TO
A FRANCHISE TAX BOARD OF TV-
COURT ORDERED DEBT PROGRAMMING
UNIT THAT WE WORK WITH THIS ALSO
INCREASES- VIA SERVICES
OPERATIONAL CONSISTENCY- AND
EFFECTIVENESS TO BETTER SERVE
THE CRIME VICTIMS OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. ENSURING
RESTITUTION COLLECTION AND
DISTRIBUTION AS TIMELY AND THE
RESTITUTION CLEAN UP OF OVER
FIFTY FOUR THOUSAND CASES JUNE
SHOW AB ONE SEVEN SEVEN RECENTLY
PASSED IN CHAPTER TWO FIFTY
SEVEN AND THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
STATUTE. AND REMOVED THE TEN
ADMINISTRATION FEE FOR EACH CASE
THAT'S CAUSING SOME CLEAN UP
CASES FOR OFFICE THIS WILL ALSO
PROVIDE RESOURCES FOR ONGOING
RESEARCH FOR APPROXIMATELY
EIGHTY EIGHT THOUSAND UNKNOWN
VICTIM CASES AND WILL ENSURE
THAT THOSE CASES ARE CLEANED UP.
DISPERSED TO THE VICTIMS AS
QUICKLY AND AS TIMELY AS
POSSIBLE I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
TODAY THANK YOU BYE. I WILL
GLADLY TAKE ANY QUESTIONS ARE
COMMENTS. THANK YOU IS JAMES
FINANCED WITH. EVEN DEPARTMENT
FINANCE I EVERY DAY THAT K<c.cyan></c>
SAID BUT I ALSO TO ADD THAT ON
THE SOCCER IS ALMOST THE OF REST
OF RESTED COLLECT. ARMS TWENTY
TEN BUT IT'S IS NOT INCREASE-
THESE RESOURCES WILL ALLOW.
VICTIM RESTITUTION TO PROVIDE
NECESSARY IN TIME RESTED SIR
KEEPING UP WITH THE INCREASED
WORKLOAD. THANK YOU MOVEMENT OF
THE L. A. O. WE DON'T RAISE ANY
CONCERNS ON THIS PROPOSAL BUT
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. OKAY GREAT- I DON'T
EITHER SO WE COULD. MOVE ON TO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO EVERYONE
FOR PARTICIPATING WITH US TODAY-
WE WILL MOVE ON NOW TO ANYONE
WANTING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT. REGARDING ANY OF THE
ISSUES DISCUSSED TODAY AS A
REMINDER TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. 844-291-6364 AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS THREE FIVE THREE
ONE TWO EIGHT THREE. DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE LENGTH
OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS THE CHAIR MAY
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY DAM GOING TO ASK THAT
EACH MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
PROVIDING COMMON KEEP THEIR
REMARKS TO WITHIN ONE MINUTE.
ONE MINUTE WILL BE TIMING NOW
LET'S BEGIN WITH ANY WITNESSES
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM. SEEING
NONE. OF MODERATE VIEW WOULD-
PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT ON
TODAY'S CALL YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN GENERAL AT THIS TIME
HERE'S MY NUMBER IS CALLED
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION. NINE EIGHTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD I'M
SORRY MISS POTTERY BEFORE YOU
MOVE ON COULD YOU TELL ME THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE. WAITING
TO TESTIFY. CURRENTLY WE DO HAVE
TWENTY FOUR IN THE QUEUE. OKAY.
OKAY PLEASE OPEN THE LINES AND
CALL THE MEMBERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND LINE EIGHTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING SHARON MEMBERS
DANIEL SANCHEZ ON THE ALBUM THE
CHIEF PROBATION OFFICERS OF
CALIFORNIA SPEAKING TO ITEM ONE
TODAY WE APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO INVEST A
HUNDRED MILLION TO UPDATE COUNTY
JUVENILE FACILITIES FOLLOWING
THE STATE'S REALIGNMENT OF THE
ENTIRE JUVENILE JUSTICE CONTINUE
ON THE COUNTY'S. OR YOU CAN. I
WOULD HIGHLY FOR THIS COMMITTEE
THE TIMING AND THE NEED WE HAVE
USE CURRENTLY IN OUR FACILITIES
THAT NEED THE BENEFIT OF THE
STATE SUPPORT IN ASSISTING
COUNTIES IN ADDRESSING THE GAPS
IDENTIFIED IN SB TWENTY THREE
PLANS. RELATED TO OUR FACILITIES
I'VE DISCUSSED TODAY I DO WANT
TO UNDERSCORE THAT INVESTING IN
FACILITY UPGRADES IS NOT A
MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE OPTION TO
CONTINUING THE IMPORTANT AND
NEEDED WORK TO MAINTAIN THE
FOCUS ON PREVENTION AND
DIVERSION. BUT WHAT THIS
PROPOSAL DOES RECOGNIZES THAT
CHINESE ARE NOW RESPONSIBLE FOR
ALL STATEWIDE SECURE SETTINGS
FOR YOU. AND IN CASES WHERE THE
COURT DETERMINES A SECURE
FACILITY IF NECESSARY EXISTING
FACILITIES AND SPACES SHOULD BE
MODERNIZE TO BEST MEET THE
REHABILITATED AND SAFETY NEEDS
OF YOU PROBABLY RECEIVE
PROGRAMMING AND SERVICES. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO LEARNING MORE
ABOUT THE SPECIFICS OF THE
PROPOSAL AND WORKING WITH THIS
COMMITTEE THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE ADMINISTRATION- TO ASSIST
COUNTY PROBATION DEPARTMENT.
THAT'S ONLY IF ACTUATING BJJ
REALIGNMENT AT THE NEEDS OF YOU
AND OUR SHARED GOALS. THANK YOU
. FOR THANK YOU VERY. NEXT BLIND
THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS A
PLEASE AHEAD. MORNING CHAIRMEN
OF HIS DANNECKER ARE NOT I
ACTUALLY CALLING IN MY PERSONAL
. I HAVE A LOVED IN CART IN
CAMPS- ABOUT ISSUE NUMBER FOUR
AND WHEN I THINK ABOUT IT CHAIR
AND STAFFERS INCLUDING THE
AGENDA AND THE WORK OF BOTH.
COMMITTEE AND GDPR CAN CONTINUE
TRYING TO ADDRESS THE ISSUES
WITH THAT THE ESTABLISH- SHE
STATED SHE ARE TO. APPOINTMENT
TIMES BUT WANTED TO THAT. YES
THEY THAT STILL CONTINUE TO BE
REALLY INTO TO LARGE. PORTIONS
THE POPULATION TRYING TO. USE
THE SCHEDULE APPOINTMENTS FOR
BLOOD DRAW AND WE LOOK TO WORK
ON THANK YOU I'M ACTUALLY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
BLIND EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THANK YOU
ALL. BUT CHAIRED DORADO- MY IS
THERE I'M A PROGRAM COORDINATOR
WITH KNOWLEDGE BECAUSE THAT WAS
A RELIEF FROM CITY SHE ARTS
TWENTY TWENTY AFTER TWENTY YEARS. PALESTINIAN PRIME DO THE
MONOCLE FATE THEY PROGRAM THAT
OFFERS THE LIFE SKILLS IN HIS
RELATE TO. BEVEL CAL INDOOR THE
HEARTS BECAUSE- IN. OUR OUR
ENGINE IN THE BUT THIS YEAR. OR
PROGRAMMING WITH CDCR WORK
BASED- ALL. BY OUR YOU CAN JUST
WITH TRANCE THE IMPRISONED. BY
THE BATHROOM TO SHUFFLE. MIGHT
TRY. OF THE OLD. IT WILL ALLOW
PROGRAMS LIKE BANKS FOR THE
PROJECT PROVIDES REENTRY
pPOSITIONS PART RETURNING. KAMALA
THE NECESSARY OR EXPERIENCE TO
QUALIFY FOR EMPLOYMENT WITH
BUSINESS PAYING LIVING WAGES.
AND YOU NEED ROADSIDE BOMBS THE
PROJECT AUTHOR WITH THE PRO CAN
ALL AND CONTINUATION OF CARE I
LIKE TO THINK YOU FOR YOUR.
THANK YOU VERY. NEXT NINE THIRTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING BRIAN
GOLDSTINE WITH THE CENTER ON
JUVENILE AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE
I'D LIKE TO SPEAK ON ISSUE ONE
WE STRONGLY URGE THE
ADMINISTRATION AND LEGISLATURE
TWIN BASKET CONDITIONS
CALIFORNIANS DIVISION OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE. WE ALSO MUST
BRING YOU HOME PRIOR TO CLOSURE
. RIGHT NOW DJJ IS FACING AN
UNPRECEDENTED COVERT NINETEEN
OUTBREAK. YOU ARE IN GRAVE
DANGER DJJ SUBJECTS SEEM TO
APPALLING CONDITIONS TWO OUT OF
EVERY THREE YOU HAVE GOTTEN SICK
IN JUST THE LAST FEW MONTHS.
YOUR ISOLATED AND UNABLE TO
ACCESS. OR PROGRAMMING. THERE'S
AN EXTREME SHORTAGE AND WE'RE
HERE REPORTS OF EXTENDED
LOCKDOWN YOU KNOW BEING. AND
STAFF ON USED FIND WE URGE THEM
ACTION TO PROTECT YOU THANK YOU
. THANK YOU MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS. NEXT. NINE FORTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS CAPITAL I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF CRAIGHEAD ACT A
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION AND
A MEMBER OF THAT TRANSFORMATIVE
IN PERSON WORKSHOP I'M NOT
MISTAKEN OP THE PROGRAM
PROGRAMMING BAY AND PACK
INCREASE THANK THE CRAFTABLE
INTERNET ACCESS ACROSS THE
PROGRAMMING SPACES AND PRESS
THEM. TO SHOW THE PROGRAMS
ACTUALLY TO MAKE CHANGE AND THE
OPEN THEY SHOULD PROVIDE THEM
CAN BE SUSTAINABLE. THAT
MOUNTAIN OF EVIDENCE OF A DECADE
BUT OP PROGRAM HAVE A DEEP
IMPACT ON BOTH WHAT DO YOU THINK
INCRETIN BYLANDT AND INFRACTIONS
AND PRETEND THE PRESIDENT ARE
CUTTING EDGE- BUT SHALL BE RE
ENTRY PROGRAM TO CREATE THE
BACK. ON THE TO THE RADICAL
TRANSFORMATION AND MANTRI BUT WE
LIKE OTHER NEED TO FINANCIAL
TECHNICAL COULD DO IT PLEASE
CONFIRM TO SUPPORT THESE-
PROGRAM THAT THE DCI HAD BECOME
FAMOUS FOR BUT A NOT AND ENOUGH
IN MY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
REALLY APPRECIATE EVERYONE
STICKING TO THE ONE MINUTE THANK
YOU NEXT. PINE FORTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS A PLEASE GO AHEAD. HEY
MY NAME IS KERRY OUR THOUGHTS
MAYBE MY LOVED ONE IS
INCARCERATED AT HIGH DESERT
STATE PRISON. SHE CHAIR AND
COMMUTING ADDRESSING PORTENT
ISSUE IS PATIENT AND FAMILY
CONNECTION PROBLEMS WIDE
CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE TO KEEP IN
TOUCH PARTICULARLY DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND- WITH THE STAGGER
APPOINTMENT. BADLY STATEWIDE ARE
STILL CONTINUE TO HAVE ISSUES
WITH OF THE CASUAL APPLICATION
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
ALONGSIDE YOU CDC. AND ALL THE
FAMILY STATEWIDE BIG OF THE YEAR
THE ISSUES WITH THE VSA TO
ENSURE THAT WE CAN REQUIRED.
THANK YOU FOR MUCH THANK YOU
PRECIADO. YOU NEXT. PINE FORTY
FOUR YEAR LINE IS A PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE FORTY FOUR YOU MAY
BE ON MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I AM THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MY NAME IS LAYLA IS
THE FROM THE DIRECTOR OF
OPERATIONS FOR PILLARS OF THE
COMMUNITY LOCATED IN SAN DIEGO
CALIFORNIA I'M CALLING REGARDING
LINE BY THE COURT YES THEY DID
BUT- BECAUSE OF THE- BUT TOWARD
INCOME WORKING WITH FAMILIES
LEVEL UP CURRENTLY INVOLVED IN
CRIMINAL TO. BUT WHERE DOES THE
WITH THEM COME UP ONE INCREASE
TO MAKE CONTRA CONNECTION HE
GAVE THEM A TO HELP IF YOU IF
YOU HOLISTIC. DISTRICT THEM AND
PREPARE FOR TRANSIT ALL. AS THE
OLD ECONOMICAL JOB COMPUTER
SHEER MORE. OF THE PURCHASE BY.
ABOUT LIMITED. HI THERE STATE
COULD VISITS A WITH INTO TECH.
AFTER THAT THAT THE BE A GOOD.
ALBUM EIGHT. OTHER BUSINESS HAVE
TO CHECK. WITH A COLLEAGUE. THE
MEETING BUY EXTRA ABOUT THE
FAMILY AND THE LOVED ONE. KERR.
NINE FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS ELI WERE CHAPTER AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF UNTAPPED
AND IMPRISONED PROGRAM OFFERED
BY KALW PUBLIC MEDIA AND GOT
PROVIDE IN PRISON MEDIA AND
RADIO CLASS AS AND IS A MEMBER
OF THE TRANSFORMATIVE IN PRISON
WORK GROUP. I'M CALLING TO URGE
THE STATE TO INVEST IN PROGRAMS
LIKE OURS WHICH HELP TO SUPPORT
INCARCERATED PEOPLE PREPARING
FOR RELEASE AND RE ENTRY AND
WHICH HELPS TO REDUCE THE PRISON
POPULATION WHILE ENSURING
COMMUNITY SAFETY AND WELL BEING
THANK YOU VERY. MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU. NOW NINE SIX
SIX LINE OF OPEN GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS ANDREW WHEN THEY
EXPECT DIRECTOR THE INSIDE
GARDEN PARK I CAN EAT PAY OR-
PROVIDING IMPRISONED PROGRAMMING
AND A MEMBER OF THE TRANSFORMER
IMPRISON WORKGROUP. REGARDING
ISSUE SIX THE PURPOSE MY CALL
HISTORY FIRST THE STATE JIM
PROGRAMS LIKE. WHICH OF
CURRENTLY PEOPLE AND IN THE
REGION. I'M CALLING URGE TO
PROGRAMS LIKE OURS PROGRAM FOR
BY IMPRISON PROGRAM GREENTREE
SERVICES DOWN CONTRIBUTE JEFF
CALLED CHANGE CARE AND PATHWAYS
SIX. ARE CURRENTLY IN PRE WE ARE
STRAIGHT PEOPLE. ARE WORKS OR
HUMANA IN THE GIUDICE AND WELL
BEING THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT. ONE SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS A
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
KENNETH AND I'M CALL ON BE OF
THE CAPITAL FOUNDER WHICH IS THE
COMMUTER BASED OR- THAT PROVIDE
IN PROBE. AND IS A OF THE
TRANSFER AND WORK CREW I'M ALSO
FORMALLY PERSON AS OUR THIRTY
EIGHT YEAR NOW CAL PARK
CORRECTION AND REBUILD. AND I
BENEFITTED FOR THE K. OF PRO-
BECOME DAY AND MANY OTHER PRO
ARE YOUR TALK ABOUT I'M IN
REGARD TO ISSUE NO SIX AND-
URGING THIS TO AND- IN PROGRAM
LIKE THE TAP FOUND. A OTHER MY
OF THE OF PRISON WORKGROUP WHICH
HELPS INCARCERATED PEOPLE
PREPARE FOR REALLY RAN. AND I'LL
REDUCE THE BOB OR ENSURING STAKE
AND WELL. AND HELP HEAL FELLOW
CAL. THANK YOU THANK YOU MUCH.
NEXT. NINE FIFTY. YOUR LINE IS A
PLEASE AHEAD. VERY WELL GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS KAREN
MCDANIEL I AM THE FOUNDER AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE PLATES
ARE GREAT AND I WILL BE MAKING
TWO COMMENTS TODAY ON NUMBER SIX
AND NUMBER FOUR WITHIN. MY
ALLOTTED ONE MINUTE PERIOD OF
TIME. REGARDING NUMBER SIX. OUR
ORGANIZATION WORKS- AS A- AT
PROGRAM PROVIDER IN MORE THAN
SEVENTEEN CALIFORNIA PRISON SH
WE ARE A LOYAL AND FAITHFUL
MEMBER OF THE OF THE
TRANSFORMATIVE IMPRISONED WORK
GROUP THAT HAD BEEN WELL
REPRESENTED HERE TODAY WE ARE
ASKING FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING
AND CONTINUED SUPPORT FOR
PROGRAMS THAT WE KNOW MAKE NOT
ONLY FISCAL SENSE BUT MORAL
STANDS- SO THAT IS THE FIRST
COMMENT THE SECOND COMMENT
REGARDING ISSUE NUMBER FOUR. AND
THAT IS THE IMPACT ON BE LACK OF
ACCESS TO THE VIDEO CALLS FOR
GAMBLING ALTHOUGH WE DO
APPRECIATE THE STAGGERED-
APPOINTMENT- RELEASED IT IS NOT
A LEADER AND BACK- D. FOR AT.
CALLS SHOULD BE A- I SIMPLY ONE
TO POINT OUT THE IMPACT ON SHE
WE HEARD FROM DAHLE HERE WHO
DESCRIBE THE IMPACT ON THEM SHE
AND THEY'RE A TO. BACK TO E. AND
EVERY WEEK WHEN THEY'RE NOT ABLE
TO GET CALL WITH THEIR LOVE ONES
THANK YOU WALDRON IS ARE NOT
THANK YOU THAT WOULD GIVE MUCH
M. YOU'RE ALMOST AT TWO SO. WE
NEED TO ON THANK YOU FOR MUCH
FOR IN PRE SHAPED YOUR MAY UP
MONTEREY COULD YOU TO ME HOW
MANY PARTICIPANTS. ARE LEFT. WE
ARE AGAIN AT TWENTY FIVE PER TO
IN THE QUEUE. OKAY WE'RE GONNA
TO WE HAVE THE END BY TWO
O'CLOCK- WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
CUT DOWN THE TIME OF THEIR
REMAINING- PARTICIPANTS- TO.
THIRTY SECONDS SO PLEASE KEEP
THAT IN MIND SO THAT WE COULD
AND BY TWELVE THANK YOU NEXT.
NINE SEVENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
LEONARD WILL BE ON THE PHONE
WITH A LABOR DISPUTE OVER TWENTY
THREE YEARS AND NOW THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE INSIDE
PRISON PROJECT IT BASED
ORGANIZER PROVIDING INCREASING
PROGRAMMING. IT PRESENTS AND A
FOUNDING MEMBER THE TRANSFORM
INCLUSIVE WELCOME. TO H. SIX
CALLING TO- URGE THE STATE TO
INVEST IN TRANSFER PROGRAMS BUT
ARE THEY READY COMMITTEE BUDGET
OFFICE OF PARTIAL PEOPLE POLICE
ENTERED. INTO REDUCE THE BUT
UNINSURED IN THE STATE AND WELL
BEING THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
CALLING NAY PLEASE. MINDSET SIX
YOUR IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO NAME IS ON THE REST OF THE
YEAR. I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE GREAT AND- BAKER BASED. PRO
PROVIDING IMPRISONED PROGRAM.
AND MA'AM OF TRANSFER AND- WHAT
WILL. I'M CALLING REGARDING
ISSUE SIX TO EIGHT THE STATE
ENACT PROGRAM LIKE OUR- WHICH
HELPS INCOME PEOPLE COULD FOR
THE- ANDRIAN. ACTUALLY NO THE
PRICE POPULATION WHILE IN
COMMUNICATE ANALOG. THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR IN FOR A THE WORK
YOU EVERY DAY NEXT. MAINZER YOUR
LINE IS PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS THE ONE HUNDRED WITH
TERM APPOINTMENT WITH CHILDREN
OF THE CORN FOR UNITY I QUALITY
BECAUSE GET EXPENSE CALL. AND
COMPLAINED FAMILY MEMBER I YOU
TO THE APPOINTMENT ARE NOT TO.
AN APPOINTMENT- THE FIFTH IT NOT
WORKING AT PATIENTS DURING
ENOUGH LOTS PEOPLE TO MAKE VISIT
A POINT- BE THEY BIRD. ALLOWED
GOLDEN AT THE IN THE MORNING AND
BY THE THIRTY- ALL THE DOCTORS
SO I'LL OR REQUEST THAT YOU ARE
PROVIDE- ENOUGH NOT FOR IN MY TO
KEEP CLEAN. THANK YOU MUCH I
MUNDELEIN DON'T FOR- BEING- BEEN
IS FAMILY COME AGAIN. AND IT TO
THE BUDGET AND WE ARE ON- NINETY
THE IMPORTANCE OF THE BILL THAT
PROPOSED FOR THE YEAR- CHILDREN
NEED TO BE TO THE FAMILY MEMBERS
THE FACTORY IS NOT WORKING AND.
NINE THIRTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING JOSH DUGGAR REPRESENTING
URBAN COUNTIES OF HEALTH AND ON
BEHALF OF MY COLLEAGUES WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE IS THE OF
COUNTY AND LITTLE COUNTY
REPRESENT OF CALIFORNIA PERCENT
PURSUANT TO DJJ RE LEGISLATION
BUDGET COURT WILL DETERMINE
WHETHER YOU REQUIRES PLACEMENT
IN A YOUR TREATMENT TO. AND
COUNTY PROBATION APARTMENTS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR DELIVERING A
TREATMENT PLAN TO CARRY OUT THE
COURT'S DIRECTION WE SUPPORT A
ONE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT IN COUNTY FACILITY TO
HELP CARRY OUT THIS NEW COUNTY
RISK. WE ARE EAGER TO WORK WITH
THE LARGEST IN ADMINISTRATION TO
FINALIZE THE PROPOSAL THAT
DISTRIBUTE FUNDS QUICKLY AND
PROVIDES ENOUGH. TO SUPPORT THE
REDESIGN OF LOCAL SETTING BETTER
MARCHING TO TROHMAN CARE
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMMING THANK
YOU AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO HAVE
CONVERSATION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT. NINE SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE
OPEN GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
TINA RANCH I AM CALLING ON
BEHALF OF MARIN SHAKESPEARE
COMPANY SHAKESPEARE CONCEPTUAL
DOCTORS PROGRAM FOR TWENTY YEARS
WE'VE BEEN PROVIDING AND
PROGRAMMING ALL OVER THE
CALIFORNIA PROGRAM DURING THIS
TIME WE'VE HEARD COUNTLESS. FROM
PEOPLE ON THESE PROGRAMS HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO ENVISIONED FUTURES
FOR THEMSELVES TO ENHANCE WORK
AND LIGHT RAIL. NUMBER OF THE
AND PUT AWAY. I AM REGARDING
NUMBER- EIGHT AND PROGRAM BUT
OURS WHICH WILL HELP CARD TO THE
PEOPLE PREPARING. REENTRY I'M TO
REDUCE THE BURDEN POPULATION
WILL ENSURE UNITY THANK THE WELL
BEYOND THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. FIND THREE LINE IS
OPEN GO AHEAD. IT MY NAME IS
KARLEY MELLON AGAIN HAS BEEN THE
PRESIDENT. AT THEM NUMBER FOUR.
THE TASTE. HELLO LOOKS LIKE WE
GOT CUT OFF. I'M SORRY- COULD WE
MOVE ONE MODERATED TO THE NEXT
ONE PLEASE. NINE SEVENTY THREE
DID COME BACK ON PLEASE GO AHEAD
. WE HEARD WE HEARD THE ISSUE
SAID IF I COULD. IF WE COULD
MOVE ON MODERATOR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LINE SIXTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU- MY NAME IS MEGAN
TOWARD AND- TONY AND THE NUMBER
OF. THE AREA KERN AND- PHONE FOR
COMMUNITY MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
RESPONSE. AND I WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE HEARING
HELD LAST YEAR ON THE ISSUE OF
CRESSMAN CLOSURE BUT THAT'S WHY
WE SO DISAPPOINTED NOT TO SEE
MORE PRISON CLOSURES NAMES GOING
FORWARD I FIRMLY. BELIEVE SB
DIVESTING SOME SEVEN CURSORY AND
IN OUR COMMUNITY. BY THE MENTAL
I'M HERE I HE- GALAK. SERVICES
AND COMMUNITY TO MENTAL. YOU CAN
INVEST IN. SHE'S ONLY MAKING
THIS MORE BETTER AND PEOPLE
COMING MORE TRAUMA NOT LAST I
WOULD LIKE TO NINETY REQUIRE YOU
FOR- THANK YOU FOR CALLING AND
FREE SKATE AND THANK YOU. WE
HEARD YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH NECK
PLEASE. NINE SIXTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING SUPERMALL POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR THE PACIFIC
JUVENILE DEFENDER CENTER
SPEAKING ON ISSUE ONE WE SUPPORT
THE L. A. O. IN RECOMMENDING
THAT THE JUVENILE FACILITY
PROPOSAL NOT BE APPROVED IN ITS
PRESENT FORM ALLOWING COUNTIES
TO FOR TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS MORE. INTO JUVENILE
HALLS IT'S LIKE PUTTING LIPSTICK
ON A PIG USE OF THOSE STANCES
UNDERSTANDABLE IN THE SHORT RUN
BUT THERE IS NOTHING IN THIS
PROPOSAL TO PREVENT THAT FROM
BECOMING A PERMANENT SOLUTION.
ANYMORE MONEY IS TO BE DEDICATED
TO THE REALIGNMENT OF YOUNG
PEOPLE OF THE COUNTY IT SHOULD
BE SUBJECT TO STRICT GUIDELINES
REQUIRING IT TO BE USED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH UNITY BASED
PROGRAM AND THEN GET YOU DOWN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE.
MIND YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE
GO AHEAD IS THAT CORRECT HI THIS
IS SERRA REGNI ON BEHALF OF
INITIATE JUSTICE WITH MORE THAN
FORTY FIVE THOUSAND MEMBERS
CURRENTLY INCARCERATED IN
CALIFORNIA. WE'RE CALLING TO
EXPRESS CONCERN REGARDING ITEM.
ADDITIONAL DOCTOR VICTIMIZED
EDUCATION COLLECTION. ALL OF THE
PROPOSAL TRAINED I PROVIDE CRIME
AT PROVIDING FOR CRIME DRIVERS
INCREASED COLLECTIONS AND
DISTRIBUTION ACCURATE IT DOES
NOT ACCURATELY REPRESENT THE
DUTY TO PROVIDE PROVIDE
PERFORMED BY THE CDC ARE THE
OFFICE OF VICTIMS AND SURVIVORS
RIGHT. IT DOESN'T ACTUALLY
REQUIRE AGAIN GENERAL BONNIE AND
- IT DOESN'T PRESCRIBERS AND IN
THE INTEREST OF TIME I'LL ALSO
OCCUR ECHO OTHERS PETER FOR THE
LACK OF ACCESS IN REGARDS TO
ITEM NUMBER FOUR THANK YOU MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE
. NINE SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MY NAME IS JONATHAN BYRD I
REPRESENT LABOR ASKED ME LOCAL
SIX EIGHTY FIVE IN LOSS ANGELES
COUNTY PROBATION OFFICER UNION-
WE ARE DRESSING ITEM NUMBER ONE
BECAUSE OF THE TIME LIMITATIONS
WE WILL PROVIDE TO YOUR OFFICE
DETAILED INFORMATION ON WHY
FUNDING IS NECESSARY AND WHILE
HUNDRED MILLION IS JUST THE TIP
OF THE ICEBERG. I WILL CALL YOU
ATTENTION ALSO TO. PAGE THREE OF
YOUR BELLY OLD REPORT TODAY. AT
THE ENDING IS THAT THEY HAVE NO
CONSENSUS AMONG RESEARCHERS AT
THE WHY THE JUVENILE ARREST RATE
HAS DECLINED- PROBATION HAD BEEN
LEFT OUT OF THAT CONVERSATION WE
KNOW WHY IT'S DECLINING. WE NEED
THE SUPPORT AND THE
INFRASTRUCTURE A TO CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE CARE PER SERVICES TO
OUR- YOU AND IF COUNTY THANK YOU
FOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
CALLING. NEXT PLEASE. NINE
THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS A
- I AM CALLING IN REGARDS TO
ISSUE FOR. I HAVE A LOT WHEN IT
GONE JERRY INCORPORATE AT
CALIFORNIA STATE PRISON SOLANO.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR DESTINY POINT
. GRANT ISSUES DEMOCRATS
CONNECTION. TOM STRUGGLE TO KEEP
IN TOUCH PROJECT DURING THE
PANDEMIC ANNUAL THE STAGGERED
APPOINTMENT. WE CAN THAT IF YOU
LOOK AT YOU CAN ALONG AT THE- WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
ALONGSIDE YOU SIXTY WITH THE V.
S. I'M SURE OUR ACCOUNT
CONNECTION- TIES. THANK YOU.
BETWEEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
. NINE THIRTY THREE LINE IS A
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO CAN HEAR
ME YES GO AHEAD. I ELMA ROBINSON
I'M EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA LAWYERS FOR THE ARTS
I FIRST OF ALL I WANTED TO THANK
ABC R. LEADERSHIP AND THE
LEGISLATURE CONTINUING TO
SUPPORT ARTS PROGRAMS IN
COLLECTIONS AS A VERY VALUABLE-
METHODOLOGIES FOR REHABILITATION
- IN TWENTY TWENTY AFTER THE
GOVERNOR EXPRESSED IN IT I'M
SORRY UP I'M SORRY WE'RE ALL
WE'RE AT THAT WERE ALLOWING THE
THIRTY SECONDS. APPRECIATE YOU
CALLING IN- AND WE'RE GONNA MOVE
ON- IF THE FURTHER THE NEXT A
PRACTICE. IF YOU COULD JUST TELL
US THE ISSUE BECAUSE WE NEED TO-
WERE SUPPOSED TO LEAVE BY TWELVE
BOMB IF YOU COULD JUST TELL US
QUICKLY THE ISSUE. AND THAT WE
NEED TO MOVE ON. NO OKAY TWENTY
NEXT PLEASE OPEN BECAUSE- THE
SANTA CLARA CA HELLO CALLING
REGARDS TO ISSUE NUMBER ONE WANT
TO CONCUR WITH COMMENTS MADE
PREVIOUSLY ACCORDING THE HUNT
MILLION DOLLAR. AND EXPECTED
DEEP NEED FOR THAT TEN. THAT
YOUTH AND COUNTY K. ARE ARE
RECEIVING SUPPORT CONSERVATIVES
THAT THEY NEED. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR CALLING APPRECIATE NEXT
PLEASE. NINE EIGHTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS ELIZABETH FRASER I'M
A MEMBER OF SHOWING UP FOR
RACIAL JUSTICE BAY AREA AND
MEMBER ORGANIZATION OF
CALIFORNIANS UNITED FOR
RESPONSIBLE BUDGET OR CURB
CHANGES APPOINTED TO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DOES NOT
INCLUDE A COMMITMENT TO CLOSING
ADDITIONAL STATE PRISON. URBAN
CALLING FOR THE CLOSURE AT EIGHT
ADDITIONAL PRISONS OVER THE NEXT
FIVE YEARS I HOPE THIS COMMITTEE
WILL CAN TO HOLD HEARINGS ON THE
ISSUE COMMIT TO A COULD CLOSURE
AND NAME OF HEALTH PUBLIC STATE
AND THE COURTS. EACH IN ADDITION
TO THAT I HOPE THAT- ON THERE
WILL ALSO BE AN EXTENSIVE LABOR
TRANSITION PLAN IN PLACE BUT IT
COULD BE AS NAMES FOR CLOSURE
FOR KEEP LIVING IN PRISON HOUND
FOR PEOPLE. JOB TV ARE AN IMPORT
BRING PEOPLE WHO BEING RELEASED
FROM PRISON I HOPE THAT AS IS AN
ISSUE THE COMMITTEE TAKE UP HERE
I LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH YOU
TO FIND A DURABLE POWER FORWARDS
TO CLOSE MORE PRESENT THANK.
NEXT PLEASE. FIND SEVENTY LINE
IS A PLEASED AHEAD. HELLO NAME
IS RETIRE AND- MY LOVE CENTER
THAT STATE PRISON. YOU HAVE BEEN
VERY HELPFUL- THANK FOR THIS THE
BILL WITH FAMILY VIDEO BY IN
BEEN VERY WOULD BE S. IS X. ALSO
EMAIL WHICH IS BUT STILL HAVEN'T
GET OUT OF THIS IS REGULAR. OKAY
YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
STICKING TO THE THIRTIES. NECK
PLEASE- IF YOU ARE. LONGER THE
THIRTY. I'M SORRY TELL YOU IN
ADVANCE BUT WE'RE GOING TO CUT
YOU OFF SO PLEASE STICK TO YOUR
NAME ORGANIZATION AND THE ISSUE
THANK YOU NEXT. NINE EIGHTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I THINK YOU CHEN MEMBERS
DEFENDED IMMINENT POLICY
ADVOCATE WITH GREAT AND CHILD
AREBEING CALIFORNIA AGAIN
APPRECIATE THE CHAIR INCLUDING
FOR ADDING IS SUPPORTED IN
CRAPPIE IMPORTANT FAMILY
CONNECTION UNDER THE PATIENT. CO
ALL THE COMMON THREE THE FAMILY
UNITY COALITION ADEQUATELY
ABBOTT CONCORD IN CATEGORICALLY
BEING COLLECTED TWENTY
QUESTIONS- OF WHAT- SIGNIFICANT
BARRIER NOT DEPEND YOU SEE OUR
PEOPLE YOU. ALTHOUGH I CAN JAIL
AND I THINK AND THE TRAUMA NOT
BEING ABLE TO CONNECT WITH MY
BROTHER WALKING THE QUESTION
CENTROLEGAL AND THEN AT
LANCASTER SPOKE REALLY URGENTLY
. TO ACT THE FAMILY. VISITATION
DURING THE PANDEMIC AND ALL
COMPUTER DROP COMPARED TO CATCH
UP AT THE END OF THE DAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK. YOU NEXT. MY
YOUR LIFE IS OPEN PLEASE GO.
HELLO MY NAME IS FUELING MARKET
I AM A PART OF THAT COULD
JUSTICE ORGANIZATION CALLED. LOS
COUNTY I AM ON THE TOP FIVE
BUDGET. TWENTY OKAY. I'M NOT A
FAN OF THE- READ REINVESTED THAT
MONEY IN OUR INDIVIDUAL
COMMUNITIES THE GOVERNOR BUDGET
DOES NOT A COMMITMENT TO CLOSE
THE CASE ALL THREE NUMBERS. I'M
HOPING THAT YOU'RE COMMITTEE
UNDERSTAND THAT BUT THE
COMMUNITY OF CALIFORNIA ONE MUST
PERSON THAN YOU ARE EMERGING THE
- THANK. NEXT. MY NINETY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO OUT. HI MY
NAME IS DIANA CREWS- I'M ABOARD
MY WITH TRADING TRIGGER COULD
ORGANISE A AND IF MAN TO THE
AND- LOVED. I'M ADDRESS ITEM TEN
I URGE ALLEGE TO REALLY DEEP
INTO CITIES ARGUE LOOK A FUNDS
FOR LAW. LAW ARE INCREASE DUE TO
THE FOURTH GRACE OF THE JET
POPULATION INDIVIDUALS WITH
OTHER INDIVIDUAL CORE IN
PROTECTIVE CUSTODY SEARCH FOR
SCHOOL INTEGRATION THERE
CREATING MASSIVE BY JOHN
BEILEIN'S IN TODAY'S YARDS. AND
WE THANK YOU VERY MUCH REGARDED
IT AND A THAT COME ABOUT WITH A
BECAUSE MY OWN A AMENDMENT RIGHT
WE ARE CALLING YOU KNOW AND-
HOPEFULLY AND. WE HAVE NEXT
UPDATE HARD TO ON A- THREE DAY
VISIT BUT THERE. IS ONLY TWO
BASED ON THE CALL. THANK YOU SO
MUCH YOUR TIME. NEXT PLEASE. MY
NINE FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS CHRISTY
FROM SANTA BECAUSE THE LETTER
CONTAINS KERR MEMBER AND
PROVIDER OF HARM ISSUE NUMBER
THREE I WOULD LIKE TO UP WITH
THE 200-407-0019 DEATH CARCERI
PEOPLE APPEAR TO BE A PERMANENT
VIOLATION AND DELIVERED IN. HERE
HAS DONE WE NEED REPLACING I'M
PRETTY CLOSE RIGHT NOW EIGHTEEN
POINT SIX BILLION DOLLAR
COMMERCIAL SPENDING IS NOT A
BLUEPRINT FOR CALIFORNIA THAT
COULD HELP. TWENTY FOUR HOURS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. PUBLIC
COMMENT SIDE. INITIALLY
LAWMAKERS ADDITION FOR THE
CLOSURE THE PARKWAY PIPE. TWENTY
FIVE. DEGREE BILLION BECAUSE
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT PART DOES
PLEASE THANK DROP A COMMUNITY
BANK SOLUTIONS FOR HEALTH AND
SAFETY AND THE ONLY WAY YOU'RE
BY CREATE THANK HAVE A GOOD. I'M
SO MR MODERATE. WE CUT FOLKS OFF
WHEN I- SO IN THE WE'RE GOING
EACH ONE GOING THROUGH TIME I'M
SORRY NET ONE NOTE PARTICIPANT
THANK YOU. NINE EIGHTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS A PLEASE AHEAD. HI I'M
CALLING THE COUNCIL. THE
COALITION PROGRAM UNIT I HAVE A
LOVED ENCOURAGE TRADE AT KERN
VALLEY AND JUST REITERATING THAT
THE B. S. A. ISSUES CONTINUE
IT'S EXTREMELY FRUSTRATING IT'S
BEEN ONGOING FOR MONTHS- I'M I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEES
THAT ENGAGEMENT ON THE SUBJECT
OF THIS OCCASION AND FAMILY
CONNECTION AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH AT THE STATE TO
FIX THESE ISSUES BUT- THANK YOU
I REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS THANK YOU NEXT
PARTICIPANT PLEASE. NINE ONE OH
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'M NAME IS ED IN
PROGRESS I'M CALLING BEHALF
GIVEN DIALOGUE AND ACTION TOO
MANY BASED ORGANIZATION
PROVIDING IN PERSON PROGRAMMING
AND A MEMBER OF TRANSFORMATION
PRESENT LOCAL I'M CALLING
REGARDING ISSUE SIX TERRORIST HM
THAT SOME PROGRAMS LIKE OURS
WHICH HELP DISCORDANT. A PEEP
OKAY POLICE SOMEBODY ENTRY
ACTIVITY THE PRISON POPULATION
WHILE ENSURING COMMUNITY SAFETY
AND WELL BEING THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. NEXT
PLEASE. MY ONE HUNDRED YOUR LINE
IS OPEN FOR GO AHEAD. CRISTINA
MORE FROM REVOLUTION WE ARE
TRANSFORMING IMPRISONED
WORKGROUP MEMBER I RESPECTED
PRIMERICA SHARED BY DIFFERENT
THEY WERE SUPPORTING I ITEM
NUMBER SIX YOUR PROVIDE
INVALUABLE SERVICES AND WE NEED
MORE FUNDING THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
CALLING NEXT PLEASE. NINE NINETY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO DELANEY GREENER
WITH THE UC BERKELEY SCHOOL
CLOBBERED RESEARCH RESTITUTION
VICTIM COMPENSATION IN
CALIFORNIA I'M CALLING TO ASK
THAT THE COMMITTEE OPPOSE AGENDA
ITEM. THE SERVICES FOR BY THE
OFFER INTO TO BUY CONTRAFECT AND
LEADING AND CREATING VICTIM
LOCATION AND IDENTIFICATION
PURPOSES WITH ACTUAL DELIVERY OF
COMPETITION CRIME SURVIVORS
WHICH IS DONE BY THE EPA. PLEASE
CONSIDER INSTEAD THAT THE THREE
MILLION DOLLARS COULD BE USED TO
SELL FIFTEEN HUNDRED ADDITIONAL
VICTIM COMPENSATION CLAIMS ARE
PROVIDE ONE POINT FIVE
ADDITIONAL TRAUMA RESEARCH
CENTER GRANT. INVEST IN FAMILIES
NOT THE DC ARE STOPPING
EXTENSION EXPANSION THANK YOU SO
MUCH APPRECIATE YOU CALLING IN
THANK. YOU NEXT PLEASE. NINE ONE
THREE YOUR MIND IS OPEN GO AHEAD
. HI MY NAME IS MARIA MARTIN I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE PLACE
ARE GREAT. AND I JUST WANT TO
ECHO ALL EVERY OTHER FAMILY
MEMBERS WHO CALLED ON ISSUE
NUMBER FOUR THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. NINE ONE OH FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS A LAWYER AND I AND I AM A
SYSTEM IMPACT A WIDE. AND I JUST
WANTED TO SAY THAT EVERYTHING-
EVERYTHING THAT WAS GIVEN HERE
TODAY- IN. IN ALL VERY WELL PUT
TOGETHER HOWEVER IT SEEMS LIKE
THE DVR- FAILED TO DELIVER- WHEN
IT IT WAS DISCUSSED AS FAR AS
HAVE THE DEPLOYMENT I DON'T KNOW
IF- YOU GUYS ARE AWARE PLEDGE-
TABLETS ARE. NOT IN SCHEDULED TO
BE DEPLOYED- A LOT OF THEM GO
INTO TWELVE NINETEEN TWENTY
TWENTY THE END OF THIS YEAR AND-
I THINK THAT- THANK YOU FOR
PROVIDING ANYMORE BUDGET. THANK
YOU THE MORE OVERSIGHT AND THANK
YOU SO MUCH SHOULD BE THANK YOU
I APPRECIATE YOU WE MUST MOVE ON
TO THE NEXT PARTICIPANT. NEXT
PLEASE. ONE ONE ALSO YEAR OF THE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO I'M MY
NAME IS BIANCA. BACK IT DIRECTOR
AT WORK RIGHT RIGHT ORGANIZATION
WORKS TO PARK- OF IT AND THE
IMPLICATION OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
INCARCERATED ARE LEFT- AND WE
WANTED TO- URGE AS- A
LEGISLATURE. CONSIDER PROVIDING
A LINE ITEM BUT YOU ARE TO
PROVIDE COMPLETELY FREE- BERMAN
COMMUNICATION ACROSS THE ENTIRE
SYSTEM WE DO UNDERSTAND RIGHT
NOW IF PROVIDING SEVENTY FIVE
MINUTES EVERY TWO WEEKS- THAT.
IS NOT. I'M IF I'M- A VISUALLY
OR- IN THE WAY THAT THAT
CONTRACT DRAWN THANK YOU SO MUCH
PREACH YOUR CALL. IN THANK YOU
NEXT. FIND ONE OF EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS MIGUEL GARCIA WITH
RECIDIVISM COALITION I WANT TO
SPEAK ON ITEM ONE JUVENILE
JUSTICE REALIGNMENT AS SOMEONE
WHO HAS SERVED ON THE PREVIOUS
REGIONAL YOUTH PROGRAMS. AND
FACILITY GRANT PROGRAM I'M WELL
AWARE OF THE LIMITED CREATIVITY
ART YET HE WAS GRANTED ENSURING
YOU THAT PROVIDED THE MOST
PROMISING REHABILITATED. HI THE
LEGISLATURE TO TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION THE L. A. L.'S
REPORT THANK YOU HAVE A GREAT
DAY THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
CALLING. NEXT PLEASE. NINE ONE
TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD.
JENNIFER NEED GOOD AFTERNOON
DISTRICT ELEVEN THIRD SAN
FRANCISCO AN ALLY ORGANIZATION
OF CALIFORNIANS UNITED FOR A
RESPONSIBLE BUDGET OR CURB IN
REGARDS TO THE CDC OUR BUDGET WE
ARE UPSET TO LEARN THE GOVERNOR
USES BUDGET DOUBLES DOWN ON
CULTURAL SPENDING AT EVERY TURN.
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT CURBS
CALL FOR THE CLOSURE OF EIGHT
ADDITIONAL PRISONS IN FIVE
YEARS. LISA REPORTING SO MUCH
ABOUT THANK YOU APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS. THANK YOU FOR CALLING
NEXT PLEASE. NINE ONE TWELVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IF IT'S M. J. KEELING I'M
CALLING BECAUSE LIKE MY
DISAPPOINTMENT IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED EIGHTEEN POINT SIX
BILLION IN CARSHALTON IT'S NOT A
BLUEPRINT FOR CALIFORNIANS
FISCAL HEALTH. I BEEN FORTUNATE
TO WORK FROM FOLKS ARE CURRENTLY
. IN THE BIGGEST LAST NIGHT MY
CONVERSATIONS ARE THE MAJOR
INEQUITY OF RESOURCES COMMITTEE
OUR STATE. BILLION COULD GO A
LONG WAY TO CREATE GREATER
EQUITY TO PREVENT OTHERS FROM
HAPPENING AFTER THE QUALITY OF
THE CORPORATION DESCANT HELLO
THE LAKERS LIKE. THE JOB THE
PORTABLE HOW METAL CARE PROGRAM
THAT'S WHAT ABOUT THE OKAY.
THANK BY YOUNG AND- THANK YOU.
HELLO TO THE- THANK YOU NICK
PLEASE WE HAVE MORE. THERE WERE
. IN NINETEEN HUNDRED GOING.
OKAY OUR FINAL COMING COMES FOR
A LINE ONE LOS YOUR LINE IS A
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY IS AND
FROM RESISTANT. AND I WANT TO
THAT. AND GETS A- IN EIGHT POINT
BILL DOLLARS BUT FOR CULTURAL. I
CONSISTENTLY HEARD THIS
COMMITTEE FOR A DETAILED PLAN
FOR CRITICAL. AND I STRONGLY
AGREE WITH THAT. I HOPE THIS
COMMITTEE WILL LEGISLATE PDC
ARGUE CREATE A FIVE YEAR PLAN
CLOSE TEN STAYED OWNED PRESIDENT
INTEREST. TO THE FAILURE.
CONTINUED HARM AND CONTINUED
PUBLIC HEALTH CORRECT. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR CALLING. J- EVERY-
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION THANK
YOU TO ALL THE END OF. SUPPORT
IN OUR PUBLIC TEST TODAY WHETHER
OR NOT YOU WERE ABLE TO TESTIFY
YOU COULDN'T PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING. TO THE BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE OR VISIT
OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE VERY IMPORTANT
TO US. WHAT DO YOU HAVE A MINUTE
OR THIRTY SECONDS DOESN'T
MATTER. WE VERY MUCH TOOK NOTICE
OF YOUR TESTIMONY AND IT WILL
APPEAR ON THE OFFICIAL OR
HEARING RECORDS. THANK YOU AGAIN
WE APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION
THE SENATE BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW-
COMMITTEE A SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER
FIVE IS NOW ADJOURNED.